Wie komme ich auf diese Frage? Warum Trecker fahren?
Wir waren auf der Gamescom und haben dort viel Kurioses gesehen,
aber besonders bemerkenswert fand ich, dass es Landwirtschaftssimulatoren gibt
und dass die sich großer Beliebtheit erfreuen, dass diese Spiele auch kompetitiv wohl gespielt werden.
Zumindest wurden da irgendwelche Menschen angefeuert, die auf der Bühne live
mit dem Trecker durch kleine Dörfer gefahren sind, um Heu von links nach rechts zu befördern.
Ich war erstaunt. Bei Gaming denke ich als allererstes an diese sehr cinematografischen,
neuen Spiele oder auch an Autorennen und was es alles gibt.
Aber dass man diese Simulatoren jetzt ganz stark vertreten hat,
wir sprechen davon Riesenständen, die wirklich megagroß sind,
größer als manches anderes.
Wir laufen durch die Gamescon und uns fällt schon auf, das ist hier eine Spiele-Messung,
keine Buchmesse. Hier gibt's keine Bühnen, hier redet keiner irgendwas.
Es sind einfach nur Bildschirme ohne Ende und die Kids dürfen halt was testen.
Also es gibt gar kein reflektorisches Programm oder so.
Die einzigen Spektakel, die dann sind, man kommt bei Ubisoft vorbei,
also so wie ich's verstehe, ein sehr großer Verlag oder so was,
und da steht dann Lamborghini, weiß ich, ihre neuen Spiele.
Und man denkt so, oh, das fällt schon auf, hier wurde ein bisschen Platz geschaffen,
Plötzlich riesige Bühne, Landwirtschaftssimulator, ein ausgewachsener Traktor
mitten im Raum, das ist auch schon architektonisch, was den Messebau eingeht,
ein Highlight gewesen, der Landwirtschaftssimulator.
Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, was man da so sieht.
Aber auch LKW-Simulatoren und Busse, Nahverkehr.
Ja, man fährt, also man macht das, was in der Realität mitunter schwierig ist,
weil man im Stau steht oder Bus fahren will man eigentlich nicht.
Aber da kann man es dann machen.
Und wir hatten ja kompetente Hilfe mit dabei. Huma Nagarfi vom Corporate Therapy
Podcast, der auch selbst Gamer ist, konnte uns dann einiges erklären und sagte,
dass das ein Riesenphänomen sei und dass das viele Menschen abends spielen zur Beruhigung.
Und man kann auch einen Auftrag erfüllen. Man fährt eine Ladung von A nach B
und hat dann, wenn man so möchte, zumindest digital etwas geleistet.
Das Korn muss eingeholt werden. Meine spontane Idee war ja die von Enders Game.
Also da sitzen sehr viele junge Leute einfach zu Hause und fahren Trecker.
Und am Ende sind die aber wirklich irgendwo angeschlossen.
Weil wir haben ja die Bilder aus der Ukraine und so gesehen,
wo Landwirtschaft anders betrieben wird als hier. wo der Traktor einfach 1,7
Kilometer geradeaus fährt, wendet und wieder zurück.
Riesige Felder, wo es keinen Sinn macht, noch Personal mit dazu zu schicken,
weil da gibt's keine Hürden, keine Bachläufe, keine Bäume. Das fährt man einfach
nur auf und ab. Und dann hat man so ein...
Willst du das verknüpfen, also die Digitalität mit der Realität?
Eigentlich wie auch in diesem Film jetzt Gran Turismo, wo der.
Gamer, der sonst immer nur an seinem Simulator und seinem Rennsimulator im Kinderzimmer
saß, plötzlich dann tatsächlich realer Rennfahrer wird, aber man könnte es ja nochmal anders machen.
Also hier, man bleibt tatsächlich zu Hause, macht Homeoffice,
wenn man so möchte und bestellt aber tatsächlich ein Feld.
Ja, am Ende, es ist ja so, klar, man könnte jetzt diese Verantwortung,
das Feld abzuernten, wirklich jemandem übergeben, der dann aber denkt,
ne, der spielt dann so wie ich, da läuft lieber Amok in GTA.
Man könnte aber das Feld an 20 Leute vergeben und dann die Durchschnittssteuerung
ausrechnen und die dann wirklich weiterleiten, weil dann hast du die kleinen
Ausreißer, die dir das Spiel zerstören wollen, also das Feld ausgemärzt.
Und produktive Arbeit wäre geleistet.
Ohne dass es jemand merkt, das ist der Punkt für mich. Wie bei Endless Gaming.
Sobald man es ja als Arbeit macht, ist es ja Arbeit und dann möchte man es nicht
tun. Denn offenbar haben ja nicht alle Leute, die jetzt diese Simulatoren bedienen,
eigentlich den unglaublichen Traum, tatsächlich in die Landwirtschaft zu gehen
oder tatsächlich Buchfahrer zu werden.
Und damit hätten wir auch ein großes Problem gelöst. Ich vermute,
du hast den Clip nicht dabei, ich hab ihn auch nicht dabei, wie Özdemir sich
gegen den Mindestlohn in der Landwirtschaft ausspricht.
Da hast du es. Die Leute müssen arm bleiben, weil und so. Und dann machen wir
das Angebot, wie sie arm bleiben können, ohne dass es jemand mehr.
Ja, es ist wirklich perfide, dass gesagt wird, damit wir hier noch weiter Landwirtschaft
betreiben können, dürfen wir jetzt aber nicht den Mindestlohn anheben in der Landwirtschaft.
Denn dann sind wir ja nicht mehr konkurrenzfähig, wenn man darüber nachdenken
kann, naja, welches System hat man da eigentlich produziert, wo das so ist?
Und wieso muss eigentlich die deutsche Landwirtschaft, wenn es ja jetzt nur
um die eigenen Sachen geht, so konkurrenzfähig zum Weltmarkt sein? sein.
Deutschland braucht 750 Millionen getötete Tiere im Jahr.
Eine Produktion und wir sind großes Land 40 Prozent über den Eigenbedarf beim
Fleisch zum Beispiel. Ansonsten.
Geht's nicht in Deutschland offenbar. Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig verrückt.
Das Einzige, was wir ja nicht haben, ist der Gemüseanbau.
Das ist ja wetterbedingt. Aber selbst das rückt ja irgendwie zu uns ran.
Also ich habe mir ja die letzten Monate sehr wohlwollend verfolgt.
Das waren ja echt gute Sachen so insgesamt.
Aber dieses Statement habe ich irgendwie so nicht so ganz verstanden.
Naja, ich meine, wenn man sich einen Industriezweig anschaut,
man spricht ja immer noch so vom primären Sektor Landwirtschaft,
Aber der ist ja schon so tertiärisiert durch diese Hyperautomatisierung.
Da arbeiten ja eigentlich gar keine Leute mehr. 1000 Tonnen Getreide an einem
Tag in einer Mühle und da machen drei Ingenieure Schichtdienst und das war's.
Also warum man da überhaupt noch Lohnkosten? Es ist so ein bisschen wie diese Energiekosten.
Also ich meine klar, es gibt riesige Konglomerate, die dann diese riesigen Kochtöpfe
da im Ruhrgebiet und so. Und das kostet alles Energie.
Aber soweit ich das jetzt verstanden habe in der Diskussion,
Kein Unternehmen kommt über drei oder vier Prozent Anteil am verkauften Produkt an Energiekosten.
Also da kann es doch nicht so schwer sein, das einfach mal hinzukriegen.
Wie ist denn dein Gamescom-Fazit?
Also wie schon gesagt, ich finde es immer interessant, so Spaziergänge zu machen.
Das Ding ist aber, nach vier, fünf Stunden in den sechs Messehallen oder wie
es sind, ist es dann auch abgelaufen.
Also ich bin kein Gamer.
Man müsste dann selbst spielen. Sich aber auch lange anstellen.
Ja genau. Das ist eben echt ein Problem. Also man kommt jetzt nicht wirklich
nah ran, bedauert so ein bisschen die Jugendlichen, die glauben sie müssten
da jetzt mal nah ran und dann stehen sie da irgendwie so rum.
Die einzige kleine Abwechslung, die es ja gab, war die Rocket Beans Bühne.
Ja, da war ich ja noch am Stream zu Gast. Wen hast du angesprochen?
Michael Krogmann. Michael Krogmann, das ist ja wirklich ein Spektakeltyp,
ich folge ihm seitdem auf Instagram und ich sehe nur noch wie er da durch die
Hallen fliegt und von irgendwelchen Fans aufgefangen wird.
Also da ging es ordentlich zur Sache. Wir haben unseren kleinen Backstage Einblick bekommen.
Klar, wir machen ja auch irgendwie Podcasts, aber die kommen ja dann gleich
mit den Kinokameras, stellen die da reinweise auf und filmen sich da auf der
Bühne. Also ist ja schon mal ein anderes Level, muss ich sagen,
diese allgemeinen Gespräche über Games.
Casts auch noch mal auf das Niveau, ohne dass man sich gleich in die Tagesthemen verwandelt.
Aber gut, also in der Sicht. Ja, wir haben es jetzt einmal gesehen, würde ich sagen.
Es war sehr amüsant. Wir sahen sehr anders aus als die anderen Leute, die da waren.
Ja, ich glaube, wir sind ein bisschen aufgefallen. Du wurdest natürlich angesprochen
und zwar nicht nur, weil du Wolfgang Schmidt bist, sondern schon wegen der Klamotte.
Tatsächlich. Junge Gamer in schwarzen T-Shirts sprechen dich an und loben noch
mal dein italienisches irgendwas. Ich habe die Worte schon wieder vergessen.
Ja, der Stoff wurde gelobt. Manche dachten wahrscheinlich aber auch ich bin
Cosplayer aus irgendeinem, weiß ich nicht welchem Simulator ich aus rausgesprungen bin.
Ich fand es interessant insofern als es gesellschaftlich natürlich einiges widerspiegelt.
Beispielsweise gibt es ja auch so eine Jobmesse sage ich mal dort.
Rheinmetall ist dort vertreten und die Bundeswehr ist dort vertreten, der BND ebenfalls.
Das heißt, da sieht man schon, wie diese Gamifizierung natürlich ideologisch
sehr gut nutzbar gemacht werden kann für Aufrüstung etc.
Also das ist dann sehr beängstigend. Das ist nicht die Messe im Ganzen,
aber diesen Aspekt sollte man, glaube ich, nicht ganz übersehen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob wir jetzt durch den Haupteingang rein sind oder so.
Ich fand es schon auffällig, dass wir hier reinkommen und der allererste Stand
ist Bundeswehr, ESA, BND.
Also der Reihe nach.
Airbus inklusive Flugsimulatoren, Menschen in Uniformen, die dort Gespräche
und Unterschriften sich abgeholt haben für was auch immer, welchen Termin zu
sagen. Das ist schon eine Rekrutierungsmesse.
Ja und auch so einen komischen, ich fahre durch die Wüste und bin aber ganz
gut gepanzert, Auto das da noch rumsteht, wo ich mir auch wieder dachte,
klar die Bundeswehr hat es jetzt irgendwie geschafft Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zu ziehen.
Aber wir haben ja auch Pistorius gehört, wie er nochmal meinte,
naja, manche kommen schon mit falschen Vorstellungen.
Und da denke ich mir, ja klar kommen die mit falschen Vorstellungen. A.
Weil ihr die falschen Vorstellungen für Köpfe der jungen Leute setzt. B.
Ihr wollt die da ins Biwak stecken und die müssen da irgendwie marschieren und
Dienste erfüllen und vor morgens aufstehen und dann stellt ihr denen als allererstes
den Flugsimulator hin. Also das ist natürlich auch, naja.
Aber man sieht das ja auch bei den Politikern, ist ja auch alles offenbar zur Fiktion geronnen.
Marie Agnes Strack-Zimmermann erfüllte sich jetzt einen Lebenstraum,
wie sie es glaube ich nannte.
Sie ist mal jetzt mitgeflogen bei der Luftwaffe oder was weiß ich und sagte,
dann ist er wie bei Top Gun gewesen.
Also das bestätigt dann nochmal deine These, dass dieser Film dann vielleicht
doch ein bisschen problematisch ist, wo ich das noch sehr verteidigt habe,
wo ich denke, naja, aber man kann es ja im Kino genießen, Aber man bezieht das nicht auf die Realität.
Da hab ich wohl einige überschätzt in ihren Kompetenzen, wie sich herausstellt.
Sicherlich gibt's noch diesen Indie-Spielbereich, da sind wir nun mal so durchspaziert schnell.
Da müsste man sich auskennen oder jemand zur Hand haben, der wirklich sagen
kann, hier, die zwei, drei Dinge müssen wir spielen.
Das hat es so noch nicht gegeben. Man hat sehr viele VR-Brillen gesehen.
Das fand ich doch zumindest in einigen Arealen erstaunlich. Und was mich überrascht
hat, war die Retro-Game-Area.
Ich wusste, dass es so zwei, drei Zeitschriften gibt, das hatte ich mal im Kiosk
gesehen, dachte aber, das richtet sich an ein Publikum 40 plus,
also das noch die alten Nintendos oder Ataris oder wie die alle heißen können.
Aber was wir da gesehen haben, waren Kinder vor Röhrenfernsehern,
die dort diese alten Spiele gespielt haben.
Das heißt, dieser Wunsch nach Übersichtlichkeit, dieser Retro-Trend ist nicht
nur bei jenen, die sich noch tatsächlich erinnern können, sondern die Erinnerung
soll jetzt auch bei denen entstehen, die sie eigentlich gar nicht haben.
Die jungen Leute spielen das jetzt auch.
Ja, es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie weitreichend dieses, und ich meine es echt so...
Landkarten-Reichweite, einfach wie viele Leute spielen. Also wir kennen ja die
Zahlen größer als der Film und Dingsmarkt zusammen und so.
Aber es gibt wohl dieses Phänomen, dass man dann doch nicht mit der Zeit geht als Publikum.
So wie beim Film. Man fragt die 100-jährigen Filmkritiker, was sind die Lieblingsfilme?
Und die sind alle 80 Jahre alt, schwarz-weiß. Und man denkt sich so,
ja, aber es gab doch technischen Fortschritt und so weiter. Wird alles ausgeblendet.
Und da saßen ja Väter mit ihren Söhnen da, wo ich dachte, der Vater versucht
gerade seinem Sohn zu erklären, was die richtigen Computerspiele sind.
Und der Sohn sitzt so daneben und denkt, naja, gut, okay. Meinst du?
Ja, okay, das Phänomen mag es geben, aber ich hatte schon auch den Eindruck,
dass es, und mir haben das ja auch Leute bestätigt,
dass es tatsächlich auch bei einem jüngeren Publikum den Wunsch danach gibt,
wie es ja auch ein junges Publikum gibt, dass plötzlich Musik aus den 80er Jahren
hört, ohne dass die Eltern das gesagt haben.
Denn eher ist ja die Absetzbewegung zu den Eltern da. Wenn die Eltern es gehört
haben, werde ich es nicht tun.
Und hier, glaube ich, gibt es schon auch den Wunsch, dass es einfacher ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt mal das vergleiche mit dem, was wir dann noch beobachtet
haben, wir sind ja noch zu einem Event dann dort in einer Messehalle.
Und zwar wurde da ein Mobile-Game, also ein Spiel, das man auf dem Handy eigentlich
spielt, kompetitiv ausgetragen.
Es gab da zwei Teams, die waren da aufgestellt. Ich hab eine unglaublich laute
Moderation dazu. Und die haben ein Handyspiel gespielt.
Und dieses Handyspiel sah ja auch nicht wesentlich anders aus als das,
was Super Nintendo früher gemacht hat.
Das heißt, dieser Wunsch nach Übersichtlichkeit, das ist ja nicht alles Death
Stranding und solche unglaublich beeindruckenden Spiele, bei denen man sagen kann, ja, das ist schon.
Filmisch, sondern da sind ja Spiele, wo einfach sehr klobige,
sehr bunte Figürchen aufeinander losgehen und sich mit irgendwas bewerfen.
Und das wird da kompetitiv ausgetragen.
Und eigentlich hat sich dann doch nicht so viel gewandelt, wie man das vielleicht auch sagen kann.
Natürlich gibt es technische Innovationen beim Film und natürlich werden auch
Filmsprachen weiterentwickelt, auch wenn es ja in der Kunst nie so einen Fortschritt in dem Sinne gibt.
Aber wenn man sich sieht, sich ansieht, wie funktionieren eigentlich die wirklichen
Mainstream-Filme, ja, dann unterscheiden die sich auch nicht von diesen ganz
typischen Mainstream-Filmen der 30er Jahre in der Art, wie sie aufgenommen sind.
Es war aber so, dass ein T-Shirt in uns Richtung flog, ich es anzog.
Ich dann noch sah, alle anderen, die auch eins bekommen haben,
sind gleich in Ohnmacht gefallen, ausgerastet oder sind dem fliegenden Hemd entgegengesprungen.
Es kam durch Zufall in meine Hände geflogen. Ich hab's angezogen,
daraufhin haben wir ein Instagram-Foto gemacht, wo ich es anhabe,
daraufhin haben viele geschrieben, oh, Broz.
Nur dadurch wissen wir es, man guckt dann aber nach im App-Store.
6 Sterne, durchschnittliche Bewertung scheint recht.
Gut zu sein. Und das ist auch eine sehr valide Angabe, denn es sind sieben Millionen
Bewertungen, die das ergeben.
Bei sieben Millionen Bewertungen denke ich, okay, das sind dann 300 Millionen
Downloads allein auf iOS.
Also wir haben neue Welten kennengelernt und sie nicht verstanden.
Die Stimmung war da trotzdem ganz gut, fand ich.
Viele Zeichen, die wir nicht entziffern konnten.
Genau. Und na ja, ich kenn das so ein bisschen von Twitch.
Ich hab mich ja vor Jahren, also 16, 17 so, abgelenkt, indem ich einfach Redaktionsschluss
schrieb und dann nachmittags erst mal zwei Stunden King of Thalion auf Twitch
geguckt habe. Der hat natürlich Destiny und so was gespielt, Destiny 2.
Was für mich bedeutete, okay, ich kann jetzt an dieser Spielewelt,
die ja schön aussieht, teilnehmen, ohne selbst spielen zu müssen.
Also quasi wie so ein Film.
Nur wenn ich dann auf Twitch gucke, was ist denn grad populär?
Leute gucken zu, wie jemand GTA oder Destiny 2 oder was auch heute so Fortnite gespielt wird.
Aber 30, 40, 50, 60.000 gucken zu, wenn einfach nur auf Vogelperspektive von
oben auf die Spiele geschaut wird, unter anderem Ballstars, wo einfach nur Sachen
hin und her fliegen und man sich wirklich einarbeiten muss, bevor man es versteht.
Also ich finde es auch beeindruckend irgendwie, dass man da,
klar am Ende, nach einer Woche hat man es irgendwie drin und wenn man es selber
Spiel sowieso, aber es widerspricht.
Allen auch politisch angegliederten Diskussionen zum Thema Killer Games oder so was,
ja, also dieser ganze ästhetische Aspekt wurde komplett rausgezogen,
um sich auf die Taktik konzentrieren zu können und das finde ich schon erstaunlich,
also in der Hinsicht hat man wieder mal gesehen, dass auf der größten Bühne
das visuell kleinste, aber taktisch spielerisch größte Spektakel stattfindet,
das ist schon erstaunlich.
Ja, es gibt eine große Sehnsucht nach dem Analogen auf so einer doch sehr digitalen
Messe. Das kann man daran sehen, dass unglaublich viel Merch verkauft wird.
Also vor allem irgendwelche Stofftierchen für 20 Cent produziert, für 40 Euro verkauft.
Man will etwas mitnehmen, auch diese ganzen Karten, die es gibt.
Das ist ja nicht nur Pokémon, sondern viele, viele andere Kartenspiele gibt
es online, die man spielen kann, beziehungsweise auf dem Handy.
Gibt es ganz viele solche Quartettspiele, im Prinzip sind das ja,
wo man irgendwelche Karten sammelt.
Und die gibt es aber dann auch noch mal in analoger Form und die kann man dann
dort auch tauschen. Da treffen sich dann Leute, die das dann tauschen wollen
und dass man so etwas mitnehmen kann, das ist wohl so ein großes Versprechen dieser Messe.
Und ich hab dann auch nochmal drüber nachgedacht, warum geht man eigentlich auf eine Messe?
Gut, wir wollten jetzt mal ein bisschen diesen Zeitgeist inhalieren,
aber warum geht man eigentlich auf eine Buchmesse, wenn man jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Autor ist oder so?
Und mir ist es nie so ganz klar geworden. Ich war vor ein paar Jahren nochmal
auf der Frankfurter Buchmesse und dann ging ich da so zwei Stunden durch und
hatte noch ein Treffen mit Freunden.
Und als dieses Treffen dann zu Ende war, wurde mir plötzlich dieser Irrsinn
klar, warum bin ich eigentlich hier? Ich habe ja jetzt nicht mit einem Verlag
zu verhandeln oder was? Und bin sofort gefahren.
Bin sofort ins Museum. Und hier ist es auch so ein Nichtereignis zugleich,
also man hat dieses Wahnsinns-Event, aber dann stehen Leute,
Eine Stunde Schlange, um sich mit einem Lamborghini fotografieren zu lassen
oder um irgendwelche Bälle in einen Korb zu werfen, weil RTL irgendein neues Spiel bewirbt.
Aber den großen Unterschied will ich nochmal markieren. Die Buchmesse gibt dir
jenseits der Bücher nochmal ihre Autoren. Einfach.
Dass man sie treffen kann, dass man sagt, ah ja.
Größeren Buchmesseständen, die du überall findest, sitzen einfach die ganze
Zeit irgendwelche Leute, reden mit irgendwelchen Leuten, und es wird so für
fünf, sechs Leute zuhörbar verstärkt.
Das heißt, man kann sich auf der Buchmesse ein Programm zusammenklicken für
sich, und dann sieht man noch mal alle, weil irgendwie dann doch viele da sind.
Und das find ich erstaunlich.
Du gehst auf die Gamescon nicht alleine, so ein paar Twitcher,
die dann so nur noch mit ihrem Publikum kommunizieren und ansonsten völlig frei
da rumschweben, sieht man auch.
Aber ansonsten hast du diese kleinen Krüppchen, alle setzen sich ihre Öhrchen
auf und die verbringen dann aber auch den Tag in diesen Krüppchen.
Die stehen gemeinsam an, die spielen gemeinsam, die reden dann gemeinsam wahrscheinlich
darüber, was sie gerade gespielt haben und wie auch immer.
Aber es gibt keine weitere, keine Ahnung, darüber hinaus.
Also da ist kein Spieleentwickler, da ist keine Bühne, wo noch immer jemand
ein Gespräch führt oder sonst. Da ist vielleicht nochmal das Arbeitsamt oder
das NRW Forum oder so und erklärt nochmal Irgendwie, welche Jobchancen die Spielebranche breithält.
Aber das war es dann auch. Also dass da so gar kein Gespräch,
keine Reflektion, kein Nichts stattfindet.
Keine Intellektualisierung eigentlich.
Genau. Wenn man einfach nur so von Spiel zu Spiel geht und das einfach mit seinen
Freunden in abgedunkelten Messehallen fand ich dann schon, keine Ahnung,
so ein bisschen ideenlos auch insgesamt.
Aber ja, also Rocket Beans, fand ich das interessant, die machen ein Action-Song.
Die machen aber auch Diskussionen, die sprechen ja schon über die Sachen oder
spielen dann übers Live und die treffen ja auch dann ihre Zuschauer,
also da gibt es ja tatsächlich den Mehrwert, der produziert wird, dass man sagt,
unsere Zuschauer, die sonst nur in digitaler Form sichtbar sind,
in Form von Klicks und Aufrufzahlen, die sind dann dort und können dann auch
mit den Einzelnen ins Gespräch kommen, aber bei vielen Sachen dachte ich,
gut, Netflix hat da einen Megastand gehabt.
Also das war der größte, glaube ich, von allem, was man gar nicht dachte,
aber die haben nicht irgendwie mit Spielen. Ja, die kommen dann mit Witcher
und so, weil sie halt eine Serie drauf gemacht haben. Die kommen mit Serien
und man geht durch riesen Pub-Aufsteller durch.
Und dann denke ich mir, ja, da haben die Messearchitekten einiges umgesetzt,
aber warum soll ich jetzt da durchgehen?
Da war einfach mal wieder Budget zu viel. Naja, ich hab jedenfalls schon seit
Jahren, weil ich mir Rocketbrains.de als Domain geholt, wir können nächstes
Jahr einen Rocketbrains Stand aufbauen.
Und dann sitzen wir da und führen mal ein Gespräch über Spiele für die Leute dort. Aber gut.
Wir machen das, ja.
So, genug. Wir fühlen uns ja schon wie Boomer, die über irgendwas reden.
Nein, nein, nein. Im Übrigen ist das ja nicht nur ein ganz junges Publikum da.
Das kann man ja auch nicht sagen. Also es ist sehr durchmischt,
wirklich sehr durchmischt in jeder Hinsicht. Das fand ich noch ganz interessant.
Aber wir haben jetzt diesen Ausflug in die digitalen Welten unternommen.
Und wir können noch kurz auf den Salon schon mal verweisen, was wir lesen werden.
Wir hatten es im Teaser ganz kurz angekündigt, wollen es aber noch mal sagen.
Es geht um die Zukunft, nämlich um die Frage, was wir der Zukunft schulden.
Wir lesen den Bestseller von William MacAskill, der nun auf deutsch erschienen
ist, bei Siedler herausgekommen.
Und dieses Buch ist …,
Ein Werk des Longtermism, das heißt,
hier versucht der Philosoph MacAskill auszubreiten,
warum wir nicht nur an die nächste Generation denken müssen,
an die Kinder oder vielleicht noch an die Enkel, sondern wir müssen an die nächsten
hunderttausend Jahre denken, wie können wir die Menschheit retten.
Und daraus leitet sich nicht nur eine eigene Ethik, sondern auch eine eigene
Politik ab. Ich halte diese Philosophie für durchaus gefährlich.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie die Argumente dafür sein werden.
Ich frage mich, inwieweit diese Denkweise vielleicht auch schon zum Teil die Politik prägt.
Und ob hier nicht der alte Satz von Carl Schmitt gilt, wer Menschheit sagt,
will betrügen. Denn darum geht es, wir retten die Menschheit.
Aber es geht jetzt nicht um dich als Individuum.
Sondern vielleicht musst du auch geopfert werden, um die Menschheit gerettet zu werden.
Ja, wir werden das kritisch behandeln. Also ich glaube, das wird jedenfalls
ein Buch sein, über das man sprechen muss, wenn man über die neuen Zwanziger
spricht, weil diese Strömung wahnsinnig verbreitet ist.
Jemand wie Elon Musk schätzt dieses Buch, aber auch jemand wie Stephen Fry oder Rutger Bregmann.
Ein kühnes Buch, sagt Stephen Fry, voller Vorstellungskraft.
Wir sind sehr gespannt darauf.
Ich habe es noch nicht gelesen. Ich bin gespannt. Ich bin erstaunt,
dass du es schon da hast, denn das kam ja irgendwie erst gestern oder so.
Ja, Buchhandlung.
Das ist erstaunlich. Meins ist noch nicht da. Es wird heute erst digital zugestellt. Super.
Der Salon ist wie immer buchbar über Steady, das ist auch die präferierte Plattform.
Außerdem ist er auch buchbar für die, die schon bei Patreon sind,
über Patreon und man kann ihn direkt über Apple auch buchen,
auch das ist eine Möglichkeit, also für die Apple Kunden, die es da ein bisschen leichter haben wollen.
Ansonsten findet man alle nötigen Informationen auf der Seite neue20er.de.
Da sind die Buttons, da kommt man zu den einzelnen Seiten.
Man kann, wenn man diesen Podcast über Spotify hört, auch über diesen Button,
der dort angezeigt ist, zu dem Salon gelangen kann, es dann dort über Steady
buchen. Also der Wege sind viele, es ist ziemlich einfach.
Und noch mal der Hinweis ist, lohnt sich in diesem Monat doppelt den Salon zu abonnieren.
Denn wir sehen uns ja noch live in Frankfurt in der KS im September und werden
dann einen bunten Strauß mitbringen.
Du hast schon ein bisschen angedeutet, wohin es geht, aber wir wollen da noch
nichts verraten. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall amüsant, dass wir das aufgreifen.
Ich habe auch schon die eine oder andere Idee.
Das heißt, der Live-Salon, der dann so etwa zwei Stunden gehen wird,
der ist auch dann mit im Abo enthalten. Den kann man dann auch im September hören.
So is it. So, wir nähern uns langsam unseren heute wahrscheinlich sehr politischen Monatsrückblick,
indem wir ganz kurz den Namen Hubert Aiwanger fallen lassen,
nicht um irgendwelche Clips zu spielen oder die Medien in die Hand zu nehmen.
Ethische Diskussion zu führen, was darf man einem Schüler 35 Jahre später noch
anhängen und so weiter und so fort.
Aber ohne dass wir jetzt einen Clip haben, denn ich glaube, den hat jeder im Ohr.
Gestern kam ja Hubert Aiwanger und dachte, er macht mal eben auf dem Parkplatz,
ruft er seinen eigenen Freispruch aus, indem er verkündet, er ist seitdem er
erwachsen ist, kein Antisemit mehr. Ja.
Ich hab das dazu gelesen, hab gedacht, mhm.
Hab ich den Clip gesehen, hab gedacht, ah ja.
Es ist wirklich irre, gestern schon mit Kumpels rumgescherzt.
Wir haben jetzt wirklich sieben Jahre, acht Jahre, seit 2015 über Donald Trump gelacht.
Haben ihn für beratungsresistent, bescheuert, nicht in der Lage,
vor der Kamera einen klaren Satz zu sagen.
Stefan Nickemeyer hat die Weltwoche jetzt mal verlinkt
oder ein bisschen aufgearbeitet, wie die Weltwoche versuchte,
ein Gespräch zwischen Donald Trump und Tucker Carlson, das auf Englisch geführt
wurde, auf Deutsch zu übersetzen und sie haben es einfach wörtlich auf Deutsch
übersetzt und es ist das Absurdeste, was man jemals gelesen hat.
Und dann sieht man aber Hubert Aiwanger, der ganz klar und für alle leicht verständlich
sich nicht eine Sekunde hat beraten lassen, nicht eine Sekunde darüber nachgedacht
hat, sondern einfach so ein Statement rausgibt.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, ey, wir dürfen auch nicht mehr über Donald Trump einfach
so lachen. Wir müssen das Schicksal einfach hinnehmen. Ja, in Amerika wird vielleicht
Donald Trump wieder regieren und wir werden vielleicht, Markus Söder weiß ja
gerade auch noch nicht genau, wie er das Zauberwerk verbringen soll,
aber natürlich nach dem 8.10.
Keine CSU-Grüne-Koalition führen, sondern irgendwie sich mit diesen Freien Wählern
weiter durchwurschteln, weil
sie ihm wirklich zu Füßen liegen und jetzt liegt ihm dieser Brocken da.
Also sozusagen diese zwei Männer, die das jetzt irgendwie hinbiegen müssen,
die nächsten Wochen, es ist wirklich absurd.
Ich muss auch sagen, dass ich so fürchterlich, also ich finde es eigentlich
alles so ekelhaft, dieses Ganze.
Es ist so widerwärtig, dass man sich auch gar nicht damit beschäftigen will.
Also ich lese nur Überschriften dazu, die ich so mitbekomme,
aber ich lese keinen längeren Artikel dazu, weil es mir alles so unter aller
Würde ist, dass ich eigentlich fassungslos bin und so schockiert darüber,
dass man solche Zustände hat.
Also ich bin ja nun niemand, der von der Regierung besonders viel erwartet oder
so, aber dass so ein gewisses Mindestmaß an Form und Anstand eingehalten wird.
Ja oder IQ einfach. Ja oder IQ.
Das ist mir wirklich in einem sehr sehr hohen Maße zu wider.
Und ich wollte es eigentlich nur aufgreifen, weil ich gestern einen ganz fantastischen
Tweet dazu gelesen habe.
Holger Bleich hat kurz gefragt, kennt eigentlich jemand jemanden,
dessen Weltbild und politische Grundhaltung sich grundlegend verändert hat,
seitdem er 17 Jahre alt und Jahrgangskollege im Gymnasium war?
Also mir ist das in all den Jahrgangstreffen nie begegnet. Hashtag Eiwanger.
Und wir kennen ja diesen alten Spruch.
In der Jugend ist man irgendwie links und dann wirft man irgendwie Steine oder
macht irgendwas und so und dann wird man irgendwann Bundesminister und dann
wird man Innenminister oder Außenminister und dann ist man die rechteste Socke
überhaupt. Also so im üblichen Spektrum.
So und das kennen wir. Nur wenn jemand sein politisches Denken schon als Hubert
Allwanger beginnt und dann uns 35 Jahre später sagen will, ne seit meinem Erwachsenenalter
bin ich kein Antisemit mehr.
Da ist doch wirklich Hopfen und Malz verloren. Also das ist doch wirklich. Ja, in jeder Hinsicht.
Also politisches Bewusstsein ist, ja, also man kann da auch was sagen.
Ganz erstaunlich, was so passiert. Na ja, kommen wir zu den Kindern.
Ein weiteres Trauerspiel.
Es ist wirklich, es ist, also ich finde keine Worte, ich habe auch versucht,
die Clips, die wir gleich gucken werden dazu, irgendwie in der Reihenfolge,
irgendwie einen roten Faden und ich dachte mir, Wir hauen den ersten Block chronologisch
so raus, wie er in den Nachrichten lief.
Und machen uns so spontane Gedanken dazu. Ich verspreche aber,
es werden größere Bögen geschwungen.
Die Brücken werden auch ans andere Ufer angeschlagen.
Wir kommen auf Murice Höfgen und Fradscha und so weiter, ein paar Kommentatoren
zurück, die uns das noch mal einhorten.
Ich war nur für mich, ich komme jetzt aus zwei Wochen Urlaub.
Diese Urlaubszeit habe ich auch ein bisschen verbringen wollen.
Die Leseprobe für die Verlage für das neue Familienbuch zu schreiben.
Ich war da ein bisschen abgelenkt mit anderen, sehr viel schöneren Schreibtätigkeiten.
Und ja, sitze jetzt halt so da, kam so aus dem Urlaub zurück,
hab gedacht, okay, ich hab nur eine halbe Seite geschafft.
Ich setze mich jetzt mal hin und mach's. Und dann kommt aber Lisa Paus und sagt,
nee, hier Veto, kein Wachstumschancengesetz.
Und man denkt sich so, ja klar, kein Veto, also klar Veto, wenn da keine Kinder
vorkommen, aber es um Wachstumschancen geht in Deutschland. Also eins plus eins ist Nummer zwei.
So und dann Scholz aber indifferent wie immer. Und dann kochte das einfach so
eine Woche durch, bis sie sich dann jetzt auf diesen Kompromiss da geeinigt haben.
Und entweder ist es ein mega Zufall, dass ich einfach gerade jetzt sowieso schon
im Kopf vorbereitet, mit diesem Thema beschäftigt war.
Oder ich übertreibe einfach gerade in meinem Kopf, weil mir selber die Maßstäbe
verloren gehen. und ich denke mir, ist das wirklich gerade in der Zeit,
diese Schicksalswoche in Deutschland
gewesen, die uns demografisch einfach wirklich in den Abgrund führen.
Also wir haben 18 Millionen Leute, die in Rente gehen und 11 Millionen kommen
nach die nächsten 13 Jahre.
Dazu ist ja mein Buch da. Ich habe es ja selber geschrieben und ich kann trotzdem
nicht glauben, wenn ich jetzt diese Woche sehe, wie sehr wir unsere Ressourcen
da verschwenden, wie grottig dieses Gesetz ist.
Wir finden hier noch die Maßstäbe gerade, ja? Es ist nicht so,
dass wir euch erzählen, also diesen Monat und so, keine Ahnung.
In der Hinsicht, ich bin selbst ein bisschen sprachlos.
Weshalb wir ganz sacht und der Nachrichtenwoche folgend, einfach mal hier so 18.
August, wir sind also mitten im Monat, hören uns mal so eine Sendungseröffnung
an. Zu dieser Pause macht irgendwie ihr Wehton.
Viele Antworten lieferte sie heute nicht, Bis zum Monatsende soll die geplante
Kindergrundsicherung stehen, die Familienministerin Lisa Paus auf den Weg gebracht hat.
Sie fordert mehr Geld für Kinder, die von Armut bedroht sind.
Sie hat deswegen ihre Zustimmung zum Wachstumschancengesetz von FDP-Finanzminister
Lindner erst mal verweigert.
In den Tagesthemen der TNO lieferte sie viele Antworten nicht.
Ich höre daraus, sie hat viele Fragen aufgeworfen.
Das würde ich gleich mal kurz einschätzen wollen. Wir hören noch mal kurz im
heute-Journal, wie das da so klang.
Der Schlagabtausch in der Ampelkoalition geht munter weiter.
Die grüne Ministerin, die den Fehlstart der Regierung nach der Sommerpause ausgelöst
hatte, indem sie ein Gesetz des FDP-Kollegen kurzerhand blockierte,
legte heute noch mal nach.
Nach drei Tagen Kamerascheue beraumte Lisa Paus für den Nachmittag ein Pressestatement an.
Drei Tage nicht mit der Presse gesprochen, Da ist man schon kamerascheu,
da ist man schon kamerascheu.
Sie hat den Fehlstart verursacht, diese Regierung.
Also wir könnten eigentlich schon so weit sein wie Deutschland.
Ja genau, wir könnten schon so weit sein, aber jetzt haben wir schon wieder
hier so ein Veto und einen Fehlschlag und so weiter und der arme Scholz und
alle leiden und dieser Paus beantwortet gar keine Fragen. Ich frage mich dann
so ein bisschen, wir hatten das Schicksalsjahr 2020.
So, wir haben so ein Virus, die Regierung sagt, Kontaktsperre,
wir machen jetzt mal Betriebsschließungen, damit ihr nicht alle konsummäßig
da rumrennt und so weiter.
Und dann kommen die Vermieter und sagen, die Leute können ja meine Miete dann
gar nicht mehr bezahlen, seid ihr bescheuert? Und dann sagt die Bundesregierung
so, kein Problem, 200 Milliarden extra aushalten.
Dann haben wir dieses Schicksalsjahr 2022.
Ein Krieg vor unserer Haustür. Olaf Scholz, ohne das mit irgendjemandem abzusprechen,
steht im Bundestag und sagt 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr.
Alle so top, super Entscheidung. Die Opposition geht ans Rednerpult und sagt,
das ist unser Mann, wir sind dabei. Grundgesetzänderung, kein Problem.
So, wir haben grundsätzlich nur noch Schicksalsjahre, seit einem Jahrzehnt ungefähr,
in dem es einfach jedes Jahr, ohne dass man nochmal im Bundestag darüber spricht,
heißt, ja, so 100 Milliarden müssen für die Rente schon sein.
Wir müssen ja Zuschuss zahlen, jedes Jahr.
So, wir haben also Sonderhaushalte im dreistelligen Milliardenbereich,
weil Mieten nicht gezahlt werden.
Wir haben grundgesetz abgesicherte Vermögen von hunderten, also hundert Milliarden
für Krieg, Panzer und dergleichen.
Wir haben sowieso immer für die Alten, für die Älteren, weil die haben halt
nicht genug eingezahlt, so muss man es einfach sagen, deswegen ist der Bundeszuschuss
so hoch, auch dreistellige Milliardenbeträge.
Und dann kommt die Familienministerin und sagt, ich hätte gern zwölf Milliarden
für die Kinder, wir bezahlen fünf Milliarden Kindergeld, ich hätte gern nochmal
so zwölf Milliarden obendrauf, weil Kinder haben gut, jedes für das Kind und
wir haben nicht viele Kinder, brauchen eigentlich jedes.
Und dann kommt die Regierung, also alle außer sie und sagen,
ja wir brauchen Wachstumschancen, das ist ganz klar. Und sie so, ja aber die Kinder.
Und dann macht sie es mit einem Mal so ein, ja aber die Kinder Ausrufezeichen.
Das kann man für die nicht mal 10 Milliarden. Und dann kommen die Journalisten so... Ja, also, öh.
Das ist ja völlig, also sie lässt alle Fragen offen. Welche Fragen lässt sie
dann offen? 100 Milliarden hier, 100 Milliarden hier, 100 Milliarden hier und
dann fordert sie 10 Milliarden für die Kinder. Und dann plötzlich sind aber
ganz viele Fragen offen.
Welche Fragen sind denn da offen? Also es ist doch wirklich.
Und man kann das ja schön koppeln, Kinder wachsen ja auch, so ein Wachstumschancengesetz.
Das Wachstumschancengesetz 2015 kommen die Familien mit ihren Kindern aus Syrien
und so weiter. Jetzt ist 2023.
Es ist acht Jahre später. Wenn die damals eingeschult worden sind,
das sind jetzt neun Klässler.
Wenn die damals als fünf Klässler kamen, haben die ihr Abitur,
ihre Berufsausbildung, was auch immer. Wir haben doch, also selbst wenn man
sagt, ja Demografie, das läuft immer alles so lange, das braucht so ewig und
so weiter. Nee, das braucht gar nicht ewig.
Das ist ein Wimpernschlag. 2015 ist für alle, die älter sind als 30, gefühlt so wie gestern.
Nachrichtenlage gestern. Aber in Realität ist das eine ganze Kindheit.
Und es ist einfach nicht mehr zu verstehen, warum der Journalismus hier so kurzfristig,
dass dann drei Tage Schweigen schon als Arbeitsverweigerung gilt und so weiter.
Also es ist wirklich grotesk. Aber gut, wir gehen das weiter durch.
Die Pressesprecher und so weiter. Der langsame Auftritt der Protagonisten.
Wie einsam sich Politikerinnen in bestimmten Momenten fühlen.
Wie dünn sie selbst das Eis einschätzen, auf dem sie sich gerade bewegen.
Wie gefährlich es also womöglich...
Ich meine die Wortwahl, ne? Sie ist isoliert, sie ist auf dünnem Eis.
Gefährliche Wortwahlen stehen jetzt an. Das ist... also... ich verstehe das alles nicht.
Ja man müsste einfach mal dieses
Voice-Over machen bei der Kanzlerrede zur Aufrüstung. 100 Milliarden.
Da müsste man sagen, auf dünnem Eis bewegt er sich, eine große Gefahr geht da
ein und so weiter. Da müsste man einfach mal so darüber reden.
Gehört es auch hin, finde ich. Aber zwölf Millionen Kinder in Deutschland,
vier Millionen davon leben einfach in Armut und sie fordert für die,
also für jedes Kind rechnerisch und am Ende,
Was sie jetzt bekommen, sind 40 Euro pro Kind, ne? Diese Forderung,
überhaupt nur aufzustellen mit einem Veto bei einem anderen Gesetz,
das Wachstumschancengesetz heißt, zu verknüpfen, ist, sie isoliert sich,
sie ist auf dünnem Eis, gefährliche Wortwahl.
Wird auch deutlich, wenn sie Pressesprecher Sätze sagen lassen wie diesen.
Ich bitte um Verständnis, da wir das kurzfristig anberaumt haben,
dass es danach keine Zeit für Rückfragen geht.
Wir mussten das in den Kalender der Ministerin reinquetschen.
Deswegen, Frau Ministerin, bitte Ihr Statement.
So, und ich will gar nicht sagen, dass Lisa Post ... Klar, es ist ein Power-Move,
sich so dagegen zu stellen.
Und auch dem eigenen Partei, nicht dem Chef, aber dem eigenen Koalitionsinternen,
Oberst, Vizekanzler Habeck und Scholz vorher nicht Bescheid zu sagen.
Aber hier, finde ich, ist sie auch selber wieder so ein Opfer der Medien,
der ganzen Mediensache, Medienlage gewesen.
Diese Regierung arbeitet nun mal nicht im, wir sind ja eine Familie,
wir verstehen uns so gut oder was auch immer, sondern die arbeitet im Konfliktmodus
und das gestehen die sich selber nicht zu.
Ich finde, wenn man so einen Move macht, was fehlt denn dann noch an Restmood,
um dann einfach vor die Presse zu gehen und zu sagen, sorry,
aber wir sind hier nicht in der Lage das vernünftig zu klären,
deswegen gibt es hier leider von mir ein Veto.
Ich mache das über die formale Ebene. Das ist sozusagen das,
was auch im Angesichts des Bundespräsidenten und seiner Hoheit über die Verfahren
müssen, bitte regulär ablaufen.
Da bleibt das Menschliche leider auf der Strecke.
Ob sie dann noch hinterherschiebt, ich hasse die FDP oder nicht,
ist ja dann geschenkt so. Aber dass man es einfach offensiv macht,
statt sich hier so, sie hat leider wenig Zeit, deswegen heute keine Rückfragen.
Man muss dann einfach hingehen und sagen, müssen wir im Konflikt lösen.
Ich weiß aber, dass Sie nur Fragen zum Konflikt stellen, Mir geht's aber um
die Sache, deswegen keine Rückfragen. Punkt.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass die Presse keine einzige vernünftige Frage stellen würde.
Ja, genau. Warum diese Spielchen? Na gut. Scholz und Lindner reagieren.
Im Streit der Ampelkoalition über die geplante Kindergrundsicherung hat Bundeskanzler
Scholz die Kabinettsmitglieder zur Zurückhaltung aufgerufen.
Beim Tag der offenen Tür der Bundesregierung appellierte der SPD-Politiker,
die Diskussion nicht öffentlich auszutragen, solange das Gesetz noch in Arbeit sei.
Was ist das für ein Appell? Sie hat drei Tage geschwiegen. Hat sie es richtig
gemacht, nämlich nicht in der Öffentlichkeit ausgetragen oder nicht?
Auch da völlige Unentschiedenheit.
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner erklärte, er wolle die Kindergrundsicherung inhaltlich neu ausgestalten.
Von Kinderarmut betroffen seien
vor allem Familien, die seit 2015 nach Deutschland eingewandert seien.
Diesen Zusammenhang müsse man in den Blick nehmen, so Lindner.
Das ist ja das, was er dann dort ganz groß gespielt hat und das wurde ja dann
auch von seinen FDP-Freunden dankbar aufgegriffen und die CDU hat dann auch noch mal gesagt,
ja klar, so ist es ja auch, gut, dass wir das mal wissen, was ist jetzt die
Schlussfolgerung daraus? Sollen wir abschieben?
Oder könnte man nicht mal sein eigenes Versagen auch eingestehen?
Also es liegt ja nicht in der Kultur oder in sonst irgendetwas,
dass mitunter da Schwierigkeiten sind.
Sondern das ist ja ein Integrationsversagen, das dem Staat angelastet werden muss.
Also das ist ja auch das große Problem dieser ganzen Merkel-Entscheidung gewesen.
Nur einfach mal zu sagen wir schaffen das und dann hat man ja ganz viele Leute
und Kommunen auch damit völlig allein gelassen.
Also wir haben es auch mit statistischer Trickserei zu tun, die hat Markus Lanz
ganz vorzüglich gegenüber Johannes Vogel. Ich verwechsel immer Vogel.
Und Konstantin Kuhler, die sind beide gleich schrecklich, aber das ist so dieses,
wir wollen auch mal so wie Christian Lindner werden. Wir sind so ganz smart,
haben uns echt noch mal richtig toll eingekleidet und gut.
Wir lassen uns ja auch gar nicht aus der Ruhe bringen und so.
Nein.
Lanz hat, äh, ja.
Aber das ist so, das sind so Leute, die unglaublich gut bei Twitter funktionieren,
auch so hier so Dauergast bei Micky Beisenherz.
So ganz persönliche Leute.
Wir sind ja auch so ein bisschen vogue, finden wir auch schon gut,
aber jetzt sollen auch mal die Kinder ruhig arm bleiben. Also das muss ja auch
ein Anreiz sein, mal Leistung zu bringen.
Aber mittlerweile glaube ich, die streben weniger Christian Lindner nach als
Dürr, weil Dürr immer absolut astreines Schwiegersohn Ding macht und immer ganz
viel Verständnis für alle zeigt. Aber wir müssen ja trotzdem jetzt mal vernünftig sein.
Also wir brauchen schon eine systematische Verarmung und nochmal einen Druck
auf die, die ohnehin schon wenig haben, aber wir fahren auch beim Christopher-Street-Day
nochmal hoch auf dem gelben Wagen.
Also dieses Lindner-Ding mit dem Ausländeranteil und so, das wird natürlich
im Buch eine riesige Rolle spielen. Ich will es nur ganz kurz machen.
Lanz hat es ganz wunderbar zusammengefasst gehabt.
2015 gab es Kinderarmut natürlich und der Ausländeranteil daran spielte kaum eine Rolle.
Dann kamen 2015 aber viele Ausländerkinder dazu, denen wir seitdem nicht weiter
geholfen haben, sondern wir haben es ja dann erst durch den Ukraine-Krieg erlebt,
was es bedeutet, wenn wir Flüchtlinge hier haben, die einfach ein Arbeitserlaubnis haben.
Zack, fällt das statistisch nicht auf. Aber wenn wir sie erstmal zusammenpferchen
an den Stadtrand und sagen, arbeiten dürft ihr auch nicht, die anderen versauen,
die halt auf ihren drei Quadratmeter Bett, die sie da irgendwie haben.
So, und es kam einfach seit 2015 die armen, zugezogenen, hergeflüchteten Kinder
noch dazu, wodurch der Anteil der Deutschen relativ gesunken ist, aber nicht absolut.
Also wir haben genau so viele deutsche arme Kinder wie damals.
Niemand wurde aus der Armut gerettet,
weil die Eltern plötzlich zur Arbeit ermunterten oder was auch immer.
Dieser ganze Quatsch. Also das ist sowieso schon ein Problem,
das so in eine Debatte einzubauen, weil ich würde sagen, ja,
man kann Man kann mit der Zahlengrundlage arbeiten und sich fragen,
wenn wir wissen, dass wir seit 1971 eine Unterwasser-Geburtenrate haben,
was die, und damit meine ich nur, unser Wohlstandsniveau angeht.
Dann haben wir plötzlich einen Zuzug von jungen Kindern. Wir importieren das
Potenzial an Erwerbstätigkeit, das wir selber nicht haben.
Und lassen die aber versauern. Und sagen dann, acht Jahre später,
die sind ja alle versauert.
Das darf eigentlich kein Argument sein. Daran sieht man wieder,
wir sind demografisch nicht aufgeklärt.
Lindner geht einfach alles durch. Ich will aber das eigentlich noch mal anders framen.
Du hast ja eben Human angesprochen. Ich war mit Human auf der GamesCon,
wir sind hin und her gefahren. Wir
haben uns auch ein bisschen über unsere biografischen Wege unterhalten.
Und wenn man das dann so hört, junge Menschen ziehen im Kindesalter nach Deutschland.
Kämpfen sich zur Hauptschule durch und danach geht's aber richtig los auf eigenen
Füßen und so weiter. Alle Gelegenheiten genutzen, die so eine Kommune zum Beispiel
bieten, unabhängig davon oder vielleicht sogar gegen so eine Haltung von der Bundesregierung.
Also Kämpfernaturen, die einfach irgendwo ankommen und dann einfach im Alltag irgendwo sind.
Wenn man dann zurückblickt, also wenn man dann einfach so Lindner-mäßig sich
so anzieht und denkt, Ja, ich stehe jetzt hier so bei Rewe, er hat ja auch schon
mal dieses Bäcker-Ding gemacht und so, man weiß ja gar nicht,
wer hier so deutsch spricht, ne?
Wieso kann es überhaupt eine Kategorie sein, dass man dann denkt,
ah, klar kauft er jetzt nur für 30 statt für 50 Euro ein, der ist ja ein Ausländerkind gewesen.
Weißt du? Das ist ja völlig verquerer Gedanke, dass das irgendwann in diesen
ganz alltäglichen beruflichen, familiären Situationen auch mal eine Rolle spielt,
was man vor 25 Jahren, wo man herkam, was man getan hat und so weiter.
Also überhaupt diese ganze Verbindung, wir kommen das aber nachher mit Fratja,
weil der macht das ganz wunderbar, also dieser ganze Gedankengang einfach.
Naja, das ist diese Opposition, dass es doch so ein wir und die anderen gibt.
Und wir, das sind die Volksdeutschen oder wen ihr da ansprechen möchtet,
so würde er sich nicht ausdrücken, das würde die AfD so tun,
aber man sagt es gibt schon so ein wir und die anderen.
Und solange wir dieses spielen können, können wir sagen, wir sind die besonders
Tüchtigen und deswegen, wir Tüchtigen benötigen auch gerne Grundsicherung für irgendetwas.
Also in eine Diskussion zu gehen mit so einem...
Ja, das Problem gibt es schon, aber das sind ja nur die Ausländer.
Ja. Das ist völlig, also das ist so banal, das macht einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Naja, für ihn ergibt es tatsächlich Sinn,
weil es wahlstrategisch toll ist und er wird dann immer darauf verweisen,
dass aber auch viele, die Migrationshintergründe haben, die FDP wählen und da
adressiert er aber dann so gewisse Selbstständige,
die es dann irgendwie doch geschafft haben und dann plötzlich das vielleicht
dann mit einer FDP spiegeln können,
aber er erreicht ja nicht eine Community, die migrantisch geprägt ist in dem
Sinne, sondern das sind so einzelne High Performer vielleicht,
die sich davon noch angesprochen fühlen.
Aber das reicht ihm ja völlig aus und er muss ja auch bei den Leuten,
die er da besonders vorführen will, also dass er sagt, die 2015 kamen,
die haben ja eh alle keine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft, die können ihn eh alle nicht wählen.
Insofern ist er da auf der absolut sicheren Seite, kann er so auf die draufhauen,
wo er nichts zu erwarten hatte. Sie können sich gar nicht revanchieren.
Ich war ihn selbst wohlwollend interpretiert, dass Lindner sagt,
naja, die armen Kinder sind ja heute sehr viele ausländische armen Kinder,
könnte man ja denken, ah ja, damit hat er zumindest ein politisches Problem markiert.
Wir haben ja ein Eingliederungs-Integrationsverfahren, das man politisch unterstützt,
indem dann auch über die Schulen usw.
Nur Hebelstreit musste ja original in dieser Woche in der Bundespressekonferenz
erklären, warum diese Integrationshilfen jetzt um ein Drittel gekürzt werden.
Also es ist einfach, es passt vorn und hinten nicht zusammen.
Christian Lindner schließt ja so an Gefühlsgewohnheiten irgendwie an,
die faktisch keinen Sinn ergeben und demografisch uns wirklich ins Verderben stößen.
Aber gut, Lars Klingbeil als SPD-Chef und damit ja in dieser besonderen Rolle,
dass er die, also selbst der Kanzler ist ja sozusagen auf.
Also über die personelle Besetzung einer Koalition bestimmen ja die Parteichefs,
das geht ja auch für diesen Kanzlerposten, weil da wird ja nicht gewählt,
sondern die Partei, die als größte da einfährt, sagt halt, das ist unser Mann und so.
Lars Klingbeil ist also irgendwie schon so formal der Oberchef dieses ganzen Kabinetts.
Und so fühlt er sich ja auch. So fühlt er sich ja auch und er denkt ja auch,
er hat es aus eigener Kraft gemacht und nicht etwa, weil Laschet gelacht hat
und der Buch geschrieben hat, sondern es ist, wie es ist. ist.
Und Lars Klingbeil macht diesen Satz hier.
Auch dem SPD-Parteivorsitzenden bleibt im ZDF-Sommerinterview wenig mehr als
ein weiterer Friedensappell an FDP und Grüne.
Jeder, der am Kabinettstisch sitzt, das ist ja ein Privileg,
auch diesem tollen Land dienen zu dürfen, je man Ministerin oder Minister ist.
Und ich erwarte von jedem, dass man auch dann den Pflichten nachgeht und dass
man dazu beiträgt. Und ich gehe schon davon aus, dass das alle auch gehört haben
und dass wir jetzt sehr schnell zu einer Einigung kommen.
Es ist ja ein Privileg, am Kabinettstisch zu sitzen und man sollte dann schon
seiner Pflicht nachkommen.
Also hier einfach zwölf Mehrjahren für die Kinder zu fordern,
das mit einem Veto zu verknüpfen für ein anderes Gesetz.
Das geht ja nun mal nicht.
Da geht gleich mal das Privileg verloren, am Kabinettstisch zu sitzen.
Also diese Drohungen, die hier so unter der Hand noch so mitgeschoben werden.
Es ist wirklich unglaublich.
Die Nachrichten haben sich nur kurz Zeit gegeben. Wir hören es nur in drei Clips,
um uns mal inhaltlich so ein bisschen was zu sagen.
2016 lägen etwa die direkten und indirekten Kosten im Zusammenhang mit Adipositas
bei jährlich mehr als 60 Milliarden Euro, denn das Risiko für starkes Übergewicht
steige durch Kinderarmut.
So, Kinderarmut führt zu Übergewicht, Übergewicht führt zu medizinischen Folgekosten
von 60 Milliarden Euro. 60 Milliarden Euro ist ungefähr fünfmal mehr als 12
Millionen, äh, 12 Milliarden.
Hier liegt also schon so ein gewisser Faktor drauf, der uns sagt,
Momentchen mal, haben wir es hier nicht mit einer Investition zu tun?
Sollte nicht Christian Lindner besonders Wachstumschancen gesetzmäßig hier davon
Abstand nehmen zu glauben, hier wird einfach Geld verbrannt oder sowas,
sondern das ist doch, hier geht es wirklich nur ums Übergewicht.
Das ist ja wirklich nur ein eigenes Problem. Aber gut, da kommen wir nachher wieder bei dir.
Das ist mir noch nicht bei Fachkräftemangel und jetzt andere Themen,
die dann ja auch abgedeckt werden könnten, wenn man Kinder aus der Armut hebt und sie gut ausbildet.
Ja genau, also Übergewicht heißt ja schon mal, das ist ja eine körperliche Zuschreibung.
Was heißt denn das für die Psyche, die ja übergewichtig ins Erwachsenenalter reinkommen soll?
Naja gut, die Statistiken sind ja alle bekannt, dass Kinder aus armen Familien
viel schwieriger es haben den entsprechenden Bildungszugang zu finden und dann
auch nachher erfolgreich zu sein im Job.
Zweiter inhaltlicher Snippet, der für uns ganz interessant ist.
Derzeit sind 11,2 % der Familien mit zwei Kindern armutsgefährdet.
Durch die von der Bundesregierung geplante Kindergrundsicherung und einfacheren
Zugang zu Leistungen wären es nur noch 10,3 %.
Erhielten die Familien pro Kind einen weiteren monatlichen Zuschuss pro Kind
von 50 Euro, sinke die Quote auf 9,4.
Und bei einem Zuschuss von 100 Euro auf 8,5.
Das ansinnend zu sagen, wir versuchen da mal bei null hinzukommen.
Wir sind ein sehr reiches Land, dass Familie mit zwei Kindern,
was eigentlich wünschenswert ist, volkswirtschaftlich gerechnet, dass die nicht arm sind.
Naja, volkswirtschaftlich gerechnet, also ganz nüchtern, sind zwei Kinder pro Familie zu wenig.
Eigentlich das ja.
Bräuchte es immer mal auch drei.
Also wir sind jetzt hier beim absoluten Minimum eigentlich schon angekommen,
was wünschenswert wäre und da rechnet man das jetzt durch und sagt,
okay bei 50 Euro Zuschuss würde das von 11,2 auf 9,4 Prozent gehen,
bei 100 dann auf 8,5 Prozent.
Also dann hätten wir immer noch bei 100 Euro Zuschuss pro Kind,
hätten wir immer noch 8,5 Prozent aller Familien mit zwei Kindern,
die arm sind in einem reichen Land wie Deutschland.
Also die Zahlen sagen zu uns zum einen, die sind wirklich extrem arm.
Und nicht armutsgefährdet, wie das hier formuliert wird.
Ja, die sind armutsbetroffen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, warum das immer bedroht
und gefährdet, es ist einfach armutsbetroffen.
Also es gibt da noch so eine sozialwissenschaftliche Definition und so weiter.
Ja, man kann einfach sagen, die sind arm, fertig. Genau, die kommen dann immer
mit diesem, ja, wenn es auf Dauer gestellt ist und so. Ich denke,
ja, wenn es auf Dauer gestellt ist, da sind die ganze Kindheit oder was.
Naja, an diesen Zahlen, bei sowas denke ich mir immer, naja,
aber liebe Journalisten, ihr habt euch jetzt drei Monate lang Christian Dürr
angehört, wie er einfach immer wieder sagt, ja, da gibt es ja gar kein Konzept.
Lisa Paus muss ja erst mal ein Konzept vorschlagen. Ich weiß ja gar nicht,
was die Kindergrundsicherung sein soll und so weiter und so fort und hier,
das ist ja also mehr auf eins plus eins ist zwei kann man es gar nicht runterbrechen.
Das kann jeder Grundschüler ausrechnen.
Ja, ich habe eine arme Familie, weil sie liegt ja unterhalb von 60 Prozent des
Medians im Monatseinkommen, im verfügbaren Monatseinkommen.
Wenn ich denen jetzt 50 Euro mehr pro Kind gebe, kann ich auf die Kommastelle
in Prozenten ausrechnen, wie viel weniger Kinder dann unter 60 Prozent fallen.
Wenn ich ihnen 100 Euro gebe, kann ich es auch wieder ausrechnen.
Dann sind es nicht 9,4, sondern 8,5.
Wenn ich jetzt 200 Euro zahle, bin ich vielleicht schon bei 5 Prozent oder so.
Was ja bedeutet, ah ja, das habe ich ja im Buch geschrieben,
das war ja für mich auch ein bisschen wie ein Schuppen von den Augen gefallen.
Die Grünen, ich habe seinen Namen nicht mehr im Kopf, standen im Bundestag,
Rede und so weiter. Und dann kam so eine Argumentation, ja, wir müssen hier
gar nicht umverteilen, umschichten irgendwas.
Wir haben eine relative Armutsdefinition, es ist diese 16 Prozent Median und
eben nicht Durchschnitt.
Das heißt, alle oberhalb des Medians, also alle die, die, also wenn man es einfach
in zwei Teile einteilt, diejenigen, die mehr verdienen als die untere Hälfte.
Bei denen kann man alles so lassen, man müsste nur diese Lücke schließen zwischen
der große Benchmark 60 Prozent des Medians und alle, die darunter liegen,
kriegen das mal theoretisch einfach aufgestockt.
Bis auf diese 60 Prozent.
Die Armut wäre damit in Deutschland beseitigt. Oder wie ich im Buch schreibe,
sozial romantisch ausgedrückt, besiegt.
Das kann man einfach politisch entscheiden, man weiß ja, wie viel Geld die Familien
haben und dann gibt man ihnen einfach das dazu, sodass niemand unter 60 Prozent des Medians kommt.
So, und dann habe ich ja diese Rechnung anhand des, das war nicht der Ulrich
Dings selbst vom Wohlfahrtsverband, sondern einer seiner Mitarbeiter,
der dann in so einer Ausschusssitzung einfach mal aufgedröselt hat.
Ja, wollte man, also wenn man sich einfach das deutsche Vermögen anschaut,
und wir haben jetzt schon nur über die untere Hälfte gesprochen,
die untere Hälfte besitzt 0,5 Prozent von allem. Die obere Hälfte 99,5 Prozent.
Wir reden also nur über diese 0,5 Prozent und da auch nur über diese kleine Lücke.
Also wir reden hier über 0,05, 0,07 Prozent des Gesamtvermögens.
Dass wir bewegen müssen, um die Armut abzuschaffen. Und wir sind dazu nicht in der Lage.
Also es ist wirklich grotesk. Das ist so grotesk, man kann es sich nicht vorstellen.
Lass mich noch eine Anmerkung machen. Wir hatten jetzt sehr viele Zahlen zum Thema Rezession.
Wir schlittern ja immer weiter in eine hinein. Vieles lässt nach,
auch auf dem globalen Markt.
Aber immer wieder war da zu lesen, lange Zeit hat ja dann doch der Service-Sektor
in Deutschland noch gut funktioniert. Und da bricht auch die Nachfrage ein.
Das heißt, also Leute gehen auf Deutsch gesagt weniger zum Friseur,
weniger zur Kosmetikerin, was auch immer.
Und dann kommt noch hinzu, ja, die Kaufkraft hat auch nachgelassen.
Und dann gab es einige Artikel, auch bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen dann dazu,
warum jetzt dann doch gerade weniger konsumiert wird. Und dann ist immer das
Argument, ja, unsichere Zeiten, die Menschen sparen.
Das trifft aber nur auf die Leute zu, die wirklich viel Geld haben oder die
so gutes Geld haben, dass sie sagen, gut, ich lege jetzt mal 500 Euro,
1000 Euro diesen Monat zurück.
Auf all die anderen, über die wir jetzt gerade gesprochen haben,
diese unteren 50 Prozent und Und auch die Armen, die nur 60 Prozent des Medianeinkommens
haben, auf die trifft das in keiner Weise zu.
Die haben weniger Geld in der Tasche durch Inflation, höhere Energiekosten et cetera.
Die bekommen jetzt auch nicht wesentlich mehr Geld. Das wird alles von der Inflation aufgefressen.
Sowohl die etwas angehobene Kindergrundsicherung wie auch der etwas angehobene Mindestlohn.
Das heißt, diese Leute haben eine extreme Kaufkraftschwächung erfahren.
Würde man diese Kaufkraft jetzt zum Beispiel durch Maßnahmen wie du sie erläutert
hast stärken, wäre vollkommen klar, dass sie das verkonsumieren würden.
Denn wir sind hier auf einem Niveau, bei dem man noch nicht mal sagen kann,
und diese 100 Euro, die wir mehr bekommen, die geben wir jetzt in ETF sparen.
Dieses Geld ist nicht vorhanden. Also das ist eine Diskussion.
Ich gebe 100 Euro mehr in ETF sparen oder sonst wohin.
Die Leute haben die meinetwegen ein Lehrergehalt oder sowas.
Da findet so eine Überlegung statt.
Da ist man vielleicht, wenn die Zeiten unsicherer sind, in der Kauflaune gebremst.
Für die sind auch diese ZDF-Berichte geschrieben.
Aber für einen Großteil der deutschen Bevölkerung spielen diese Fragen von Konsumaufschub keine Rolle.
Die haben wenig Geld. Wenn sie etwas mehr Geld bekämen, würden sie dieses Geld verkonsumieren.
Zum Beispiel in besseres Essen das Geld ausgeben oder was Kinder dann brauchen für die Bildung.
Vielleicht dann doch mal einen eigenen Computer, vielleicht ein paar Bücher.
Diese ganzen Käufe würden getätigt. Das würde eigentlich der Konjunktur sehr
gut tun. Also es ist wirklich ein Wahnsinn, dass man hier ausprobiert.
Also das scheint mir, und damit meine ich nicht, dass da einer einen großen Plan hat,
aber so im Retrospektiv würde man sagen, man hat es ausprobiert und vielleicht hat es geklappt,
dass man sagt, eine Bevölkerung,
ein Land kann auch damit leben, dass es eine kleine,
sehr, sehr reiche Gruppe gibt und noch eine etwas größere, sagen wir irgendwas
zwischen 10 und 20 Prozent, die sich auch relativ viel leisten kann,
die auch das Mittelklasseauto sich alle zwei Jahre erneuern kann und so.
Und die anderen sind arm. Also wir haben ja Länder, in denen es das gibt,
wo wir 20 Prozent haben, die sehr
gut verdient und dann noch mal so drei Prozent, die richtig reich sind.
Ja, alle westlichen Länder tendieren dazu.
Alle tendieren immer mehr dazu. Und in südamerikanischen Ländern oder so ist
diese Ungleichheit ja viel, viel größer.
Und dann noch, und da gibt es dann nur noch diese Spitze und Volkswirtschaften funktionieren.
Und ich sag mal, die Konzerne, bei denen Kuhle,
Vogel und Lindner einkaufen, profitieren von solchen Entwicklungen,
also wo die Ungleichheit wächst, steigt der Profit in der Regel nicht nur für
LVMH und andere Luxuskonzerne, sondern da kann man ja eine ganze Wirtschaft drauf aufbauen.
Unsichere Zeiten, mehr Beschaffungskriminalität, alles was da so dran hängt,
also braucht man mehr Sicherheit.
Ja, es ist ja ganz klar, dass man auch.
Auf so einen Katastrophenkapitalismus profitable Geschäfte errichten kann.
Das ist gesamtvolkswirtschaftlich gesehen vielleicht nicht sinnvoll.
Neokensianer sehen das natürlich sofort. Denn das, was ich jetzt hier gemacht
habe, ist eigentlich eine neokensianische Argumentation.
Aber trotzdem kann das für Partikularinteressen nach wie vor ein super Modell
sein oder sogar noch ein besseres Modell.
Und das ist wirklich die ganz große Gefahr, in die wir uns hinbewegen oder wo
wir auch jetzt eigentlich schon drinnen stecken und man sieht es an diesen Zahlen,
dass man sagt, wir probieren es jetzt mal aus, ob man auch einen Großteil der
Bevölkerung in relativer oder tatsächliche Armut lassen kann.
Funktioniert das dann immer noch? Rebellieren die? Machen die draußen heißen
Herbst? Nee, machen sie nicht.
Und dann gibt es auf der anderen Seite die, die überhaupt kein Problem damit
haben für eine Hotelübernachtung 300 Euro auszugeben und sich mit dem Fahrservice
dann zum Flughafen bringen zu lassen.
Also es ist absolut grotesk und man hört ja schon an der Länge jetzt auch,
wie du darüber sprichst, ich habe mit Absicht heute nicht die Pressekonferenz,
Lintner und Paus, wie Lisa Paus nochmal versucht, Mosefkin hat es ganz gut beschrieben,
so halb gar dann doch nicht in die Vollen zu gehen und so weiter.
Und Lindner einfach daneben sitzt und sagt, wir machen das jetzt,
aber das ist jetzt auch die letzte sozialpolitische Maßnahme dieser Bundesregierung.
Also Originalzitat. Und gleichzeitig hört man dann noch, ah ja,
Unterhaltsvorschuss für alleinerziehende Eltern gibt es nur noch bis zum sechsten
Lebensjahr der Kinder, weil danach werden die eingeschult. Das heißt viel Freizeit
für die Eltern, um arbeiten zu gehen.
Lindner dann mit der Ansage, bitte arbeiten.
Schöpfen sie, ziehen sie sich selber aus dem Haus.
Hat er ja auch Unsinn erzählt. Hat er ja auch gesagt, dass die Alleinerziehenden,
da würde die Erwerbstätigenquote zurückgehen. Hat man ihm dann ja sofort nachgewiesen.
Es ist alles Quatsch, aber es läuft alles unter diesem. Und ich würde sagen,
man sieht das doch ganz deutlich als Experiment. Wie weit können wir es treiben?
Wie weit kriegen wir die Leute aus der Not heraus in den Arbeitsmarkt irgendwie
importiert? Egal, was sie dann machen.
Büros müssen geputzt werden, Lieferservices.
Es wird ja auch dann journalistisch so argumentiert, aber lohnt sich dann noch
arbeiten, wenn Kindergrundsicherung nach oben geht?
Gerade erfahren, dass ein Viertel der Arbeitenden in Deutschland unter 14 Euro
verdient und dass damit für sie die Altersarmut gewiss ist.
Da muss doch klar sein, dass da das Problem liegt,
dass man, also es wird ja auch noch immer so getan,
als sei das in irgendeiner Weise ein luxuriöses Leben, dass man von der Stütze führen kann,
wo ich sagen will, ja, mir ist es so schon schleierhaft, wie das überhaupt gehen
kann, aber dass man das auch noch als Luxus darstellt, das muss doch auch noch
irgendwo deutend deutlich sein.
Uns wird der große Paradigmenwechsel, den wir hier einfach fordern,
der wird uns gleich explizit vorgeschlagen. Also mit gleich meine ich,
es sind noch ein paar Journalisten und Politiker Stimmen, die wir abspülen.
Wir müssen uns aufladen, um dann Fratsche richtig zu verstehen.
Hier nur noch zu diesem Punkt, du hast es angemerkt.
Wir haben, das hören wir nachher auch, eine ausführliche Studienlage zur Frage,
Was machen bitter arme Eltern mit Kindern zu Hause, wenn sie 50 Euro mehr kriegen?
Wir müssen da nicht drüber spekulieren oder klar gar Christian Lindner glauben,
dass das irgendwie entsprechend sachfremd verwendet wird.
Christian Lindner wird es verrauchen.
Diese Familien wissen, wie sie mit Geld umgehen. Ich würde sagen,
für eine Partei, die sich auf Wirtschaftskompetenz und so weiter besinnt,
Nirgendwo kann man besser mit Geld umgehen als in einem Alleinerziehendenhaushalt.
Ja, ich würde mir, wenn ich manche FDPler, man darf ja hier nichts sagen,
wenn ich mir die ansehe, würde ich sagen, die sollten vielleicht mal ein paar
andere Dinge, ihr Geld nicht mehr investieren.
Ja, das sind Überlebensleistungen und das ist jetzt wirklich kein Quatsch,
wenn man das so vergleicht.
Diese Familien haben alleinerziehend mit zwei Kindern weniger Budget als Christian Lindner an einem Tag.
Jeden Tag. Also es ist einfach jenseits von allem.
Der weiß nicht worüber er spricht und er kann vor allem diese große Verknüpfung
zur wirtschaftlichen Sicherung und vor allem den Wohlstandsfragen,
die wir haben, einfach nicht ziehen.
Aber die müssen sich ja nicht orange ansprühen lassen.
Um das einfach mal so stehen zu lassen. Ich glaube, manche konnten sich ja noch
mal ein paar Bilder ansehen.
Ah, okay, verstehe. Ich glaube, ich verstehe. Hier noch mal die Tagesthemen.
In dem Fall haben wir uns einen Verweis auf die Diakoniearbeit gegeben,
die wir ja dann gleich in der Bundespressekonferenz noch mal ein bisschen ausführlicher hören.
Zuspruch bekam Paus heute von der Diakonie. Die hat vom Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung berechnen lassen, was Kinderarmut langfristig kostet.
Die Forscher sind überzeugt, wenn man Kinderarmut heute nicht bekämpft,
wird es morgen um ein Vielfaches teurer.
Ja, und damit sind dann so 3,4 Prozent BIP. Wir kriegen das nachher aufgeschlüsselt.
Das sind auch wieder im dreistelligen Milliardenbereich.
Die Diakonie, das finde ich auch wieder so, es sind so viele Kinder,
es ist so eine gigantische Schicksalsfrage.
Und die Diakonie ist dann die einzige, die überhaupt mal sagt,
wir interessieren uns dafür, wir machen mal, wir haben jetzt hier gehört,
eine Studie. Nee, nicht mal die waren in der Lage, noch eine Studie zu machen.
So ein Handapparat, was für Texte gibt es denn gerade und so.
Also nicht mal die haben so richtig den Taschenrechner rausgeholt. Was ich grotesk finde.
Kommen wir zu den Parteien, die FDP.
Erst erwirtschaften, bevor es verteilt werden könne. Auf diesem Standpunkt bleibt die FDP.
Wir können uns in der jetzigen Situation nicht eine Ausweitung des Sozialstaates erlauben.
Das geht nicht. Sondern derzeit geht es darum, den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
wieder zukunftsfähig, wieder wettbewerbsfähig zu machen, damit wir überhaupt
in der Lage sind, gute Jobs zu haben, damit die Menschen dementsprechend auch
später ihre Familien durch Jobs, Arbeit ernähren können.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir Kinderarmut effektiv bekämpfen, indem wir einfach
pauschal den Eltern irgendwelche Summen überweisen. Das ist aus meiner Sicht
keine überzeugende Lösung.
Gegen Armut und all ihre Folgen. Hilft nur ein was. Geld.
Das ist die Definition von Armut. Zu wenig Geld, zu wenig Handlungsvermögen.
Wie man hier dann sagen kann, ich glaube nicht, dass das hilft.
Ich glaube nicht, dass gegen Durst hilft, jetzt ein Glas Wasser zu trinken.
Vielleicht solltest du lieber nochmal draußen in den Wald, vielleicht findest
du irgendwo, keine Ahnung, aber jetzt einfach ein Glas Wasser trinken.
Das wäre doch so. Christian Döhr hat natürlich auch noch ein bisschen abgeliefert.
Wir ordnen die Migration nach Deutschland in den Arbeitsmarkt,
nicht in die sozialen Sicherungssysteme.
Und ich hätte mir gewünscht, ganz offen am vergangenen Mittwoch,
dass es alle so sehen wie Robert Habeck, der Bundeskanzler, und wir als FDP,
dass Deutschland ein Wachstumschancengesetz braucht, damit wir wirtschaftlich durchstarten.
Wir sind ein sehr starkes und tolles Land. Die Unternehmen brauchen aber bessere Rahmenbedingungen.
Das kam unter der Vorgängerregierung zu Kurs, da wollen wir besser werden.
Und es ist schade, dass eine Ministerin da ihr Veto eingelegt hat, jedenfalls vorläufig.
Das sind natürlich für mein Anliegen, mein Buch, Zehn Seiten zu solchen Dingern,
weil dieses, wir brauchen jetzt Rahmenbedingungen für die Unternehmen.
Ja, aber was ist denn eine Familie? Jetzt mal so ganz, ich will ja mit Absicht
nicht dieses nächste weinerliche Buch über die armen Kinder und so.
Was ist eine Familie? Eine Familie ist der einzige Ort und zwar zu allen historischen
Zeiten und in allen Politikmodellen, wo die Kinder herkommen,
die später in Unternehmen arbeiten.
Ohne Mitarbeiter sind Unternehmen nichts wert. Also diese Automatisierungsgrade
wird es hier niemals geben.
Klar, kann man jetzt sagen, das ist aber irgendwie komisch, wenn man sich Familien
als Unternehmen betrachtet und so weiter, aber jetzt mal so ganz funktional betrachtet.
Nicht mal im Nationalsozialismus, nicht bei den Chinesen, nicht bei den Russen, nirgendwo.
Man hatte diese Idee von Kaderschmiede und hier und da und so.
Aber diese Idee von wir zeugen und erziehen, sozialisieren Kinder jenseits von Familien.
Hat niemals funktioniert. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach kommen und sagen,
ja, die Unternehmen, die Unternehmen und dann blenden wir aber die Familien aus.
Wenn Unternehmen Rahmenbedingungen brauchen, dann Familien auch.
Also es ist einfach, das passiert nicht einfach so. Also wir haben ja diesen
Text gelesen in der New York Times über, man hat sich halt sehr lange auf die
Mutterliebe besonnen. Ja, die Mutterliebe macht das schon, die wird ja nicht
ihr Kind verdorren lassen und so, ja.
Sondern da müssen wir gar nicht eingreifen politisch. Das ist jenseits der Politik,
wir dürfen uns da nicht einmischen.
Und so freizügig und fordernd innerhalb eines Satzes über Unternehmen zu sprechen,
gegen Familien, sie auszuspielen, ist einfach völlig banal. Also,
das passt einfach wirklich nicht zusammen. Das ergibt keinen logischen Sinnzusammenhang.
Dürr, noch ein bisschen weiter.
Warum fällt der FDP das Regieren mit den Grünen so wahnsinnig schwer?
Nein, das ist ja in der Sache vom vergangenen Mittwoch, Sie sprechen ja auf
die Kabinettsentscheidung an, da ist ein großes Paket verabschiedet worden,
aber es fehlt ja das Wachstumsschanzengesetz, was alle sagen wir brauchen es.
Die Unternehmen in Deutschland, die Wirtschaftsverbände sagen das,
die Forschungsinstitute und natürlich auch große Teile der Koalition und es
waren sicher auch der Bundeskanzler, der Bundeswirtschaftsminister von den Grünen
und Diese lange Reihe von wer sich alles einig ist und wie isoliert also Lisa Paus ist.
Aber was ist denn das auch wieder für eine Frage? Warum fällt das dann der FDP und den Grünen so?
Sie müssen sich nicht alle verstehen, sie dürfen auf gar keinen Fall im Streit
hier und so weiter. Aber diese große Isolierungsbemühung, Lisa Pau, steht ganz alleine.
Es gibt keine Veranstaltung, die das Thema Kinder oder Familien im Mittelpunkt
hat, bei der irgendeiner sagt, zwei Milliarden reichen.
Die FDP beräumt so was nicht an. Die hat auch keine Wissensgrundlage dazu.
Da gibt es keine Texte, deren Autoren man nochmal einladen kann,
die dann ganz freimütig sagen, zwei Milliarden reichen völlig.
Sondern es sind einfach nur diese politischen Botschaften, die so und dann Frank
Schäffler, der auf Twitter nochmal und so vom Sozial Klimbimm spricht,
den man sich nicht leisten kann, weil ja die Unternehmen so viel Hilfe brauchen.
Also es ist völlig crazy, wie man, wie er überhaupt, also dass er einfach so versucht sozusagen.
Die Lisa Pau steht damit ganz alleine.
Aber es verfängt ja.
Ja, also in den Nachrichten wird ihm dann nicht widersprochen,
da wird nicht nachgehakt, da wird einfach nur, ja verstehen sie sich jetzt bald
wieder in der Regierung.
Finanzminister Christian Hintner, wir von der FDP uns alle einig,
es war eine Ministerin, die ihr Veto eingelegt hat, was ich schade finde,
denn wir könnten jetzt richtig durchstarten.
Das ist dieses Chaos, wir könnten uns doch einfach mal vernünftig sagen.
Die Sache ist nur aufgeschoben, nicht aufgehoben. Ich bin sicher,
das Gesetz wird kommen, es ist notwendig. Und im Übrigen, das will ich kurz
sagen, Frau Gerlinek, weil die Familienministerin zu Recht auch auf Kinderarmut hinweist.
Das größte Risiko für Kinderarmut ist ja die Arbeitslosigkeit der Eltern.
Und da müssen wir besser werden, dass mehr Menschen in Jobs kommen.
Und das heißt Wachstum. An der Stelle, glaube ich, wird sie sich eines besseren
besinnen, hoffe ich jedenfalls.
Und ich würde mich freuen, wenn die Grünen sich da intern einig werden.
Wie gesagt, das ist kein Diskurs so sehr zwischen FDP und Grünen,
sondern eher innerhalb der grünen Partei.
Das ist natürlich...
Habeck soll da jetzt mal Maß regeln, was er im Prinzip auch getan hat.
Also hier einfach so... Klar, das ist natürlich die marktwirtschaftliche Doktrin,
die Ideologie, mit der man rangeht. Wir haben eine Marktwirtschaft und alles hat sich zu fügen.
So wenig wie wir politisch in Familien reinregieren können.
Können wir auch marktwirtschaftliche oder überhaupt wirtschaftliche Prinzipien
einfach in sie reinkopieren.
Eine gute, gelingende Kindererziehung ist ja nicht einfach eine erfolgreiche
interne Leistungsabrechnung,
bei der die Kinder dann besonders tapfer rauskommen und leistungsfähig sind,
wenn du jede kleine Hilfestellung, die du von ihnen erfahren hast,
irgendwie abrechnest mit irgendwas oder so.
Ja, so funktioniert es ja nicht und dass Familien für uns politisch und wirtschaftlich
so elementar sind und wir gleichzeitig keine politische und keine wirtschaftliche Handhabe haben,
mit den jeweiligen Macht- oder Profitprinzipien da irgendwas zu steuern.
Schafft vielleicht mal eine Oma, die dann irgendwie zu Weihnachten kommt und
sagt, also wenn du heute ganz artig bist, kriegst du morgen ein großes Geschenk.
Ja gut, diesen einen Tag artig sein, kriegt das Kind halt irgendwie hin.
Aber darüber hinaus ist es einfach Sense mit solchen Prinzipien.
Für die FDP spielt das alles gar keine Rolle. Das ist irgendwie auch,
finde ich, so der, als ob die alle so lieblose Leben führen.
Also das ist einfach, die gehen
nicht nach Hause und lieben ihren Partner und ihre Kinder oder sowas.
Da muss ja irgendwas nicht stimmen, wenn man in der FDP ist,
würde ich schon mutmaßen.
Es ist doch erstaunlich, dass wir zum einen es im Diskurs nicht fertig bringen,
einmal unter wirtschaftlichen Gesichtspunkten Familien zu betrachten.
Käme man ja bei all dem heraus, was wir schon hier aufgeführt haben.
Und zugleich ist es dem Journalismus nicht möglich,
die Koalition einmal funktional zu betrachten, sondern hier versucht man eigentlich
die Koalition wie eine Familie, die sich zankt, die ganze Zeit uns zu inszenieren.
Und jetzt sollen sich aber Papa, Mama und die Kinder wieder liebhaben.
Und die eine komische Tante, die Lisa Paus, Die schlägt ja immer raus,
die müssen wir jetzt auch mal wieder zurück an den Tisch holen.
Und das ist so toll, wie hier alle Kategorien durcheinandergeworfen werden.
Das ist wirklich grotesk.
Der Journalismus redet mit Politikern darüber, wie man mit Familien umgeht und
die ganze Zeit kreist sich das Thema um, die Wirtschafts- und Politikprinzipien
müssen in der Familie so richtig einmal wirken.
Gleichzeitig hat man aber als Gesprächspartner Leute, die in einem politischen
Kontext Geldentscheidungen treffen.
Und von denen verlangt man aber die ganze Zeit, wie eine Familie zu funktionieren.
Ja. Es ist wirklich ... Ja, es ist einfach ...
Alle müssen an einem Strang ziehen.
Ich finde keine Worte dafür, wie grotesk das so was ist. Es ist wirklich so
bescheuert. Dürr, noch ein bisschen weiter.
Seitdessen hat Ihr Parteichef, Christian Lindner, Finanzminister,
heute ja die Sinnfrage gestellt, ob die Kindergrundsicherung überhaupt der richtige
Weg ist. Das klingt so, als ob Sie sich nicht einigen wollen.
Ich möchte kurz einordnen, Frau Gellinck.
Ich sagte vorhin schon, den 1. wichtigen Punkt, die Arbeitslosigkeit der Eltern
ist das größte Risiko für Kinderarmut in Deutschland. Da müssen wir besser werden,
mehr Wachstumschancen.
Das erwähnte ich vorhin. Ich bin sicher, dass das entsprechende Gesetz bald kommen wird. Zum 2.
Ist es so, dass man schon die Frage stellen muss, ob einfach nur höhere Sozialtransfers,
Deutschland ist ja international auf dem Spitzenplatz, wir haben hohe Sozialleistungen
in Deutschland, ob das schon reicht gegen Kinderarmut.
Wir haben hohe Sozialleistungen. Ich will noch mal daran erinnern,
117 Milliarden pro Jahr für die Rente. Das fällt natürlich alles unter Sozialleistungen.
Ja. Ich würde auch mal noch einhaken bei diesem Argument, dass Kinder arm sind,
wenn die Eltern nicht arbeiten.
Nun ist es ja aber so, dass ja sehr viele Kinder arm sind, obwohl die Eltern
arbeiten. Also wir haben ja eine relativ geringe Arbeitslosenquote in Deutschland.
Eineinhalb Millionen Arbeitslose, aber über fünf Millionen Aufstocker.
Die Hartz-IV-Betriebe.
Da stimmt doch etwas an dem System nicht. Man kann ja nicht sagen,
wir haben etwa zwölf Prozent der Familie mit zwei Kindern, die arm sind.
Dann hat man aber eine geringe Arbeitslosenquote. Die sind ja gar nicht alle
arbeitslos, die dort aufgeführt werden. Arbeitslosigkeit ist nicht das Problem.
Ja, Arbeitslosigkeit ist gar nicht das Problem. Und sie arbeiten ja dann,
wenn, so wie Dürr das will, in Jobs, bei denen sie arm trotz Arbeit sind.
Arm trotz Arbeit, das ist die Losung, genau. Und ich will nochmal dieses qualitative
Argument hinterher schieben.
Der Job, den alleinerziehende Mütter hauptsächlich ergreifen, ist die Raumpflege.
Mit einer Arbeitszeit, das Kind kommt gerade aus der Schule,
die Mutter geht zur Arbeit. Es ist wirklich absurd.
Gut, richtig schlimm fand ich, aber ich meine, Dürr, das kann man alles,
das weiß man, ja. Man wird angekündigt, okay, Dürr kommt, die Journalisten haben
ihm nichts entgegenzusetzen.
Aber Habeck, also Habeck fand ich hier wirklich, das ist schlimm.
Sie sind gerade aus dem Urlaub zurück. Wie schön ist das denn,
wenn man im Urlaub damit quasi aufwacht, dass eine Parteifreunde den nächsten
großen Konflikt in der Koalition vom Zaun gebrochen hat?
Das hat mit Urlaub ja nichts zu tun. Das ist natürlich jetzt kein Glanzstück gewesen.
Andererseits kommt das Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz jetzt in der Kabinettsklausel
in Meseberg. Auch bei der Kindergrundsicherung sind wir auf gutem Weg.
Wenn man mal den Streit beiseite lässt, das alles gut hin?
Kein Glanzstück. Wir wissen, dass das im Politiker-Sprech der Todesstoß für
dieser Pause ist, parteiintern.
Ja gut, wenn die sich alle so selber... Ich meine, Annalena Baerbock kommt ins
Amt mit diesem Buch. Wir haben es ja gelesen. Ich habe es sehr gut gefunden.
Es handelt von 90 Prozent nur die Kinder, die Kinder, die Kinder.
Und ich dachte mir so, ah ja, eine Mutter in einem Ministerposten, das ist ja auch mal neu.
Außer Ursula von der Leyen hatten wir die Corona-Politik von einem Wirtschaftsminister,
einem Finanzminister, einem Gesundheitsminister und einer Kanzlerin,
die alle keine Kinder hatten.
Null Kinder auf diese vier Posten, die einfach zwei Jahre lang Lockdowns beschlossen haben.
Und am liebsten sowieso abends zu Hause sind und Fernsehen gucken.
Ja, dann vertreiben wir eine Familienpolitikerin, also eine Familienministerin
mit mehreren Kindern, weil sie es nicht hinbekommen hat, auch noch ihren Schlaganfall
geschädigten Mann zu Hause durchzukriegen, wo man sich denkt,
Ja, haben wir sie noch alle? Kriegen wir eine neue Familienministerin und die
wird jetzt einfach so gekillt.
Also Familienpolitik in Deutschland ist wirklich ein Schlachtfeld für alle Beteiligten.
Naja und wir können das Resultat, das können wir ja vorwegnehmen.
Also es gibt ja de facto 400 Millionen Euro mehr als ursprünglich gedacht.
Also der Kompromiss ist ja kein Kompromiss.
2,4 Milliarden.
Lindner hat sich durchgesetzt, fertig ab und dann ist ja doch interessant,
denn mich verwundert diese Aussage davon Habeck jetzt in dem Sinne gar nicht
und tatsächlich scheint dieser Poster auch verloren im Posten zu stehen,
dass von den angeblich progressiven, den den Hopfstohlen von TikTok ja dann
auch nichts anderes kommt von grüner Seite.
Also zum Beispiel Emilia Fester hat dann gepostet mit einem TikTok Video,
das wir jetzt hier nicht abspielen.
Aus kompliziert wird einfach, aus ungerecht wird gerecht. Mit der Kindergrundsicherung
holen wir Kinder aus der Armut.
Wir schaffen Gerechtigkeit und Vereinfachung bei der Unterstützung für Kinder.
Und im etwaselben Wortlaut hat sich auch die vermeintlich progressive Ricarda Lang geäußert.
Also, wir blenden ja diese Inhalte jetzt aus. Ich will nur einen Fakt nennen,
weil aus kompliziert wird einfach.
Diese ganze Idee von der Staat geht ja über in eine Bringhol,
Bringschuld und so weiter, er bietet jetzt diese, also das Kind wird geboren
und dann steht der Staat da und sagt, hier ist dein Geld.
Dieses Geld wird künftig über die Familienkasse ausgezahlt.
Wir haben sehr viele Kassen, die Geld auszahlen. Wir haben die Rentenkasse,
wir haben Gesundheitskram, wir haben alle die Sozialkassen, die ganze Kram.
Die Familienkasse nicht besonders groß, weshalb von den 2,4 Milliarden jetzt
500 Millionen nur in den Verwaltungsapparat Aufbau fließen, Familienkassen.
Bravo!
Wenn das nicht wirklich auf diese Lindnasche ...
2,4 Milliarden willst du? Ich habe dir nur 2 Milliarden angeboten.
Okay, 500 Millionen gehen aber an meine Freunde.
Such dir die Beratungsorganisationen aus und lass dir so ein Apparat hinstellen.
Also es ist, man wird wirklich wütend, wenn man da in die Details geht.
Aber kann man da nicht einfach dann mal FDP-like sagen, wir lassen das Paypal
machen? Das müsste doch besser gehen.
Zum Beispiel, wir machen gleich ein Paypal-Konto und wir überweisen es euch.
Aber es ist, nee, das müssen jetzt die Familienkassen machen.
Wir haben ja so 100 in Deutschland, wir brauchen aber dann irgendwie 500 und
da fehlen auch noch tausende Mitarbeiter.
Oder vielleicht könnte darauf sich Steady bewerben, dass die das machen.
Sie machen es jedenfalls günstiger und effizienter.
Es ist wirklich, ja man baut jetzt erstmal eine parallele Infrastruktur auf dafür.
Ja aber verstehst du da ist doch, ich meine das ist doch wie Hohn,
also wenn jetzt selbst Grüner, also Emilia Fester und Ricarda Lange einem solchen
Knopf an die Backe nähen, welche Schlussfolgerung soll man denn noch daraus ziehen?
Wen soll man wählen? Ja das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Ja, gar nicht jetzt nur da, da denke ich ja schon gar nicht mehr daran,
dass man mit Wahlen was bewegt, aber nein, dass man, das ist ja,
das ist ja so, so unehrlich.
Für den Fall, dass ihr heute zum ersten Mal hier zuhört, weil wir jetzt eineinhalb
Stunden darüber reden, aber es ist einfach, wir kommen diesmals auch nicht auf
einen grünen Zweig, wir finden es einfach bescheuert, was wir hier sehen.
Ja, also ich kann ja jetzt nicht. Wir versuchen aber gleich noch eine konzeptive
Wende. Ihr habt mich ja am Parkplatz abgeholt, ich steige aus meinem Auto aus,
da kann ich ja auch nicht sagen, ich bin heute mit dem Fahrrad gekommen, also das geht ja nicht.
Ja, ja, ja, es ist einfach. Machen wir einen kurzen humoristischen Einschlag,
die Regierung sitzt jetzt in Meseberg und muss dort das Heizungsgesetz,
das ja auch noch nicht fertig ist, das Wirtschaftschancengesetz und die Kindergrundsicherung
noch parlamentfähig und dann auch wirklich mal beschließen.
Karl-Rudolf Korth.
Wenn Sie so in die nächste Woche blicken auf Meseberg, wie würden Sie Ihre Erwartungen
formulieren? Wird das gelingen, da irgendwie ein neues Miteinander zu finden?
Nein, nur schöne Bilder. Ich erwarte da gar nichts.
Eine Wiederholung dessen, was wir bisher auch erlebt haben und das deutet viel
auf zwei lange Jahre, wenn die Koalition genauso weitermacht,
wie wir das in den letzten Tagen wieder erneut erlebt haben.
Ich erwarte da gar nichts, sagt er.
Ja, und ich befürchte, er hat recht.
Absolut. Wir hören noch ein bisschen Scholz.
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat eine schnelle Einigung im Streit um die Kindergrundsicherung angekündigt.
Die Regierung werde bis nächste Woche klären, wie die Sozialleistungen für Kinder
konkret ausgestaltet werden sollen, sagte der Kanzler den Zeitungen der Mediengruppe Bayern.
Vor allem der finanzielle Rahmen ist umstritten.
Familienministerin Paus hatte bis zu 7 Mrd. Euro jährlich dafür veranschlagt.
Finanzminister Lindner will die Ausgabe bei 2 Mrd. Euro deckeln.
Scholz gibt uns zu erkennen, dass er mal wieder wie bei so vielen Themen ...
Ich kenn mich da aus, keine Sorge, ich hab's im Griff.
Kleiner Gruß aus Berlin. Stimmt es, dass Sie den Gesetzentwurf von Frau Paus gelesen haben?
Da hab ich sehr dafür gesorgt, dass es einen großen Fortschritt gibt.
Wie ich schon bei verschiedenen Gelegenheiten gesagt hab, wir sind mit 99 Prozent,
vielleicht sind's nur 98, je nachdem was man zählt, fertig. Den Rest schaffen wir auch noch.
Was ist das für eine Detailversessenheit? Wenn man anders zählt,
98 Prozent des Gesetzes fertig. Es geht ja um die Frage, ja sind es jetzt zwei
Milliarden oder wie die andere Gegenseite wünscht fünfmal mehr, sechsmal mehr.
Wenn das im Einprozentbereich der noch offenen Fragen, dasselbe Statement im ZDF.
Ja, aber das ist eine Argumentation, die du auch bei diesen komischen Funkleuten
gefunden hast, Schippmann und wie die alle heißen.
Das war ja immer, naja, sie hat das Gesetz ja gar nicht richtig ausgearbeitet,
als ging es jetzt um irgendwelche funktionalen Details, als müsste ich jetzt
genau wissen, wer mit was betraut ist als Bürger. Das ist ja völlig irrelevant.
Dann hätte man ja auch sagen können, diese 100 Milliarden hätte man nie versprechen
dürfen. War das im Detail ausgearbeitet?
Nee, der hat sich einfach breitbeinig da vorne hingestellt und gesagt,
wir rüsten jetzt auf. Wir erreichen jetzt das zwei Prozent Ziel der NATO.
Wie genau habe ich jetzt da Einsicht vom Bundesamt für Wertechnik und Beschaffung,
dass die mir jetzt da das auflisten können? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Weiß ich, wie irgendein Gesetz funktioniert en detail?
Muss das jeder wissen? Hat Scholz das Gesetz so genau gelesen,
dass er sagen kann 98, 99 Prozent?
Natürlich nicht. Der kriegt mal irgendwas grob zusammengefasst und sagt ja,
was soll der Kram kosten?
Ach, 20 Milliarden will die haben? Nee, nee, lieber mal weniger.
Also das ist doch reiner Humbug und auch kein Journalist setzt sich ja damit auseinander.
Das ist ja auch alle nur so ein paar Meldungen und irgendwann gibt es dann einen
Artikel von Maurice oder Lukas Scholle, die dann wirklich mal reingelesen haben
und die dann sagen, nee, nee, es ist alles viel schlimmer.
Ich empfehle sehr das letzte Wirtschaftsbriefing von Maurice und seinem Kollegen,
den er dauerhaft hat. Namen gerade nicht präsent.
Die gehen auch nochmal schön die Kindergrundsicherung so ein bisschen inhaltlich da durch.
Das was man im Fernsehen bekommt ist halt hier Scholz nochmal.
In der Kindergrundsicherung, da habe ich sehr dafür gesorgt,
dass es einen großen Fortschritt gibt. Und wie ich schon bei verschiedenen Gelegenheiten
gesagt habe, wir sind mit 99 Prozent, vielleicht sind es nur 98,
je nachdem was man zählt, fertig. Den Rest schaffen wir auch noch.
Wir kriegen einfach diese gigantische Redundanz von diesen O-Tönen,
völlig inhaltsbefreit.
Dann, was sagt die CDU dazu? Das ist so interessant.
Sonst immer, ja, wie man halt so fragt, Linnemann natürlich,
Merz, die ganzen Typen, dann dieser, naja, man kennt sie ja alle, Frei und so.
In dem Fall geht es ja ums Gedöns, also darf die Frau Behr noch mal.
Sie spricht von einer Kindergrundsicherung. Ehrlich gesagt weiß ich nicht mehr,
was sie damit überhaupt meint. In jedem Interview nennt sie andere Zahlen.
In jedem Interview fügt sie andere Begriffe zusammen. Es ist überhaupt keine Linie erkennbar.
Die Familien in Deutschland haben einen Anspruch darauf, dass wir dieses seit
Jahrzehnten ungelöste Problem endlich lösen.
Herzlichen Dank.
Das ist ja das allgemeine Problem, dass man immer glaubt, man müsse eine Gesamtabdeckung
haben. Man könnte auch einfach, nachdem man Bea interviewt hat,
sagen, oh, wir haben leider keinen vernünftigen O-Ton bekommen,
dann lassen wir das rausfallen.
Ja, machen wir aber nicht. Wir haben den O-Ton, zack.
Und das war ja so ein original Julia Klöckner Statement.
Ja, da geht alles drunter und drüber. Wir brauchen eine klare Linie,
sonst können wir ja gar nichts bewerten.
Das kann ich ja zu allem, jederzeit sagen.
Ja, so jetzt habe ich eben schon kurz das Wort zu den Familienkassen gesagt
und so, wir hören dazu noch mal, aber nur weil es so amüsant ist.
Und das ist der Kern der Kindergrundsicherung. Wir fassen alle familienpolitischen
Leistungen in eine Leistung zusammen. Es ist bisher sehr unübersichtlich in
Deutschland für Familien, gerade für die, die es schwerer haben.
Und da den Kindern gute Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen, das ist ja das Ziel.
Entbürokratisierung, das Ganze auch digitaler zu machen, das haben wir uns als
Koalition auf die Fahnen geschrieben.
Solche bürokratischen Vorgänge viel einfacher zu machen. Und da sind wir uns
einig und ich hoffe, dass genau das der Gesetzentwurf von PAUS auch leisten wird.
Wir zahlen wirklich jedem Kind Kindergeld. Wir haben diesen Zahlungsweg. Ja.
Und machen jetzt für dieses Ding einen neuen auf und nennen das dann Entbürokratisierung.
Ja.
Es ist jenseits von allem. Aber der Presseclub hat sich auch um dieses Thema
gekümmert. Schönborn moderiert.
Ich habe gedacht, ich falle vom Stuhl. Ich konnte es nicht glauben.
Man hätte ja denken können, okay, Journalisten im Fernsehen,
die kennen sich aus, die haben Kinder, die kennen jemand mit Kindern,
die waren selber mal Kinder, irgendwie so, oder?
Es ist vielleicht, liegt es irgendwie nahe, dass das so einen lebensweltlichen Touch hat.
Irgendwas politisches, also aus ihrem Metier, Realität allgemein.
Stattdessen erste Frage von Jörg Schönborn.
Ich will beginnen, Frau Thomae, mit etwas, was man so bei Seminaren und Workshops
immer macht, um die Fantasie zu erweitern. Da heißt es dann,
stellen Sie sich vor, Sie hätten Zauberkraft und Sie könnten eine Maßnahme bewirken
mit dieser Zauberkraft.
Es geht um arme Kinder in Deutschland. Von welcher Maßnahme würden Sie träumen,
von der Sie glauben, die wäre die beste?
Bundesjugendspiele wieder nach den Bewertungskriterien einführen?
Das große FDP-Thema gerade.
Wir haben ein Gesetz da liegen. Man könnte das lesen, besprechen,
wie auch immer, fürs Publikum aufdröseln. Man ist ja im Lese- und Schreibe-Business.
Stattdessen, Ja, wenn wir so eine Zauberkraft hätten, also das ist doch wirklich
jenseits von allem. Natürlich machen dann alle mit.
Ich würde auch bei den Schulen ansetzen.
Wo sonst, ja?
Thema fehlt Bildung. Ganz klar. Also ich habe nichts dagegen Schulen aufzumöbeln,
aber dass diese erste Bildung nicht irgendwie einfach mal das Geld geben,
damit sich ein Eis kaufen können.
Nein, es muss diesen, die müssen schon was dafür tun. Später.
Der Weg dahin, die müssen einmal durch die Hölle Schule und so,
aber die kann man ja nochmal ausstatten.
Mit Bundesjugendspiel. Das ist das große Thema jetzt.
Ich wusste es gar nicht. Du hast Kinder. Ich war aber ein Kind,
viele werden es nicht glauben.
Und ich muss sagen, ich habe die Bundesjugendspiele natürlich in ganz jungen
Jahren als große Qual erlebt,
weil ich dachte, ich müsste mich messen, bis ich dann aber relativ früh zur
intellektuellen Reife gelangt bin und wusste, nein, die Bundesjugendspiele sind
eigentlich ein ganz guter Tag, um sich mal mit Freunden auf eine Bank zu setzen und zu unterhalten.
Und dann wollte ich auch nur noch die Teilnahmeurkunde oder was weiß ich haben.
Ich habe glaube ich einmal eine Siegerurkunde bekommen.
Ja schon sehr gut. Also ich reklamiere die gewisse Reife im Kopf auch für mich
und gehe trotzdem jedes Jahr auf den Sportplatz und mache mir ein Sportabzeichen.
Du machst ein Sportabzeichen?
Ne, das ist ja, Bundesjugendspieler heißt ja, die Kinder gehen im Klassenverband
auf den Sportplatz und machen Sportabzeichen.
Naja, also die machen Kugelstoßen und Sprinten und dann bekommen die aber doch so eine Urkunde.
Irgendwelche Punkte sammelt man, das ist ja immer das, die Sportlehrer bereiten
sich Monate darauf vor. Sagen sie immer, sagen sie immer.
Also bestimmt hier welche zu, wir kriegen böse E-Mails.
Das witzige ist ja, die FDP hat ja jetzt gefordert, dass die Leistungsbewertung
wieder reinkommt in die Bundesjugendspiele.
Und die war weg, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Die ist ja gar nicht weg, das ist ja nur künftig, das ist glaube ich geplant, dass die weg ist,
also seitdem, was ich bei meinen Kindern mitkriege und bei mir,
da wird noch knallhart abgerechnet, also wenn der Weitsprung nicht klappt,
dann klappt es halt nicht, kommt niemand und sagt, ja trotzdem Gold oder so,
ne es muss halt schon passen.
Und die FDP glaubt ja, damit werden dann unsere Sportler allgemein wieder… Die
FDP glaubt jetzt, wenn wir künftig die Leistungsdings nicht rausnehmen,
schaffen wir rückblickend für die letzte WM wieder Medaillen bei der Leichtathletik.
Und alle, die ja da angetreten sind, die hatten ja noch die alten Bundesjugendspiele.
Und ich hatte ja mal die Gelegenheit, mich mit einem Zehnkämpfer zu unterhalten,
der auch an den Olympischen Spielen schon teilgenommen hat. genommen hat.
Und das große Problem ist ja einfach die Zeit. Also man muss ja überhaupt einen
Job finden, wo man das machen kann.
Und dann kann man zur Polizei oder zur Bundeswehr gehen. Und viel mehr ist da ja gar nicht.
Das heißt, in Deutschland wird dieser Sport ja werden. Also wenn man jetzt nicht
gerade so Fußballprofis, so wird man ja sehr, sehr gering unterstützt.
Und die Vereine bekommen auch immer weniger Geld.
Und genau, was macht man dann? Das heißt, da sind ganz, ganz große Probleme.
Aber die möchte natürlich die FDP nicht angehen, sondern mit Leistung allein
und den entsprechenden Maßstäben kann man Das Deutschlands Schicksal hängt an
den Bundesjugendspielen und denen.
Es ist wirklich, es ist ganz schlimm. Aber Sie haben sich schon mal auf das Thema Schule besonnen.
Wenn ich Sauberkräfte hätte, würde ich alle Schulen im Land,
wo das nötig ist, einmal baulich, tippitoppi, schön hinzaubern.
Ich war ja auch schon ein paar mal im Presseclub. Wie kann man diese Frage so
ernst nehmen? Da muss man wirklich, es tut mir leid, Herr Schönborn, aber...
Das ist eine tolle Idee. Ich bin gespannt, wie es sich aussehen wird.
Es gibt ordentliche Gebäude.
Prima Ausstattung. Schöner Freizeitbereich.
Und dafür sorgen, dass die personelle Ausstattung stimmt. Dass da Fachkräfte
sind. Dass da auch Sonderpädagogen sind, die den Kindern helfen können.
Ich glaube, das hätte, wenn man Zauberkräfte hätte,
Ich würde mich meinen beiden Vorrednern anschließen. Ich würde,
wenn ich nur einen Wunsch frei habe, auch dafür sorgen, dass Schulen und Kindergärten
das sind, was sie in Sonntagsreden beschrieben werden, nämlich die Kathedralen unseres Landes.
Kathedralen unseres Landes.
Da kriegt man Tränen in die Augen. Ja. Das ist wirklich ... Na gut.
Schönborn zieht hier mal Lindners Argument raus.
Ich zeig mal kurz, damit man das noch besser versteht, Eine Grafik über die
Gruppe, über die wir sprechen, das sind jetzt die Kinder, die in Familien leben,
wo Grundsicherung, früher hieß das Hartz IV, jetzt Bürgergeld bezahlt wird.
Die beiden Säulen 2015 und ganz aktuell.
Und man sieht, die Säulen sind gleich hoch. Also, wir reden über einen Kreis
von etwa zwei Millionen Minderjährigen.
Also, nicht nur Kinder, sind auch Jugendliche jetzt mitgezählt.
Und der blaue Anteil sind Familien, die ja einen deutschen Hintergrund haben
oder sehr lange in Deutschland leben. Das waren vor acht Jahren ungefähr drei Viertel.
Und jetzt nur noch etwas mehr als die Hälfte der Betroffenen.
Also das ist die relative Armutsdefinition. In absoluten Zahlen ist der blaue
Balken genauso groß wie der von 2015, 2023.
Macht keinen Unterschied. Es wurde einfach nur gedrückt durch.
Ah ja, mehr arme Kinder. Gut.
Jetzt rutscht das einfach von der Etage weiter und sie fangen an mit dieser
Zauberei, wenn sie zaubern könnten, lassen sich diese Zahlen hier zeigen,
schlüsseln das nicht auf.
Es ist wirklich grotesk. Aber man hat noch mit Zahlen um sich geworfen.
Zumal teilweise auch Zahlen in die Debatte geworfen wurden, jetzt auch gerade
noch mal ganz aktuell, wo ich mich auch ein bisschen frage, wie belastbar ist
das? Es hat ja vor vergangener Woche noch mal diese Kurzstudie des DIW für Aufsehen gesorgt.
Da wurde quasi mit Verweis auf die OECD gesagt, Kinderarmut kostet uns 3,4 Prozent
des Bruttoinlandprodukts pro Jahr.
3,4 Prozent, das ist mehr als die Gasmangellage im Krieg in der Ukraine.
Und alles, was man zuletzt so hatte.
Das ist natürlich eine absolut furchteinflößende Schreckenszahl.
Da heißt es dann, ja, das sind quasi die aktuellen Kosten und die Folgekosten
von früherer Kinderarmut, weil eben jemand vor 30 Jahren arm war und dann jetzt
vielleicht nicht den Job, den er haben könnte. Da kann man dann einfach sehr viel reinrechnen.
Um in dem Dschungel und Gestrüpp von Zahlen und sich verschlingen zu lassen.
Er hat 3,4 Prozent BIP- genannt. Jetzt bloß nicht in den Zahlen verstolpern.
Wir müssen mal zurück zur Zauberei. Wo will er denn da hin?
Es ist wirklich grotesk. Aber wir können ja noch ein bisschen Schönborn zuhören.
Ich musste es dann noch mal hören, und dann habe ich es noch mal gehört.
Und mittlerweile, glaube ich, zehnmal. Der folgende Clip ist wirklich total schräg.
Ja, bin sehr gespannt.
Kinderarmut ist ja das eine. Also wir haben Kinder und die sind arm.
Aber es sind ja auch sehr viele Kinder einfach nicht da.
Wenn wir jetzt so an dieses, aber werden wir dann auch volkswirtschaftlich arm?
Also sind wir eigentlich arm an Kindern? Wir haben arme Kinder und sind arm
an Kindern. Also irgendwo ist ja noch so ein Personalmangel. Ja.
Angefangen bei Fachkräftemangel und so weiter.
Von dem man weiß, dass das ja immer die Rezession auslösen kann,
wie man ja in China beispielsweise ganz deutlich sieht. Japan wäre das andere Beispiel.
Also zu wenig Menschen heißt Wirtschaftsschrumpfung. Man kann es da konstruktiv
gestalten, weil es müssen ja weniger versorgt werden. Also es ging ja eigentlich.
Aber man muss es halt gestalten. Man kann nicht einfach mit einer Wachstumsideologie weitermachen.
Und jetzt kommt hier in dieses Kinderarmutsthema und wie man dem begegnet,
dieses Menschenmangel-Argument irgendwie rein. Aber auf so eine schräge Art und Weise.
Wir merken auch in der Diskussion, es gibt eine Decke, an der gezogen wird.
Sie haben das Beispiel genannt mit dem, was im Bundeshaushalt langzeitarbeitslos
und so gestrichen wird. Damit man auf der anderen Seite denselben Familien dann
über Kindergrundsicherung vielleicht was geben kann.
Begrenztheit von Geld zu tun. Aber ist es das alleine? Wir haben gehört,
die Organisationskraft, etwas an die Richtigen auszuzahlen, spielt auch eine Rolle.
Welche Rolle spielt einfach der Mangel an Menschen, die die Arbeit machen können?
So, gegen Kinderarmut hilft also Geld, aber auch Menschen, die diese Arbeit
machen können, nämlich sich um die ärmeren Kinder irgendwie zu kümmern.
Wir haben ja gerade gehört, eine Zauberidee, wir zaubern uns Lehrer her und so.
Und jetzt stellt er fest, naja, wir haben ja jetzt zu wenig Menschen,
die überhaupt verfügbar wären, um sich um arme Kinder zu kümmern,
weshalb wir ja Kinderarmut haben, die dazu führt, dass wir, da wir schon zu
wenig Kinder haben, deren Potenzial dann nicht ausschöpfen.
Ja, also es ist wirklich wahnsinnig grotesk, aber wir kommen jetzt zu unserer konstruktiven Wende.
Bleiben damit aber noch im Presseklub, denn der Presseklub hat ja Zuhörer.
Die dürfen ja anrufen. 45 hört die Sendung in der ARD auf, dann geht's bei Phoenix
weiter, und bei Phoenix hört man ja plötzlich Zuhörer. Und wir hören jetzt mal zwei Zuhörer an.
Dann würde ich sagen, gehen wir nach Berlin. Thorsten Hund hat das Wort. Hallo.
Ja, hallo, guten Mittag, guten Tag, alle zusammen im Studio und hier auch an den Fernsehzuschauer.
Mir stellt sich hier bei der ganzen Diskussion die Frage, hier offenbart sich
mir auch vor allen Dingen die Problematik, wie schäbig und wie asozial wir als
Gesellschaft mit unserem wertvollsten Gut, nämlich unserem Nachwuchs umgehen.
Warum begreifen wir nicht, ich weiß meine Gedanken sind vielleicht 50 Jahre
voraus, dass wir als wertvollstes Gut immer nur die Kinder haben.
Was nützt uns eine von Christian Lindner unterstützte Wirtschaft,
wenn die Kinder nicht entsprechend gefördert werden.
Gerade wenn sie in ihrer Ausbildung, in ihrer Jugend nicht die richtigen Impulse
bekommen, dann kann Christian Lindner mit seinem Geld machen,
was er will. Das geht alles dem Bach runter.
Abgesehen mal davon, dass unser gesamter Kapitalismus sowieso uns gerade um
die Ohren fliegt, wie wir sehen.
Wir sollten bei Kindern mal endlich darauf achten, dass egal wie viel es kostet,
es ist vollkommen egal, alles Alles was die Kinder brauchen muss finanziert werden.
Dann muss es eben woanders weggenommen werden. Und alle Menschen,
die mehr als genug Geld auf dem Konto haben, die aber jetzt keine Steuern zahlen
müssen, beziehungsweise nur Marginal, müssen viel härter herangezogen werden.
Jeder hat da sich dran zu beteiligen, weil ohne Kinder hat die Menschheit keine Zukunft.
Ich würde mal sagen, das sind 1 Minute 28, also es ist nahezu perfekt.
Den sollte man eigentlich mal in den Presseclub einladen.
Absolut, man soll den Burger Club machen. Weniger zaubern, mehr all in.
Also, lassen wir es so stehen.
Genial. Und wir hören noch eine zweite Stimme.
In Osterode am Harz ist Lutz Brinkmann in der Leitung. Herr Brinkmann.
Ja, guten Tag. Ich würde mal sagen, natürlich muss man das Geld in die Familie
geben und nicht politisch irgendwie verwalten oder machen. Das kann nicht richtig
sein. Meine Mutter war alleinerziehend.
Ich bin Jahrgang 54. Meine Schwiegermutter war alleinerziehend.
Und wenn Sie was lernen wollen, dann können Sie mich fragen,
ich kann Ihnen da helfen.
Das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Und wenn wir es nicht wollen,
okay, dann müssen wir eben einen anderen Weg gehen.
Aber die Eltern haben halt einfach mal die Pflicht, ihre Kinder groß zu kriegen
und alles mit auf den Weg zu geben, was sie wollen. Und die werden das auf jeden
Fall, oder die allermeisten jedenfalls, auf jeden Fall hinkriegen.
Egal wie. Und wenn Politik Sie nicht beteiligen will oder meint,
man muss die schwarze Null halten oder irgendwelchen Unfug, dann ist das eben
so. Aber das ist rausgeschmissenes Geld.
Alles, was heute nicht erledigt wird, wird in Zukunft sicher teurer werden.
Das sollte man vielleicht den Erlindern befragen, wo er das hernehmen will.
Danke schön, Herr Brinkmann. Das ist jetzt mehrfach gesagt worden,
vertraut den Eltern und hört auf mit dieser Diskussion.
Das Geld kommt nicht an, mag im Einzelfall der Fall sein, aber die allermeisten
werden es schon so einsetzen, dass es der Familie hilft.
Ja, den Mann kann man auch einladen.
Ja.
Auch ideal für die nächste Sendung.
Also, keine Ahnung wie repräsentativ das so ist, aber wir scheinen doch eine
sehr aufgeklärte Bürgerschaft zum Thema, egal was Journalisten im Fernsehen
über Monate abliefern, die Ihre Minute zu nutzen.
Also das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Und das waren ja jetzt keine ganz jungen Hörer, die angehört haben.
Nee, das war ja eher die Puma-Generation, die war jetzt da, die gescholtenen,
haben das aber sehr gut verstanden.
Also das ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Vielleicht weniger zaubern und weniger den üblichen Journalismus machen.
Gut, wir schließen mit den Clips aus der Bundespressekonferenz.
Nur wenige, also die Diakonie hat eingeladen.
Es saßen mehrere Fachmenschen da, unter anderem Marcel Fratsche und so weiter,
man hat ein bisschen mit den Zahlen um sich geworfen.
Und herausgekommen ist, dass in Deutschland ungefähr im Jahr 2019 circa 3,4
Prozent des Bibs in dieser Größenordnung die Folgekosten von Kinderarmut lagen.
Also das sind die Diakoniebeauftragten Autoren, kommen auf diese 3,4 Milliarden,
die eben im Presseklub schon angesprochen wurden.
Hier wird diese Prozentzahl nochmal in Euros umgerechnet.
Da hat sich die Studie in erster Linie auf Arbeitsmarktkosten und auch gesundheitsvolle
Kosten beschränkt und 3,4 Prozent des WIBs, das sind im Jahr 2019 ungefähr 110
bis 120 Milliarden Euro.
Also die mitgeschleppte Kinderarmut
kostet uns einfach 100 Milliarden volkswirtschaftliches Vermögen.
Immer ein Sondervermögen.
Ja, jedes Jahr ein Krieg gegen die Russen. So kostet uns das.
Einfach mal kein ordentliches Mittagessen, sondern Adipositas in Kauf zu nehmen,
keine Nachmittagsbetreuung, ordentlich, die den Geisten ein bisschen anregt, sondern.
Ja, dann sind die Handyspiele dran.
Genau, sowas. Also es ist eine Größenordnung, von der ich jetzt nicht glaube,
man müsste dann im Presseclub sagen, uiuiui, also da kann man ja viel reinrechnen
in diese Zahlen und ja, wir wollen jetzt eh nicht das Publikum damit belasten,
dass es hier um Zahlen geht.
Ich würde mal sagen, 100 Milliarden, das liegt ja auf der Hand,
wenn allein schon die Übergewichtskalkulation 60 Milliarden pro Jahr ausmacht.
Schulanfang. Einer der Autoren erklärt mal, wie das so ist, wenn man in Hannover
Feldforschung macht. Also nicht, wir lesen hier mal nur die Texte,
überlegen, was das so bedeutet, gucken in die Statistik, sondern einfach mal
in Hannover vor Ort sein.
War ich in Hannover in einem Stadtteil, der Schuldirektor einer Grundschule
in einem Stadtbezirk sagte mir, ein Drittel der Kinder, die hier ankommen,
sagen, sie sollen mich hier melden.
Die stehen da ohne irgendjemanden anderen, die haben keinen Ranzen dabei,
gar nichts. Die sagen, und was passiert denn jetzt hier?
So sieht der Schulanfang für diese Kinder in Hannover aus.
Unvorstellbar, ja. Und trotzdem ja überall. Also das ist ja das Interessante,
dass wir das auch jetzt hier nur über eine Pressekonferenz hören und es aber
doch auch nicht erfahren.
Also das ist ja schon interessant, dass man in einer Gesellschaft lebt,
wo man sich ja nicht selbst in einer gated community befindet und sagt,
man ist nie mehr aus dem Luxushotel rausgekommen oder so und deshalb weiß man es nicht.
Aber dass es eigentlich ganz nah ist, du selbst hast ja Kinder und dass man
hier solche Zahlen dann nochmal hört und ist einfach so schockiert darüber.
Ja, das ist einfach ganz schlimm.
Und also ich meine, ich habe jetzt das dritte Kind in der Grundschule.
Morgen ist ja wieder großer, nee am Dienstag ist großer Einschulungstag und
so. Also nächste Woche geht es ja eh wieder los.
Es ist ja nicht nur, dass Kinder, wie er sagt, der Vater schickt es dann einfach
rein und sagt, wird schon irgendwas passieren?
Keine Ahnung, ihr habt davon auch keine Ahnung oder so, sondern du hast ja auch
dieses grundsätzliche Eltern super engagiert und dann Klassenkasse.
Bitte fünf Euro für die Klassenkasse mitbringen und dann glühen die WhatsApp-Gruppen,
ob man das auch nächste Woche mitbringen kann und überhaupt und so.
Man muss erst mal warten, dass.
Also zu meiner Zeit hatte ich immer noch den Eindruck, kann natürlich trüben,
dass das so ein bisschen versteckt wurde irgendwie.
Ach und das ist jetzt auch so.
Mittlerweile ist diese Armut unter Eltern einfach ein ganz offenes Thema.
Ja, ist einfach völlig klar, wenn ein Ausflug ist oder so, dann muss da vorher
organisiert werden und dann hängen auch die Lehrer da mit drin und kümmern sich halt.
Ich frage mich dann auch, wenn man jetzt noch mal so zehn Jahre vorausdenkt,
ob man es nicht doch noch mal irgendwie organisiert kriegt, weißt du?
Also diese offensichtbare Schicksalsgemeinschaftlichkeit, die da so drin steckt.
Ja.
Aber wir sehen ja bei der ganzen Diskussion, Thema Vereinfachungen und so,
man weiß halt nicht genau, wie man es politisch kanalisiert.
Also auch Kommunalpolitik schon ist halt sehr anonym.
Man weiß nicht genau, wo sind die Adressen, wo kann man hier mal ein bisschen
für Aufmerksamkeit sorgen. Aber mittlerweile glaube ich, so ein bisschen sprechfähig
ist es schon. Also Armut ist jetzt nicht mehr dieses mega Tabu,
sondern mal gucken, wohin es führt.
Gut, kommen wir, ach so, diesen einen Punkt wollen wir uns natürlich den Endfakt
noch anhören zum Thema Studienlage.
Was machen Eltern mit Geld, wenn man es ihnen einfach so gibt,
ohne weitere programmatische, aber wir haben ja diese politische Zielsetzung
und überhaupt, da muss dieser wirtschaftliche Ertrag rauskommen,
sondern einfach nur mal pro Monat mehr Geld geben.
Das wirklich obszöne Vorurteil, dass Eltern einkommensschwache Familien Hilfen
nicht an ihre Kinder weitergeben, wird ja immer wieder geschworen.
Bereits 2018, liebe Damen und Herren, hat eine Bertelsmann-Studie,
die jetzt nicht als linksradikale Organisation verschrien ist,
ist, gezeigt, dass gerade Eltern in schwachen wirtschaftlichen Verhältnissen
alles bereit sind dafür zu tun, dass es ihren Kindern besser geht.
Und das finde ich auch intuitiv, so da brauche ich jetzt keine Studienlage,
aber gut, dass es sie gibt für die, die sie noch brauchen. Aber die brauchen
sie auch nur aus instrumentellen Gründen.
Also wenn es anthropologische Konstanten gibt, dann wohl diese.
Das nehme ich mal an. Ja, ja, genau. So, Marcel Franscha.
Man hat sich ja auch irgendwann mal entschieden Kinder zu haben.
Also das ist ja auch mit einem gewissen Zukunftsprojekt.
Ja, selbst wenn nicht. Wenn sie dann da sind, ist man halt trotzdem anders im Kopf. Ja, ja, klar.
Die Natur sorgt dann schon dafür, dass man die ganz frühen Sachen relativ zügig vergisst.
Also nicht nur die Kinder, sondern auch die Eltern. Und dann wächst man da so
rein und klar quält man sich zum Teil auch durch.
Aber das sind nach dem, was ich mitbekomme, dieses, das ist so anstrengend mit Kindern und so weiter.
Es sind die äußeren Umstände. Also es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie mein Kind ist
so hässlich oder sowas, sondern es ist immer nur dieses, ich würde gern,
ich möchte gern, es geht nicht, keine Zeit, kein Geld und so weiter,
man quillt sich da so durch.
Also in der Sicht haben wir es eigentlich mit, ich weiß ja auch nicht,
das ist eigentlich das einfachste Problem der Welt, Kinder haben zu wenig Geld,
was hilft gegen Armut? Geld. Also gibt man ihnen Geld, fertig ist die Laube.
Aber nein, aber nein. Gut, Marcel Fratscher macht jetzt so einen Punkt,
von dem ich sage, das kommt nicht nur eins zu eins in mein Buch,
sondern es wird noch in alle Richtungen entfaltet.
Im Grunde dient das ganze Buch nur dazu, dafür nochmal die Grundlage zu legen,
damit es eben, wenn man es einfach nur so weghört, nicht einfach direkt wieder
verschwindet, sondern damit man wirklich versteht, gerade jetzt in dieser krassen,
mega historischen, demografischen Zäsur. Wir wachsen nicht mehr.
Alles, was wir bisher als menschliche Errungenschaft von der Aufklärung,
von Wohlstand, von technischem Fortschritt und so weiter, das hat alles nur
mit Bevölkerungswachstum zu tun. Eins zu eins. Einfach nur eine Folge davon.
Und jetzt wachsen wir nicht mehr. Was machen wir jetzt?
Und Marcel Fratscher, ich glaube, ich werde ihn auch nochmal fürs Gespräch anfragen.
Eine wirklich wichtige Veränderung bei der Kindergrundsicherung wäre,
was ich Bringschuld und Hohlschuld vorhin genannt habe, dass man wirklich die
Logik des Sozialstaats, zumindest bei diesem Element, umdrehen würde.
Nicht, dass die Berechtigten es einfordern müssen, beantragen müssen,
was häufig eben mit extrem viel Bürokratie verbunden ist, sondern dass der Staat
in die Pflicht geht, zu sagen, wir stellen sicher, dass die Menschen es bekommen,
die, die es wirklich, die, die einen Anspruch haben.
Und das würde natürlich, also das ist eigentlich schockierend,
35 Prozent nur nehmen diese Leistungen in Anspruch, in vielen Fällen eben gar nicht.
Und das betrifft eben nicht nur den Kinderzuschlag, sondern eben viele andere
Elemente, wie das Bildungs- und Teilhabepaket und andere Elemente.
Und auch hier noch einmal zu denken, wir müssen weg von einem Sozialstaat,
der passiv ist, der konditionierend, sanktionierend ist, hin zu einem Sozialstaat,
der befähigend, unterstützend ist, der vorbeugend ist, gar nicht erst die Probleme entstehen lässt.
Ich glaube, das ist ein ganz wichtiges Element. Und das will ich noch einmal
betonen. Ich glaube, Gerade bei der Kindergrundsicherung geht es nicht nur um
die Verbesserung, Erhöhung der Leistung für Bedürftige, sondern eben auch um
diese Veränderungen der Logik.
Und das wäre wirklich ein großer Beitrag, den der Kindergrundsicherung dadurch leisten könnte.
Könnte, sie wird die nicht leisten. Es wird diese Umkehrung der Logik nicht geben.
Für unsere Bundesregierung ist weiterhin 1917, wir haben das ja im Film im Westen
nichts Neues. Im Buch steht es vielleicht auch so deutlich drin,
aber du hast es ja auch schon mal aus dem Film so zitiert.
Dieses, also grundsätzlich das Pratigma, im Westen nichts Neues,
aber der nächste Jahrgang wird es vielleicht richten.
Jetzt muss man sagen, es wird keinen neuen Jahrgang geben. Es sind Menschen
auf dem Feld und da sind sie.
Das ist die entscheidende Schicksal. Wenn die jetzt einfach alle totgeschlossen
werden, im Westen nichts Neues, dann sind alle tot. Es wird keinen neuen Jahrgang
geben und deswegen muss man mit diesen Ressourcen, und das werde ich im Buch
dann auch, klar, ich werde mich natürlich entsprechend immunisieren.
Ich sehe nicht Menschen als Ressourcen für die Wirtschaft und so weiter,
Aber angenommen, wir übernehmen jetzt einfach mal die Logik der FDP,
dieses Ressourcendenken.
Diese Ressource ist jetzt begrenzt. Fachkräftemangel heißt nicht,
ich habe eine offene Stelle und es bewerben sich nur noch sechs statt sieben
Leute, sondern es bewirbt sich gar keiner. Null. Das ist die Ausgangslage.
Und da muss man einfach anders überlegen, wie man zu Kindern kommt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Deutschland eine große Idee jetzt irgendwie hat oder
es eben, wie vorhin angesprochen, erstmals gelingen wird, den Zeugungs- und
Sozialisationsakt jenseits der Familie so zu organisieren, dass man einfach
sagt, okay, politisches Programm ist zwei Kinder pro Frau.
Also ja, was denn? Zwingen wir sie oder was?
Also nähern sich die Ressourcen sind knapp, wir kennen die Ressource,
wir wissen wie wir damit umgehen müssten, aber wir machen es nicht.
Maurice Höfgen schlug in der letzten Wirtschaftsbriefing in dieselbe Schneise,
er hat sich mal dieses Linden, dieses eine Linden Zitat rausgenommen.
Mein Anliegen, unser Anliegen ist es, Erwerbsanreize zu erhalten.
Das Beste, um Armut zu überwinden, ist Arbeit.
Denn der Grund für Kinderarmut ist ja oft die Armut an Arbeit,
an Integration, an Sprachkenntnissen der Eltern.
Deshalb darf von einer Reform der sozialen Unterstützungsleistungen für Familien
kein Anreiz ausgehen, nicht sich um Erwerbsarbeit, um Integration und Sprachkenntnisse zu bemühen.
Diesen Satz, den fand ich so Wahnsinn, weil was er übersetzt hier sagt ist,
Kinder sollen arm bleiben, damit die Eltern auch weiterhin jeden mies bezahlten
Drecksjob annehmen und damit,
dass die Eltern sich um Jobs kümmern sollen, die es gar nicht gibt,
weil es sind immer noch mehr Menschen arbeitslos, als es offene Stellen gibt.
Der spart gerade mitten in eine Krise hinein. Es wird also Arbeitslosigkeit dadurch gefördert.
Es gibt strukturell für viele gar nicht die Chance und wälzt das hier komplett,
das Thema arme Kinder auf die individuelle
Verantwortung der strukturell benachteiligten Eltern ab. Wahnsinn.
Ja, also Kinderarmut als Katalysator um den Schrott Arbeitsmarkt billig lohnen.
Zu füllen, weil ja die Elternliebe dazu führt, dass man dann wenigstens auch
diesen Job noch annimmt, damit es dem Kind ein bisschen besser geht.
Wird nicht mehr lange aufgehen. Also da ist alle Vorzeichen sind umgedreht.
Das ist einfach, dieser Drops ist gelutscht. Das war ein sehr gutes Programm
zwischen 1986 und 2020 bis zur Corona-Krise.
Also 86 so als das Jahr, in dem die Lohnzahlung und die gesellschaftliche Produktivität
entkoppelt wurden und man eben
nicht mehr einfach alle gleichmäßig am Wohlstand hat teilhaben lassen,
sondern sich dann so ein Finanzmarkt entwickelte und so weiter,
wo das Geld so ein Eigenleben führte und ist einfach vorbei.
In Amerika haben sie es ja verstanden, ja. Also Biden stand ja da und meinte,
trickle down ist Geschichte. Hat ja jetzt nochmal so ein Twitter-Video gemacht,
ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast, wo er das nochmal so richtig,
einfach so eine Tafel neben sich und dann malte er das so auf.
Ja, das trickelte dann so runter, das war die Idee, aber das, so ist nicht mehr.
Wir müssen jetzt von uns aus sagen, was wir wollen, müssen wir erstmal reininvestieren.
Also machen wir Geschenke einfach durch die Gesellschaft.
Und das bedeutet aber auch höhere Löhne. Und das ist das Erstaunliche,
dass es diese Lohnentwicklung, obwohl es so viel Mangel an Arbeitskräften gibt,
diese Lohnentwicklung nach oben nicht gibt.
Das ist so erstaunlich, denn in den USA hat es sie schon gegeben,
nicht überall und noch nicht genug sicherlich. Scott Galloway sagt,
wir brauchen eigentlich 25 Dollar Mindestlohn.
Das ist eine interessante Überlegung, die er da hatte. Die Gewerkschaften als
solche waren in Amerika, obwohl sie durchaus Macht hatten, nicht besonders erfolgreich.
Man müsste eigentlich so eine Massenbewegung haben für einen Mindestlohn von 25 Dollar.
Ich würde das auch mal adaptieren wollen für den deutschen Rahmen. Würde man es schaffen?
Eine Massenbewegung herzustellen, also in Form von Streiks oder Demonstrationen,
denken wir an irgendeine Mischung
aus Fridays for Future und dem was Gewerkschaften sonst so machen,
für einen höheren Mindestlohn, aber nicht nur für die, die jetzt gerade Mindestlohn
bekommen, dass die jetzt daran mitwirken, sondern dass man wirklich sagt,
wir wollen 18 Euro Mindestlohn, also deutlich mehr als jetzt,
jetzt wären wir bald dann 12,41 Euro.
Und man weiß aber mindestens 14 Euro müssten es sein, um nicht völlig arm zu sein im Halter.
Und wenn man jetzt auf 18 Euro geht, dann würde man damit natürlich einen enormen
Druck auch auf alle jene ausüben, die momentan so ein bisschen über Mindestlohn
bezahlen, aber die eigentlich alle zu wenig verdienen werden.
Ich finde es sehr erstaunlich und ich würde
es jetzt mal so auf dieser Privatunternehmer-Sicht betrachten wollen.
Ich merke immer mehr ja, dass Dinge, dass Geschäfte früher schließen,
dass Tage Ruhetage werden. Und dann wird immer gesagt wegen Personalmangel.
Onlinehandel.
Und ja, dann geht es in Onlinehandel. Aber ich gebe dir ein Beispiel,
ein Kosmetikstudio, das ich kenne,
das wahnsinnig gut läuft, hat jetzt plötzlich einen Ruhetag und es läuft aber
so gut, dass ich sagen würde, gut, die könnten wahrscheinlich noch nachts um
drei aufmachen und es würden immer noch Leute kommen.
Und das sind Behandlungen, die sind ja relativ teuer. Da geht man ja nicht hin und zahlt zehn Euro.
Sondern da sind ja ganz schnell 60, 80, 90, 140 Euro für verschiedene Dinge da.
Die machen irgendwelche aufwendigen Make-up-Sachen, auch die sind dann noch teurer.
Was auch immer. Und da ist doch interessant, da kein Personal für beschafft werden kann.
Dass da arbeitet, sodass die einen Ruhetag einlegen müssen.
Und das erlebt man ja jetzt bei sehr sehr vielen solchen Unternehmen und gerade
auch ich glaube bei Konzernen, da gibt es da im Personalmanagement ein anderes Denken.
Aber gerade so bei dem kleinen Mittelstand, den wir ja so unglaublich verehren
in Deutschland, sagt man eher schließe ich einen Tag, als dass ich mehr Lohn
zahle und Leute damit anlocke.
Denn volkswirtschaftlich betrachtet stimmt es natürlich, es fehlen Leute.
Und das ist ja das eine, aber man kann es ja jetzt für sich als privater Unternehmer
schon durch höhere Löhne schaffen, dass man Leute bekommt.
Genau das machen ja große Unternehmen, dass sie einfach sagen,
gut wir bieten 10.000 Euro mehr fertig.
Und hier wäre es ja die Frage, werden also in diesen,
Frisöre ist ja auch ein klassisches Beispiel dafür,
Restaurants ist auch ein ähnliches Beispiel, da werden aber Leute beschäftigt,
wenn man sich mal so ein bisschen umhört, was wird da so eigentlich gezahlt,
das findet man ja dann doch raus, man kann vielleicht nicht gerade den Chef
fragen, aber man findet schon raus, was so gezahlt wird.
Dann stellt sich doch heraus, dass selbst in diesen Restaurants oder Kosmetikstudios
oder was, wo relativ hohe Preise verlangt werden, Löhne bezahlt werden von 12,
13, vielleicht mal 14 Euro, mehr aber nicht.
Und es gibt da auch keinen Lohnanstieg und das ist erstaunlich,
also dass ich da nicht eine Kultur der Lohnerhöhung durchsetze,
um dann einfach bessere oder überhaupt mal Mitarbeiter zu bekommen.
Also ich kann ja auch nicht sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne einen Assistenten,
dem gebe ich fünf Euro die Stunde und der trägt mir die Koffer hinterher oder so.
Da muss man sagen, ja dann bist du halt schief gewickelt, dann geht es halt nicht.
Und genauso muss man muss man diesen Unternehmen dann einfach sagen ja dann
ist die Zeit vorbei oder sie nehmen dann entsprechende Preisanpassungen vor.
Und das ist ja das Verrückte in einem Restaurant
wo man zu zweit ist und dann ist da schon fast ein dreistelliger Betrag für
das Essen fällig ja für zwei Hauptgerichte und dann soll aber nicht kann man
nicht von diesen da gibt es nicht genügend Gewinnmarge um zwei Euro mehr Lohn die Stunde zu zahlen.
Oder bei einer Kosmetikbehandlung, die 90 Euro kostet, da ist dann alles aufgebraucht
und da können nur 12 Euro gezahlt werden dem Angestellten. Ich glaube, nein.
Oder wenn es denn so ist, da muss man sagen, kostet halt diese komische Kosmetikbehandlung
ab jetzt 92 Euro und die zwei Euro gehen dann eben an die Mitarbeiter.
Aber das ist so interessant, dass jetzt auch hier, Wir hatten so einen Bericht,
ich weiß nicht, ZDF oder ARD.
Tankstellenbesitzer, die sagten, ja also jetzt mit dieser Mindestlohnerhöhung,
die jungen Leute haben nur noch Urlaub im Kopf.
Ich sage ihnen mal, wenn wir jetzt die Mindestlohnerhöhung haben,
das kostet mich dann im Jahr 5000 Euro mehr, die ich an Lohn zahlen muss.
Dafür könnte ich auch schön Urlaub machen.
Also sein Originalzitat war, das wäre auch für mich ein schöner Urlaub gewesen.
Also man wirft den jungen Leuten vor, sie wollen Urlaub und er sagt,
ja da muss ich jetzt, wenn die Mindestlohn-Erhöhung kommt, dann hast du ein
nicht profitables Geschäft offenbar, dann lass es sein, dann musst du untergehen
oder du machst Preisanhebungen, die Tankenstellenpreise sind ja sowieso so eine Sache.
Wir haben ja eben die älteren Herrschaften im Presseklub gehört,
die ja, also da muss man ja wirklich sagen.
Alle stabil.
Mit denen könnte man ja zusammen das eine oder andere anstoßen.
Ich habe gestern einen Tweet gemacht, der natürlich auch wieder ein bisschen
kontrovers gelesen wurde.
Die Jugend ist einfach nicht bereit anzupacken, Ausrufezeichen,
sagen die Älteren. Die sagen aber auch, und dann Politbarometer, Fachkräftemangel.
Sollte der vorzeitige Renteneintritt erschwert werden, 79 Prozent sagen nein.
Also, wir haben es hier offenbar mit, ich würde mal sagen,
wohlwollend, einer Missverständlichkeit zu tun im Sinne von,
nee, wir können ruhig der Jugend so ein paar diese Freiräume lassen,
die ja sowieso schon begrenzt sind, aber auch den Rentnern.
Also eigentlich sind sich in Sachen Lebensarbeitszeit, Jugend und die Älteren
ziemlich einig, dass sie nicht
länger und auch nicht früher und auch nicht überfordernd arbeiten wollen.
Alles ganz vernünftig. Und jetzt werde ich den letzten Clip spielen von Marcel Fratscher,
auch mit dem Verweis auf, dass ich nächste Woche am siebten abends in Hamburg bin,
bei der Zeitstiftung, bei einer Veranstaltung und am sechsten zehnten,
also zwei Tage vor den Landtagswahlen, in Hessen und in Bayern in Taufkirchen,
bei der Volkshochschule in München, um dort nochmal einen Punkt auch zu machen.
Ich weiß ja, wer da so als Publikum kommt, außer ihr seid jetzt aufgerufen,
natürlich da auch zu kommen, mich zu unterstützen.
Aber dieser folgende Clip hat es ein bisschen in sich, hinsichtlich dieser großen
strukturellen Fragen, wie du sie jetzt aufgeworfen hast.
Wir hören mal Marcel Fratscher zu und behalten alles im Hinterkopf,
was ich jetzt insgesamt schon dazu gesagt habe.
Also man darf das Kinderthema ruhig mal ein bisschen unemotional nüchtern,
durchaus im Sinne der FDP.
Es geht ja um die Volkswirtschaft und so weiter, aber es sind eben von 80 Jahren
Leben nur 45 Jahre Erwerbsarbeit und zwar einfach so mittendrin.
So sagen wir mal von 25 bis 70 oder von 20 bis 65, je nachdem wie man so in
diesem Range irgendwo verstecken sich 45 Jahre, die man zum Leben braucht,
aber man wird halt 80 Jahre.
Und jetzt haben wir einen Start, der...
Zum einen, wenn man die aktuelle Regierung hört, sagt, da müsste selber Vorleistung
gehen. Also können die hier nicht unterstützen und so.
Der aber gleichzeitig sagt, ja, wenn du einmal gearbeitet hast,
wir bezahlen es dir, dein Rentenanspruch ist nur so und so, naja,
wir haben ja noch einen Bundeshaushalt, wir schießen was zu.
Und diese Schieflage, die ich eben schon aufwarf, die hat Marcel Fratscher hier
nochmal auf den Punkt gebracht. Und ich finde, das könnte man durchaus mal,
also ich sehe mich da schon so auf der Bühne, wie ich das Publikum anschaue
und sage, ist das nicht ein Gedanke wert?
Jetzt da zu verglichen, ob das jetzt 4 Milliarden oder 5 Milliarden sind,
das ist natürlich absolut eine Summe, 5 Milliarden Euro, aber im Vergleich zu
dem, was an Kindergeld ausgezahlt wird, ist es eben relativ begrenzt.
Vielleicht noch ein anderes Beispiel, der Staat steuert jedes Jahr über 100
Milliarden Euro an Steuerzuschüssen für die gesetzliche Rente bei,
das auch nochmal in Proportion zu setzen.
Ich glaube, es ist immer ganz wichtig, eine Vergleichsgrößen zu haben,
wofür gibt der Geld Staat aus. dann auch um die Prioritäten.
Und Sie sehen bei diesen Zahlen, dass egal welche Szenarien Sie nehmen,
die Summen zwar absolut gesehen nicht trivial sind, aber im Vergleich zu anderen
Größenordnungen jetzt nicht unbedingt überbordend.
So, der Staat zahlt sachfremd 100 Milliarden, mehr als 100 Milliarden jedes
Jahr in die Rentenkasse ein.
Dieses Geld wurde nicht einfach so von den alten Leuten über die Sozialbeiträge erarbeitet oder sowas,
sondern das ist eine sachfremde für die Kassen, die das verwalten,
zusätzliche Leistung, die wir einfach abknapsen aus unserem volkswirtschaftlichen
Durchlauferhitzer, wir so Faktwirtschaft nennen.
Warum haben die Alten Anspruch darauf und die Jungen nicht? In dieser Größenordnung.
Warum bezahlen wir? Wir wollen den Alten diesen Anspruch nicht nehmen.
Wir wollen es nur in Relation setzen zu den Jungen.
Wir wollen immer über diese Relation nachdenken. Und dann gemeinsam überlegen,
welche Forderungen wir stellen können. Jung und Alt. Wir wollen es den Alten nicht wegnehmen.
Die Rente ist in Deutschland im Durchschnitt dreistellig.
Und ob nicht höhere Löhne auch dazu beitragen könnten, dass die Rentenkassen
ein bisschen besser gefüllt sind, stelle ich mal so hin.
Grundsätzlich diese Frage Leistungsgesellschaft.
Verlangen wir von den Menschen leistungsbereit zu sein und dann geben wir ihnen auch was zurück?
Oder sehen wir es als staatliche Aufgabe Menschen in Leistungsbereitschaft zu
bringen? Er ist kein Selbstläufer.
Und in der Hinsicht liegen hier noch einige Fragestellungen auf dem Tisch,
gerade für diese veränderten demografischen Vorzeichen Das Fratscher,
das auf der Bühne einfach mal so in 40 Sekunden rauswirft als Thema,
ist natürlich als Einladung meinerseits dankend angenommen.
Als so ein bisschen Freigeist. Ich muss ja hier nicht für ein Institut oder
sowas sprechen oder für einen Verlag oder für einen Arbeitgeber oder so.
Ich kann ja auf die Bühne gehen und sagen, also der Fratscher,
ich weiß nicht, ob Sie den kennen, ich würde dem jetzt mal nicht widersprechen,
ist schon einer dieser Top 5 Institutsleitenden Ökonomen in Deutschland,
hat da mal so einen Vergleich gemacht.
Mal sehen, wie viel Gaudi das bringt. Seid gern dabei.
Musik Wir springen ganz kurz zum Krieg. Es ist ja im Prinzip die Lage keine
besonders andere. Also es ist nach wie vor alles sehr schlimm.
Dieser Krieg dauert an. Viele gehen davon aus, dass er noch sehr,
sehr lange weitergehen wird.
Man weiß es nicht sehr genau, aber mir sind noch so ein paar Dinge aufgefallen,
die ich eigenartig fand.
Und zwar gab es ja dieses Vorgehen von Selenskyj gegen die Korruption im eigenen
Land. Und diese Korruption, die sah ja wie folgt aus. Wir hören jetzt hier einen Beitrag von Welt TV.
Viele der Ukrainer, die wollen das aber nicht mehr. Die sind natürlich nach
vielen Monaten im Krieg auch kriegsmüde.
Und deswegen gibt es beispielsweise solche Telegram-Gruppen in Kiew und damit
warnen sich die Bürger in Kiew gegenseitig, wo Rekrutierungsoffiziere auf den
Straßen unterwegs sind.
Denn viele Ukrainer haben Angst, dass sie beispielsweise beim Spazieren gehen
oder beim Einkaufen einfach von der Straße weg rekrutiert werden.
Wenn man diesem Video hier Glauben schenken darf, dann läuft das teilweise auch
relativ brutal ab. Ein Mann wird von ukrainischen Rekrutierungsoffizieren in ein Auto gezerrt.
Wir hatten irgendwann mal im Salon einen Artikel aus der jungen Welt,
bei dem ich fast vorsichtig war, ihn vorzulesen, sollen wir es wirklich machen
und so, zwangsvoll Rekrutierung.
Jetzt wird da bei Welt TV einfach mal so drüber berichtet, dass dem so ist und
der Korruptionsvorwurf ist, und der hat sich ja dann auch in dem Sinne bestätigt,
dass man sich wohl mit so etwa 10.000,
Euro aus diesem Rekrutierungsprozess rauskaufen kann.
Also dass man nicht rekrutiert wird, dass man dann nicht gemustert wird und
sich dann auch eigentlich nicht mehr diesem Kriege entziehen kann.
Das heißt also, es wird extremer Zwang vom Staat ausgeübt.
Jetzt wurde das vor allem so rezipiert, Selensky greift durch und wie kann das
denn sein mit der Korruption und jetzt aber wird aufgeräumt.
Aber man kann ja daran sehen, wenn Leute bereit sind, 10.000 Euro zusammenzukratzen,
dass sie nicht rekrutiert werden.
Dass sie offenbar nicht ein so hohes Interesse daran haben, in den Krieg zu ziehen für ihr Land.
Ich kann das vollkommen nachvollziehen, dass das so ist. Ich würde,
wenn ich jetzt einen Hutbaufreund in der Ukraine hätte, und der braucht 10.000
Euro, würde ich, dass sie ihm möglich machen, dass er da auch raus kann.
Daran zeigt sich ja schon mal etwas sehr deutliches, was aber die ganze Zeit
nicht thematisiert wurde.
Jetzt aber plötzlich dann im Zuge einer solchen Korruptionswelle,
die da ein bisschen angegangen wird, thematisiert wird.
Jelensky hat,
mit präsidialer Befugnis alle Büroleiter, alle Rekrutierungsbüros entlassen.
So flächendeckend war dieses in Anführungszeichen Korruptionsproblem,
dass junge Männer einfach gesagt haben, für 10.000 Euro kaufe ich mich frei.
Wir müssen nochmal daran erinnern, das volkswirtschaftliche Niveau der Ukraine
war schon vor dem Krieg so, dass 10.000 Euro dort, 100.000 Euro hier sind.
Also das ist exakt wie du sagst,
also das pro Kopf BEP liegt bei etwa 5000 Euro im Jahr und die zahlen also zweimal das pro Kopf BEP,
also eine enorme Summe, was auch wieder heißt, diesen Krieg zu beenden.
Erleben müssen vor allem die, die diese 10.000 Euro dann auch nicht beraten können.
B1 Und weil du eben von manchen Argumenten muss man mutig voranbringen.
Ich will noch mal daran erinnern, wenn der Kongress 40 Milliarden Waffendieferung
entscheidet, dann werden für 40 Milliarden Waffen geliefert,
bevor die an der Front landen, werden gehen die erst mal durch drei Hände.
Also da sind Wertschöpfungsketten drin und so weiter und so fort,
dass diese diese Geschichten aus dem Ukraine Krieg, die so nahe liegen und so zwangsläufig sind,
dass man sie einfach wirklich nicht abstreiten kann, einfach so,
liebe Hörer. Ich kenne ja manche unserer Pappenheimer.
Wir werden von diesem Krieg noch ein paar Geschichten hören.
Ja, und du hast es jetzt gerade angesprochen mit dem US-Kongress.
Wir sehen das in Deutschland ja auch, Rheinmetall auf der Gamescom vertreten.
Und natürlich ein unglaublicher Kriegsgewinnler, auch wenn die jetzt gerade
sagen, nee, nee, wir profitieren nicht von diesem Krieg.
Ja, wovon denn sonst? Wovon denn sonst? Aber diese Profite einfahren,
tun am Ende die, die mit den Waffen kämpfen.
Und das sind dann nicht irgendwelche Leute aus Thinktanks oder so,
sondern das sind die da in der Ukraine.
Also ich will das nicht überstrapazieren, aber wir wagen uns ja gerne ein bisschen vor.
Aber es ist ja doch erstaunlich, dass wir immer mal wieder irgendwelche Sachen
haben, für die man sich engagieren will, auch wenn sie nicht direkt hier vor Ort sind.
Also das eine sind ja zum Beispiel, dass es Flüchtlinge gibt,
die hier ankommen, um die man sich dann direkt kümmert. Aber es gibt ja doch
auch sehr viele, die über die deutschen Landesgrenzen hinaus Hilfe leisten.
Zum Beispiel dann Seenotrettung oder andere Projekte.
Immer mal wieder ein paar Namen und die tauchen dann auf bei Twitter oder auch
mal in Sendungen oder so und finden das ja unglaublich bemerkenswert,
mit wie viel Mut und Engagement da für die gute Sache gekämpft wird.
Ich erlebe aber interessanterweise ja beim Krieg, dass wir zwar da unglaublich
viele Befürworter haben, die die ganze sagen, jetzt ist auch mal Schluss mit
der Spaßgesellschaft und alles.
Aber da haben wir noch keinen einzigen Bekannten je gesehen,
der gesagt hat, ja, ich kämpfe jetzt damit. Also das steht ja den Deutschen
frei. In der Schweiz ist das ja verboten.
Achso, ja genau. Die Deutschen könnten aber.
Man könnte sich, aber das, das, also es gibt ja dann ein paar,
die zurückgekehrt sind, die aber nicht aus diesem Spektrum sind,
die dann auch bei Lanz mal gesessen haben und gesagt haben, wie das dann da alles verlaufen ist.
Meistens sehr chaotisch. Aber dann finde ich ja doch interessant,
dass man da nochmal sagt, okay, ja, also die sollen das mal machen,
aber ich jetzt selbst, dann lieber doch nicht.
Was ich sehr verstehe, ich finde nur, da müsste man ja auch schon mal so eine
gewisse Kluft merken, dass man sagt, ja, dieser Krieg ist dann doch offenbar nicht so ganz meiner.
Das würde ich auch mal sagen. Und natürlich, wir wissen auch nicht,
wie viele Leute für die Russen damit kämpfen aus Deutschland.
Also wir haben ja auch so eine nicht ganz unterschwellige,
anti-amerikanische Haltung, die immer noch nicht ganz so wahrhaben möchte,
dass vielleicht die Russen und so weiter doch auch und so nicht die allerbesten
deutsch-sovietischen Freunde und Nachlassverwalter sind.
Und in deren Sicht geht es drunter drüber. Also dieser Krieg,
wir haben es ja schon ein paar Mal thematisiert, wie viel Jahrzehnte so was nachwirkt.
Bis hin zu epigenetischen Stressvererbungen und so weiter.
Und ich bin überrascht, dass wir, obwohl der jetzt schon anderthalb Jahre so
geht, diese Art der Bücher eigentlich noch nicht haben. Aber wer weiß.
Ja, sind momentan offenbar nicht gewünscht. Wir hören jetzt aus den Tagesthemen,
Vasili Golot ist dazu gescheitert. auch noch mal um diese Korruptionsaffäre.
Der ukrainische Präsident hat heute alle Leiter der für die militärische Rekrutierung
zuständigen Regionalbüros entlassen.
Was steckt dahinter? Das war in der Tat eine sehr bemerkenswerte Entscheidung.
Es brodelte aber auch schon die ganze Zeit. Es gab Fälle von Korruption,
viele Fälle von Korruption.
Das war hier im Land auch ein offenes Geheimnis, über das sich die Zivilgesellschaft
aufgeregt hat, dass man sich für einen Betrag von etwa 10.000,
Dollar als Mann freikaufen konnte, um nicht eingezogen zu werden und Selenskyj
hat das heute mit sehr, sehr scharfen Worten verurteilt, hat gesagt, das ist zynisch.
Also diesen Clip habe ich auch mir parat gelegt, weil hier doch diese Eiseskälte
von, ja die Die haben sich da freigekauft vom Krieg.
Nee, die wollten einfach leben.
Also die haben sich einfach vom Tod freigekauft. Krieg ist hier tot.
Wir haben es mit so krassen Zahlen zu tun.
Würde jeden Kredit aufnehmen, um das nicht zu machen.
Also das 10.000 Euro.
Und dann noch zu sagen, das hat die Zivilgesellschaft verärgert.
Naja, da werden sie sich ganz viel geärgert haben, die 10.000 Euro nicht zu haben.
Das ist gewiss. Aber ich finde das ... Und dann auch noch zwei Sachen.
Er sagt, es gab viele Fälle und es war ein offenes Geheimnis.
Warum erfahre ich von diesen vielen Fällen und diesem offenen Geheimnis erst Mitte August?
Warum muss ich mir das sonst irgendwo zurechtsuchen, wo ich das bei Twitter
zum Teil nicht nachvollziehen kann, ob es stimmt, weil man ja immer in die Gefahr
gerät, dann auf Putin-Trolle reinzufallen.
Aber wenn das ja ein offenes Geheimnis war, warum ist dann ein Korrespondent
nicht mal in der Lage, dieses offene Geheimnis zu berichten,
denn das ist ja seit Monaten, eigentlich seit Kriegsbeginn, dann zu erleben gewesen.
Das ist ja ein Offenbarungseid, dieses Interview.
Und wir kommen zu einem weiteren Offenbarungseid, den ich nicht selbst rausgefischt
habe, sondern Matthias bei Twitter hatte da Clips gepostet.
Und die habe ich jetzt einfach mal hier reinkopiert. Und zwar gibt es Markus
M. Kolb, der ist Militärexperte von der ETH Zürich und wird laufend zugeschaltet,
im privaten wie im öffentlich-rechtlichen.
Wir hören den jetzt hier im September 22.
Also das ist jetzt ziemlich genau ein Jahr her.
Ich habe mir mal den Spaß gemacht, es durchzurechnen. Wenn Sie mal schauen,
Russland hatte vor dem Krieg ungefähr 2700 einsatzfähige Panzer westlich der Volga.
Davon sind laut der Oryx-Liste jetzt 1.155,
vernichtet oder von den Ukrainern angeeignet. Wir sind heute Tag 208 des Krieges.
Das ergibt also eine Verlustquote von 5,5 Panzern pro Tag.
Also mit anderen Worten, der Krieg dauert noch 280 Tage und dann hat Russland keine Panzer mehr.
So sagte er im September.
Sagte er vor 350 Tagen.
Vor einem Jahr. Sagte er vor 350 Tagen. Der Krieg ist aber noch im Gange und
ich habe jetzt auch noch gehört, dass der endet. Ich will das nochmal,
weil immer wieder, wenn sich Leute zum Krieg geäußert haben,
wie Habermas oder Alexander Kluge, das sind ja gar keine Militärexperten.
Was halten wir von Militärexperten? Wir bringen noch einen weiteren Clip,
der ist etwas länger, aber wir hören uns trotzdem an.
Selber Experte. April 23, Frühjahrsoffensive.
In diesem Win-Interview habe ich das am Beispiel der Panzer vorgerechnet.
Wie lange reicht die Konsensschätzung über Russlands einsatzfähige Panzer noch,
bis sie endgültig alle weg sind?
Und die ähnliche Rechnung können Sie für andere schwere Fahrzeuge,
also für Armored Fighting Vehicles und Infantry Fighting Vehicles, aufmachen.
Ich entschuldige mich ein bisschen für das Denglisch. Mir fallen jetzt gerade
die deutschen Fachbegriffe nicht ein.
Aber wenn Sie schauen, mit welcher unglaublichen Rate diese Reserven abschmelzen,
dann kommen Sie sehr bald an einen Punkt, wo Russland einfach nicht mehr in
der Lage ist, überhaupt noch Operationen zu führen. Das heißt,
das Einzige, was Sie dann tun können, ist, sich einzugraben.
Das ist aber keine gute Idee, weil gegenüber steht ein anderes Technologieniveau,
denn die Ukraine geht jetzt im Laufe des Frühjahrs und Sommers eben über von
alter sowjetischer Technologie auf westliche Technologie, also insbesondere
auf westliche Kampfpanzer und auf westliche Infanteriefahrzeuge wie zum Beispiel
den Bradley oder den Marder.
Und das darf man auf keinen Fall unterschätzen, diesen Effekt.
Bisher kämpft in diesem Krieg Sowjetmaterial gegen Sowjetmaterial,
aber das wird sich fundamental ändern.
Und sobald die ukrainische Frühjahrsoffensive losgeht, also ich rechne so etwa
Mitte April damit, da wird man diesen Technologieeffekt dann deutlich sehen.
Und das wird dann zu einer noch größeren Verlustrate der Russen führen.
Wenn Sie das so ein bisschen zusammen sich überlegen, wozu führt das eigentlich
in der Gefechtsführung, dann ist eigentlich gar kein anderer Ausgang denkbar.
Ich denke, Europa ist einfach im Moment so sehr durchseucht von der russischen Propaganda,
dass viele es schwierig finden, das zu glauben und deswegen sage ich immer,
sie müssen das nicht glauben, es ist keine Frage des Glaubens,
sie müssen einfach die Zahlen sich angucken und die Abnutzungsrate betrachten
und dann kommen sie eigentlich schon zu belastbaren Schlussfolgerungen.
Tja, die Modellierung.
Da ist die Modellierung, hat irgendwie zweimal jetzt nicht so gut funktioniert,
aber er sendet nach wie vor weiter, also ist ja jede Woche irgendwo zu erleben,
wird dann ja auch immer von den wohlbekannten Twitter-Profilen eifrig geteilt.
Und ich frage mich, warum kann man das nicht mal, auch wenn man so eine Redaktion
ist und man lädt den ja ein, warum kann man dann nicht mehr sagen,
ja, aber irgendwie waren ja so die Prognosen nicht so immer so 100 Prozent korrekt.
Also was hat man sich damals aufgeregt, wenn Richard David Precht irgendwas
gesagt hat, so im freien Dialog.
Und hier wird immer ein Experte, der das mal ganz ohne Glauben,
sondern an reinen Fakten durchrechnet, das wird alles durchgehen gelassen.
Naja, und das erinnert mich jetzt schon fast an die Crash-Propheten,
die immer sagen, ja, der Crash kommt, wenn man das jeden Tag sagt, irgendwann kommt er.
Irgendwann hat er auch gestern recht gehabt.
Das stimmt. Und irgendwann wird auch dieser Krieg zu Ende sein.
Und irgendwann wird auch Russland erkennen, dass es nicht weitergeht oder was
weiß ich, oder man wird das gemeinsam erkennen, wie auch immer. Es ist absurd.
Vielleicht noch ein Letztes, hat nicht mit dem Krieg direkt zu tun,
aber doch mit der Berichterstattung.
Wir müssen heute doch ein bisschen Medienschild machen, weil ich habe mich schon
immer geärgert über das Wort Sommerloch.
Für mich gibt es kein Sommerloch. Nur weil die jetzt gerade nicht im Bundestag
reden schwingen, gibt es ja kein Sommerloch.
Als wir jetzt hier diesen Podcast geplant haben, also jeder für sich plant den
ja, dann dachte ich gut, das kriege ich gar nicht mehr rein, das schaffe ich nicht.
Also ich nehme ja lauter Sachen raus und weiß schon jetzt, was ich mitgebracht
habe, dass es wahrscheinlich heute gar nicht alles gehen wird.
Und wie kann dann ein solcher Bericht zustande kommen?
Baerbock wollte fliegen und kam nicht weg.
Szenen wie aus täglich grüßt das Murmeltier, das gibt es doch nur bei der deutschen Flugbereitschaft.
Nein, sagt die Kollegin vom Schweizer Fernsehen, die Eidgenossen,
übrigens auch ein Ingenieursvolk, haben genau dieselben Probleme.
Bundespräsident Guy Barbelin, der wollte eigentlich nach Japan,
hatte ein Treffen mit dem japanischen Kaiser und kam dort nie an.
Er musste umdrehen wegen einer technischen Panne an seinem Flugzeug.
Genauso der Außenminister.
Statt in China landet er in Moskau. Das kommt immer wieder mal vor.
Also man hat jetzt noch mal bei den Schweizer Kollegen nachgefragt,
wir haben hier einen Fall Baerbock. Also man merkt ja, man hatte eigentlich
nichts zu berichten und muss ja jetzt so ein bisschen Fleisch dran bekommen.
Das ist ja die Vorgehensweise.
Ach, wir gucken mal, ob schon mal irgendwo anders ein Regierungsflieger nicht abheben konnte.
Jetzt Auftritt Scholz, kommt auch die Treppe runter. Bei ihm hat es offenbar geklappt.
Der einzige, der bisher immer ankommt, ist der deutsche Kanzler,
denn er benutzt den neuen, teuren A350.
Der aber sei für Baerbock nicht verfügbar gewesen, sagt das Verteidigungsministerium.
Das wundert nicht wenige Parlamentarier.
Langstreckenflugzeuge, ganz neue Airbus A350, die der Haushaltsausschuss genehmigt
hatte, die auch angeschafft worden sind.
Warum ist Annalena Baerbock mit diesem uralten A340 unterwegs gewesen?
Hat da die Hackordnung im Bundeskabinett vielleicht daran verhindert,
dass die Bundesaußenministerin das für diesen Flug eigentlich geeignetere Flugzeug hätte nutzen können?
Behindert also Kanzler Scholz. Außenministerin Baerbock, damit sie im Ausland
nichts mehr anrichten kann.
Ist das vielleicht die neue Verschwörungstheorie, die wir brauchen?
Es ist vor allem die Frage, die wir in diesem, die Regierung ist eine Familie und so.
Ja, ja, das ist ja so, man wartet auf die Familie, ist im Urlaub,
dann kriegt man SMS, ja wird doch zwei Stunden später, kannst du uns am Flughafen abholen?
Ach, was ist denn los? Ja, Maschine hat einen Defekt. Also das sind ja genau
diese Modi, in denen man eigentlich das familiäre oder Freundschaftliche versucht,
unter einen Hut zu bekommen. Es geht noch weiter.
Ist also am Ende der Bundeskanzler an diesen Szenen schuld?
Also das war jetzt von mir nicht nur so eine verrückte Moose-Maßnahme,
sondern sprechen die auch noch mal in den Tagesthemen aus.
Oh wei.
Bevor diese Frage geklärt werden kann, am Ende zähle, dass alle gesund gelandet
seien, sagt die Vorsitzende des Verteidigungsausschusses.
Shit happens, das ist blöd, aber möge uns nichts Schlimmeres passieren.
Ja, Strackzimmer, man lässt sich auch nochmal dafür zuschalten.
Du hast zum Glück nicht noch diesen ZDF-Clip, ich habe ihn mit Mick im Fernsehpodcast
gehört, wie der Typ nochmal erklärt, was es genau bedeutet, wenn Annalena Baerbock
dann per Twitter sagt, verflixt.
Das heißt nämlich verflixt und zugenäht und noch ein verdammt oben drauf.
Also Originalzitat, Journalisteneinschätzung. Sie haben jetzt bei den Schweizern
nachgefragt, man hätte auch nochmal nachfragen können bei der für uns alle sehr
viel wichtigeren als die Bundesregierung Europäischen Kommission.
Wie macht die Europäische Kommission?
Ursula von der Leyen hat einen Termin in, sagen wir mal Singapur,
also geht zu fluege.de oder booking, bucht sich einen Flug und fliegt dahin.
Wollte doch Hannah Lehner auch eigentlich machen, sie wollte doch viel mehr lieben ihr Fliegen.
Wollte sie nicht, ja, aber das ist, Robin Alexander hat diese Frage auch nochmal gestellt.
Üblicherweise war das so, während der Merkel-Zeit, ja, aus Convenience-Gründen
fliegt die ganze Journalisten-Entourage da so mit und dann hat man auf dem Flug
noch so ein bisschen Zeit.
Das finde ich auch absolut legitim und so. Wenn es aber nicht klappt,
hat die Merkel-Regierung einfach umgebucht, hat die Termine trotzdem eingehalten.
Die Journalisten mussten halt gucken, wo sie bleiben, konnten ja hinterherfliegen,
aber dann selber buchen.
Und das hat Annalena Baerbock nicht gemacht. Und zwar einmal nicht und beim
zweiten Mal nochmal nicht.
Und da hat sie diese Termine, die sie hatte, die politischen,
geopfert, weil es keine Medientermine werden konnten ohne landeseigene Fotografen dabei.
Und ich finde das ist ehrlicherweise ein Riesenskandal, der wurde gar nicht thematisiert.
Alena Baerbock muss ihre politischen Termine einhalten, auch wenn ihre Medienmeute
nicht mitfliegt. Ja, also es ist einfach, ich finde es grotesk, aber ja.
Aber das ist ja auch, das ist ja der Bericht aus dem Regierungsflieger für die
im Regierungsflieger, für niemand anders. Also das ist ja so zu gucken,
wir gucken mal, wie geht es Mama und Papa?
Es war schwierig, Mama wollte Linie fliegen, Papa hat aber gesagt,
wir nehmen den Jet und na, hat es wieder nicht geklappt. Also das ist der Modus,
in dem wir hier auf Politik blicken und wir schauen, ob es ihnen gut geht,
unseren lieben Politikern.
Ja, da wird einfach das Tagebuch der Regierungsprotagonisten fortgeschrieben.
Wir sprechen in diesem Podcast so gut wie nie über die AfD, weil diese Partei,
wie du so schön sagst, die Partei des Hasses ist.
Und ich habe das von Michel Friedmann übernommen, natürlich.
Und ich will dazu sagen, gleich am Anfang, kann man ja gleich mal so prime.
Wenn man über die AfD spricht, redet man über eine politische Partei,
die hat natürlich ein politisches Programm und Personal und so weiter.
Man könnte über alles mit denen reden, aber, und das ist der Fehler im Journalismus,
wenn sie es denn machen, vergessen sie immer diesen Nachsatz dann noch.
Aber lieber Herr So und So, oder nochmal im Programm nachgucken,
warum müssen wir deswegen jetzt Menschen im Mittelmeer töten?
Ist ja schön, dass sie was für die Kinder, für irgendwas machen wollen,
aber warum müssen dafür jetzt Menschen sterben? Warum hassen sie deswegen die
anderen und so weiter? Das können wir jetzt gleich einpreisen.
Das ist die dauerhafte, immer nicht nur implizit, sondern explizit hier auch vorangestellte Frage.
Egal worüber wir jetzt reden.
Und ich dachte mir aber heute wäre es doch mal sinnvoll über die AfD zu reden,
weil die AfD nach einigen Querelen innerhalb der Partei nun einen Spitzenkandidat
für die Europawahl hat, Maximilian Krah.
Ist bekannt dadurch auch, dass er mit dem Institut in Schnellroda von Götz Kubitschek zu tun hat.
Er dort auch im Verlag von Kubitschek ein Buch publiziert hat,
Politik von rechts, ein Manifest.
Ich habe das Buch jetzt bereits gelesen. Ich habe jetzt doch entschieden,
weil wir so viele Clips haben, nun nicht sehr viel aus diesem Buch vorzutragen,
sondern will das in den Salon verlagern.
Von wann ist das? Es ist aktuell erschienen.
Es ist aufschlussreich, aber ich will jetzt hier nochmal ausdrücklich sagen,
das ist jetzt nicht Werbung für ein rechtes Buch.
Und auch die, die gerne auch das Buch kaufen, über das wir im Salon reden,
über Longtermism oder so kann man das machen oder auch bei anderen Büchern.
Hier würde ich jetzt tatsächlich sagen wollen, ich lese es, damit ihr es nicht
lesen müsst und habe es auch gelesen und würde da vor allem diesen wirtschaftlichen
Aspekt mal rausstellen.
Was will die AfD eigentlich wirtschaftlich? Aber wir konzentrieren uns hier
mal auf etwas anderes. Und auf die Idee gekommen bin ich, über KRA zu reden
durch einen Beitrag von Sebastian Friedrich in Panorama.
Dort wurde nämlich KRA interviewt. Es ging eigentlich um die Zukunft des Konservatismus.
Und es gibt ja so ein leichtes Blinken hin zur AfD seitens der CDU.
Ja, wir müssen dann vielleicht ja doch so auch zusammenarbeiten können.
Man versucht es ja jetzt mal so in alle Richtungen und dann wird ein Friedrich
Merz wieder eingefangen.
Wie sieht das eigentlich jemand von der AfD, jemand wie Krah,
der, man merkt das schon, wenn er so im Kubitschek reist und so ist,
sich als Rechtsintellektueller versteht?
Und nun hat Sebastian Friedrich folgende Aussage aus Krah herausbekommen in
diesem Panorama-Beitrag, die wir uns jetzt mal kurz anhören.
Der europäische Vergleich zeigt, dass die politische Rechte nur dann zum Erfolg
kommt, wenn die Christdemokraten verschwinden.
Von daher setze ich nicht auf die CDU, ich setze auf die Inklusion der CDU.
Also die Zerstörung der CDU ist Ihr Ziel? Genau. Letztlich in zwei Teile.
Einen Teil, der rechts offen ist.
Und eben in einen Teil, der am Ende eine Art grüne 2.0 ist. Insofern bleibt
die CDU der strategische Hauptgegner.
Und es wird eine neue, nicht von den Grünen dominierte Politik in Deutschland
nur geben, wenn die CDU in ihrer heutigen Form verschwindet.
CDU muss in ihrer heutigen Form verschwinden, eine Aufspaltung.
Das hat mich hellhörig werden lassen. Was will dieser Krah?
Ist die CDU daran selber schuld? Dass sie so zum ...
Kann man jetzt sagen aus der AfD-Richtung, so zum Abschuss freigegeben aus, es scheint.
Nun, er bezieht sich ja darauf am Anfang und er macht das dann in anderen Interviews,
die ich mir angehört habe, auch immer wieder, dass eigentlich die rechten beziehungsweise
faschistischen, postfaschistischen Parteien, die in Europa erfolgreich geworden sind,
nur dadurch erfolgreich wurden, dass die Christdemokratie verdrängt wurde.
Das können wir in Italien sehen, das können wir in Frankreich sehen,
das können wir durchgängig eigentlich erleben.
Also dieses Kerkül, was er da drin hat, nämlich, dass es in der CDU Menschen
gibt, und er schätzt so die Hälfte, die sich dann der AfD anschließen.
Wir haben ja bisher schon erlebt, dass sehr viele Leute aus der CDU bis hin
zu irgendwelchen Staatsministern, Büroleitern und so weiter,
dann einfach in der AfD so Karriere machen.
Er war ja auch CDU Mitglied.
Zum Beispiel, ja. Also es gibt so, ja schon einige und man denkt,
man schaut sich das an und denkt, ja irgendwie scheint es da sowas zu geben.
Und die CDU hat ja nun deswegen sein zweiter Teil, da gibt es welche,
die so Richtung die neuen Grünen oder sowas werden.
Die CDU hat sich ja unter Merkel ganz lange diesen Vorwurf anhören müssen,
das ist die Sozialdemokratisierung, die Auflösung und so weiter.
Wir haben kein eigenes Fundament. Wer sind wir eigentlich?
Und dann gab es ja so eine Zeit, wo man das so bewundert hat.
Die CDU ist ein krasser Ausbildungsbetrieb.
Da kann man einfach Karriere machen und zwar inhaltlich offen.
Man sieht das ja bei den Leuten, die jetzt angekommen sind oben.
Hendrik Füßt. Daniel Günther vielleicht ein bisschen ausgeklammert, aber Söder.
Söder redet irgendwas von Asyltourismus, sie dann, oh hier gibt es irgendwie
so ein Bürgerbegehren hinsichtlich rettet die Bienen, na dann werde ich halt
grün. Und dann ist er plötzlich grün.
Und das passt ja eigentlich nicht zusammen und geht wirklich nur,
wenn man inhaltlich sich komplett befreit hat und die einzige Treue zum Politikbetrieb
wirklich nur die Karrierechance ist.
So und wenn jetzt aber die Karrierechance bei der AfD viel größer sind als bei
der CSU, Ich glaube, die haben absolut recht.
Die konservative Partei wird verschwinden, aber die in Anführungszeichen Konservativen,
die das nur als Ausbildungsbetrieb benutzt haben, die werden bleiben.
Und wenn die Losung nicht mehr ist, naja, der zweite Weltkrieg war noch ganz schön nah,
der Holocaust und so weiter, wir versuchen mal die sachte Schiene und jetzt
plötzlich, nee, die letzten Überlebenden sind eigentlich gestorben und die Feierstunden
sind auch nicht mehr die große Nummer und diese kleine Rede von dem Steinmeier,
die packen wir auch noch weg.
Wir können jetzt eigentlich wieder ein bisschen inhaltlich all in gehen,
das zieht beim Publikum viel mehr, dann gehen die wirklich alle rüber und machen
bei der AfD einfach Karriere, wenn es nur darum geht.
Das ist eine große Gefahr und ich habe aufgrund dieses Beitrags dann gedacht,
gut, ich muss mich mal mit diesem KRA genauer beschäftigen, habe nicht nur das
Buch gelesen, sondern habe mir zwei einstündige Interviews angesehen,
die auch in diesem Monat erschienen sind.
Also in diesem Monat ist viel passiert und zwar war Krah bei der Weltwoche zu Gast und war dort in,
es sollte ein Streitgespräch sein zwischen Werner Patzelt,
der am rechten Rand der CDU wissenschaftlich fischt und Krah,
wenngleich sie sich sehr einig waren, wir hören jetzt Patzelt so gut wie gar
nicht, wir hören vor allem Krah und er zeigt noch mal, was sein Problem mit der CDU ist.
Ich hatte als Student mal einen denkwürdigen Streit mit einem Assistenten,
der jetzt Staatsrechtsprofessor hier in Berlin ist.
Und das war eher ein Linker und ich muss zugeben, der zog mich zwei Stunden
lang am Nasenring durch die Arena. Und der sagte mir unter anderem,
Herr Krah, ich würde nie CDU wählen, aber wissen Sie, wofür ich die CDU liebe?
Dass sie Menschen wie Sie neutralisiert.
Die CDU ist eine Partei, die die Konservativen zwar einsammelt,
aber die gleichzeitig dafür gesorgt, dass sie in der Bundesrepublik nach 1945
nie wirklich etwas bewegen und konnten und sich durchsetzen konnten.
Sondern es ist ein endloses Abschleifen.
Das geht sehr in deine Richtung. Also jetzt nochmal all in gehen mit einer rechten Position.
Also das, um damit auch eine Profilschärfung vorzunehmen und nicht zu sagen,
naja, wie Strauß gesagt hat, rechts von der CDU darf es nicht geben.
Was man zum einen so auslegen kann, also die CDU ist also rechts oder CSU ist rechts.
Was aber auch bedeutet, wir fangen die mal alle ein und dann sind die Progressiveren
mit den Konservativeren und so weiter so alle unter einem Dach und niemand hat
mehr wirklich zum Beispiel staatsgefährdende Gedanken.
Denn das sieht man ja nicht nur an den Untersuchungen des Verfassungsschutzes,
sondern generell, was da so artikuliert wird im Umfeld von Schnellroda,
dass das nicht unbedingt auf eine liberale Demokratie hinausläuft,
um es mal vorsichtig zu sagen.
Gibt mir irgendwie so eine innere Ruhe. Die Gefahr ist dann doch nicht so groß,
denn dieses Argument, ja, die werden dann alle da geschliffen und so weiter.
Ja, es ist halt ein Ausbildungsbetrieb. Es wird nur einer dort Bundeskanzler.
Aber einer wird eben Bundeskanzler in der CDU. Das ist die Geschichtsschreibung
der letzten 60 Jahre. Also trittst du in der CDU ein, bist du im Topf.
Wirst du Linker, Grüner oder was weiß ich immer. Also wenn du vor 30 Jahren
in die Grünen eingestiegen bist, die Idee irgendwann mal Ministerposten zu,
war völlig jenseits von allem. Das war halt bei der CDU immer anders.
Deswegen hat man sich diesem Ausbildungsbetrieb und dann, das hat ja Precht
vor Jahren schon bei Thilo mal gesagt, ja, im Politikbetrieb wirst du halt abgeschliffen.
Die Frage ist nur, wer schleift hier wen ab? Also hat man eine CDU,
die die ganzen etwas zu rechts denkenden Typen einfach abschleiftet aussortiert?
Oder haben wir eine AfD, die seit zehn Jahren einfach die andere Seite,
Petri raus, Lücke raus, zuletzt Meuthen und so weiter und im Kern bleibt dann
eben doch das übrig als abgeschliffene.
Die schleifen sich dahin ab, dass sie immer rechter werden, wenn man das so formulieren kann.
Er war CDU-Mitglied und war dann auf so einer CDU-Veranstaltung.
Merkel trat dort auf. Das war jetzt gerade nach dieser Flüchtlingspolitik von,
2015. Das war für ihn so ein Umkehrerlebnis.
Und ich bin ab jetzt euer Feind, weil ich habe auch noch sechs Kinder.
Und ich möchte, dass die vielleicht die selben Chancen der Ausbildung und des
Aufstiegs haben, am selben Ort, wie ich sie selbst gemacht habe und ihr macht
es kaputt. Und deshalb sage ich ganz klar, die CDU muss weg,
sie hat sich aufgegeben und ist eine Bedrohung geworden.
Ja, das ist eine Schlussfolgerung dann daraus, dann tritt er in die AfD ein.
Diese Idee von, wenn wir es nur richtig machen im Sinne von ethno pluralistisch,
dass es unser Gebiet hier bleibt und so weiter. Wir haben jetzt diese Landratswahl.
Wir wissen, was das für die wirtschaftliche Standortbestimmung dort bedeutet.
Also solche Namen schon, Sömmerda und so weiter, das ist verbrannte Erde.
Niemand investiert da irgendwas.
Da haben jetzt 44 Prozent Mindestlohn bekommen und das ist halt der Zustand.
Wir hören dann zwar immer wieder, ja, es läuft aber doch ein bisschen besser
als sonst und die Arbeitslosigkeit ist geringer als sonst. Ja,
warum ist nochmal die Arbeitslosigkeit geringer als sonst? Achso,
ja genau, weil nämlich alle Jungen gehen.
Klar ist die Arbeitslosigkeit da geringer als sonst.
Also wenn man mit diesem Anspruch einen wirtschaftlichen Standortvorteil haben
möchte, kriegt man ihn genau nicht. Das ist genau dieses Paradox,
dass Zuwanderung dort als allergrößtes
Problem gesehen ist, wo Abwanderung faktisch das größte Problem ist.
Und in deren Sicht, ja, seine sechs Kinder werden sich wahrscheinlich eh ihre
Jobs aussuchen können, nur auf entsprechendem Niveau.
Es ist ganz erstaunlich, dass
er das von dieser wirtschaftlichen Seite überhaupt nicht betrachten kann.
Aber die ganze Zeit will. Er will es ja und sagt, da schwächte unser Wohlstand
und er bezeichnet ja dann die ganze Zeit Flüchtlinge als Sozialschmarotzer und Vergleichen.
Und er ist nicht in der Lage wirtschaftlich darüber nachzudenken,
weil die Ideologie ihm natürlich vollends den Blick verstellt darauf.
Krah ist jemand, der durchaus ein Rechtsintellektueller ist,
insofern, als er ein Taktiker ist, der versucht zu schauen, wie funktioniert
eigentlich so eine Öffentlichkeit, wie kann man an Hegemonie gewinnen.
Da hat auch jemand mal Gramsci zumindest aufgeschlagen, das kann man schon merken.
Und er sagt dann auch zu den Grünen, denn eigentlich sagt Patzelt,
sie müssen so werden wie die Grünen.
Die Grünen sind eine erfolgreiche Partei geworden. Sie waren irgendwann nicht
mehr Anti-Establishment, sie waren nicht mehr Radikal-Gegner gegen irgendetwas,
sondern haben sich angepasst. Und Krah stimmt dem dann auf verquere Weise zu.
Ich bin sogar der Meinung, wir müssen von den Grünen lernen.
Schauen Sie, keine Partei hat in den letzten 30 Jahren, das in 40 Jahren Deutschland
mehr verändert. Ich finde natürlich zum schlechten als die Grünen. Das kann man ja sagen.
Sie haben aber in der ganzen Zeit gerade mal sieben Jahre regiert.
Das heißt also das erste, wo ich widerspreche ist, wenn man das Land verändern
will, muss man regieren.
Man muss die Journalisten auf seiner Seite haben, das war bei den Grünen so.
Man muss letztlich konsequent eine Vision positiv formulieren und an ihr festhalten
und das Land dadurch auch in Diskussion zwingen. Wir müssen in Deutschland das
Meinungsspektrum erweitern.
Wir haben zurzeit ein Meinungsspektrum, das bewegt sich von linksradikal bis linke Mitte.
Was will ich denn in die Regierung, solange das so ist? Erst muss das Meinungsspektrum
bereit sein, konservative, auch demokratisch rechte Positionen als zulässige
Meinungen zu akzeptieren.
Wenn wir ein Land haben, das überhaupt bereit ist zu akzeptieren,
dass man die Welt auch von rechts betrachten kann, ohne dass man deshalb ein
menschenfressender Kindermörder ist, dann können wir in die Regierung gehen.
Und ich finde, da hatte er absolut recht, wenn er sich ansieht,
wie man egomonial vorgehen muss. Und ich finde, dass die AfD genau das ja auch
tut. Wir haben jetzt den Asylkompromiss, der wirklich schändlich ist.
Und man denkt, wie kann sich sowas durchsetzen, bekommt dann als Antwort geliefert,
das machen wir auch, weil es Sorgen und Ängste der Bürger gibt etc.
Und dann vergeht nicht ein oder zwei Tage und Jens Spahn gibt der Bild-Zeitung ein Interview,
wo er sagt, ja, also alles ist außer Rand und Band, also das kann mit dem Asylkompromiss,
das reicht alles noch nicht. Wir müssen dann noch viel weitergehen.
Wir haben nur solche Äußerungen erlebt. Und was ist das Resultat?
Man macht doch eigentlich mit all dem, was man da tut, mit dem Asylkompromiss,
mit den Äußerungen dann aus der CDU.
Werbung für die AfD, so damit das AfD-Wählerpublikum darauf wie folgt reagiert.
Ah ja, die sagen ja sogar selbst, dass alles chaotisch ist. Dass die das mit
dem Asylrecht nicht kontrolliert bekommen. Also wählen wir doch die AfD.
Denn die sagen das am allerlängsten und sind am konsequentesten bei der ganzen Angelegenheit.
Eine gute mediale Tradition, Fokusgruppengespräche zu führen.
Wir kriegen allenfalls mal einen Presseklub, wo wir am Ende noch ein paar Hörer hören.
Und dann sind wir überrascht, wie dm.
Dann gibt's so Umfragen, in denen plötzlich rauskommt, ach so,
wir dachten, ein Drittel der Deutschen traut irgendwie den Nachbarn nicht zu,
doch für den Klimawandel und so entsprechende politische Einschnitte dann auch
zu nehmen und dann stellt sich raus.
Ne, man muss nur die Frage mal richtig stellen und kann dann immer noch im quantitativen
Abfragen bleiben, also von qualitativen Fokusgruppengesprächen noch weit entfernt
und stellen fest, ah ne, es sind doch zwei Drittel, die es eigentlich befürworten.
Genau wie bei den ganzen Zuwanderungsfragen. Die Ossis, das sind einfach so
ängstliche Menschen. Dann fragt man mal nach, wovor habt ihr Angst?
Dann sagen die, vor dem Neuerstarken des Rechtsradikalismus.
Man wird ja immer wieder überrascht. Und ich glaube, wenn der Krah hier so redet,
die Grünen waren eine sehr erfolgreiche Partei, die haben das ganze Land in ihre Richtung gedreht.
Die Grünen stellen gerade fest, dass die Menschen noch viel mehr Angst vor den
Klimawandelfolgen haben, als sie selbst bereit sind, dafür politische Entscheidungen
zu treffen, gerade in der Machtposition sind.
Die Grünen verbrennen nach gerade ihr eigenes Klientel, weil man irgendwie feststellt,
hier in Frankfurt gab es vor zwei Wochen einen Regenfall.
Wir saßen im Schwarzwald, haben diese TikTok-Videos gesehen,
wie der Südbahnhof zwei Meter unter Wasser steht, das Wasser durch diese Glasdinger
da strömt. Absolute Katastrophe. Und wir haben es nicht verstanden,
weil diese TikTok-Videos zeigen ja kein Datum mehr, dass das alles gestern war.
So und dann sickert so langsam dieses, naja, gestern war eine Flut.
Heute kommt eine mediale Flut mit diesen Videos.
Die Flut ist medial, weil das sind alles Videos von gestern.
Und du sitzt im Schwarzwald und denkst, habe ich mein Dachfenster zu?
Habe ich meine Kellerfenster zu? Habe ich es eigentlich geregelt?
Wie geht es meinen Nachbarn, was ist denn hier eigentlich los und so weiter, ja? Und diesem...
Gefühl, was man dann plötzlich hat, entsprechen die Grünen so gar nicht.
Hier hat keiner das Gefühl von, oh ja, zum Glück haben wir die Grünen in der
Regierung und zum Glück drehen die alles in diesen Klimaschutz und so weiter.
Nee, das ist auch nicht krasse Argumentation, aber krasse Argumentation ist,
dass gerade auch da, wo die Grünen, wenn die Grünen nicht regiert haben,
trotzdem eine gewisse grüne Politik damals, dass die Grünen die Gesellschaft
verändert haben, dass jetzt also niemand, der noch halbwegs bei Trost ist,
sagen würde, Klimawandel ist kein Problem oder Recycling brauchen wir nicht.
Oder denken wir an so was wie Einführung des Dosenpfands, was das für ein Kulturkampf war.
Heute völlig selbstverständlich auch gewisse Lebensformen, die heute verrechtlicht
sind und damit akzeptiert sind.
Und das zeichnet er jetzt als Siegeszug der Grünen nach.
Ich würde das, aber das ist noch eine größere Debatte, mal in Frage stellen
wollen, inwieweit man das so einer Partei zuschreiben kann.
Oder ob die Partei gerade auch dann zeitgleich da war mit dem,
was ohnehin gesellschaftlich da war.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass das Thema Klima oder das Thema Ehe für alle ein
genuin grünes Phänomen ist,
sondern in gewisser Weise erleben wir ja auch zivilisatorische Fortschritte,
sodass wir anerkennen, das ist nicht mehr so richtig, dass wir Leute,
die andere Lebensformen leben, auf diese Weise diskriminieren.
Also sollen ja auch heiraten können. Wie auch gut möglich ist,
dass in zehn Jahren man eher verdutzt auf die heutige Zeitblick,
was den Fleischkonsum anbelangt. Dass man sagt, ja, das war wirklich verrückt,
da hat man sieben Tage die Woche Fleisch gegessen? Wer hat denn so was gemacht?
Und da war es aber dann nicht die grüne Partei, die das dahin gebracht hat,
sondern die grüne Partei hat dem vielleicht hin und wieder Ausdruck verliehen
oder war mal Sprachrohr des einen oder anderen. Aber ist es nicht so da.
Also man könnte davon einer allgemeinen Entwicklung ausgehen.
Nur was man glaube ich festhalten muss ist, dass man schon so etwas erleben kann bei der AfD gerade.
Oder seitdem sie da ist, dass die Politik sich gerade mit Blick auf die Migration
nach rechts entwickelt hat, und zwar immer weiter.
Und dass ein irrsinniger Glaube vorherrscht, dass, wenn wir jetzt noch so ein,
zwei, drei Verschärfungen machen, die Leute dann zufrieden sind.
Aber da man hier eh nur mit Emotionen regiert, es ist ja überhaupt dieser Asylkompromiss
für den Normalbürger undurchsichtig, was da jetzt eigentlich gemacht wird.
Der kann gar nicht beurteilen, würde das Migration stoppen oder nicht?
Mal davon abgesehen, dass ich nicht dafür bin, Migration zu stoppen.
Aber man wäre in dieser Denkweise gefangen.
Kann überhaupt keiner absehen. Dann wird aber, wenn man von diesem Gefühl,
hier stimmt was nicht, hier muss wieder Ordnung gestiftet werden.
Weil die zum einen das Original sind und zum anderen alle anderen Parteien nur
bestätigen, was die AfD immer gesagt hat.
Hier stimmt was nicht, hier muss man durchgegriffen werden. Und dass selbst
bei so einem harten Einschnitt wie dem Asylkompromiss schon ein,
zwei Tage später ein Jens Spahn auftritt und sagt, hier stimmt ja alles gar
nicht mehr, wir müssen jetzt mal durchgreifen.
Man kann in dieser Hinsicht nie genug machen.
Für eine weitere Verschärfung, weil die davor hat ja noch gar nicht gereicht oder war ineffektiv.
Und deswegen sehen wir schon, dass eigentlich hier von Mittel-Links-Parteien
wie auch konservativen Parteien AfD-Politik gemacht wird.
Ja, also ich meine, wenn man jetzt umfragt und die Umfragen gibt es auch aktuell,
Deutschland trennt und so.
Die Deutschen vertrauen nicht mehr, dass die Regierung die Sache im Griff hat,
allen voran bei der Flüchtlingspolitik.
Dafür, dass 2022 ein absolutes Ausnahme- und Rekordjahr war,
das auch 2015 weit in den Schatten stellt, was Zuwanderung usw.
Angeht, finde ich, ist das jetzt nicht unbedingt prägendes Thema irgendwo.
Also ich habe jetzt niemanden gehört, der beklagt, dass seine Turnhalle mal
wieder blockiert ist oder was auch immer.
Sondern das, was Graal hier unterstellt, also diesen hegemonialen Gestaltungsgedanken,
den Grünen in die Schuhe schiebend, die das gerade gar nicht fühlen,
wenn sie über ihr eigenes Regierungshandel so nachdenken.
Also da ist einfach so eine Verdrehung, die mir einfach nur zeigt,
ja, das ist das Wunschdenken.
Er unterstellt das den Grünen, um sich das auch andichten zu können.
Aber für die AfD wird diese ganze Flüchtlingsangelegenheit...
Genauso wenig produktiv umsetzbar sein in dem Maße, wie sie glauben,
dass die Grünen, das ist, ich hatte das.
Nee, aber es war ein Erfolg für sie. Also ich meine, sie sind bei über 20 Prozent.
Aber nicht wegen Vergangensthemen. Das ist diese Unsicherheit,
Heizung, die Regierung funktioniert nicht mehr, ich vertraue dem nicht mehr.
Meine Nachbarn sind auch alle durch den Wind und so weiter. Ich bin verwirrt.
Naja, aber das ist ja schon interessant, dass die Leute dann die AfD wählen,
deren Unix-Highpoint ist ja schon die Flüchtlingspolitik.
Ich sage, dass sie, wenn sie gefragt werden, wen würden sie denn wählen?
Sie können jetzt auch mal eine provokative Note setzen. Sie wissen ja genau,
es ist gerade keine Wahl, dass sie dann sagen AfD.
Das ist nochmal ein Unterschied. Und muss man auch. Ich weiß,
ich kämpfe da auch immer ein bisschen gegen Windmühlen, weil ich immer wieder
sage, Trump wird nicht wiedergewählt. Und dann kommen aber alle mit.
Aber die Umfragewerte. Und ich sage ja, die Umfragewerte. Aber die Wahl ist 2024.
Ja gut, ich kann natürlich jetzt auch nicht sagen, ich wünsche mir auch nicht,
dass sie wieder, dass sie, dass sie 20 Prozent erreicht.
Aber zumindest mal ist ja diese Stimmung eindeutig und die hängt schon damit zusammen.
Und ich glaube, das hört man schon bei den Bürgern, dass sie glauben,
dass Migration ein Problem ist. Und das sieht man auch schon in Umfragen,
dass das als Problem markiert wird.
Jetzt wirst du sagen, aber die Mehrheit ist immer noch für Einwanderung von
Fachkräften oder so. Aber tatsächlich sieht man gerade, wie die Stimmung kippt.
Und man sieht es ja daran, dass es keine Proteste gegen den Asylkompromiss gegeben hat.
Überhaupt nichts. Man sieht es ja auch daran, dass es heute undenkbar wäre,
so einen Merkel-Schritt zu machen.
Das wäre das totale Fiasko.
Und deshalb, glaube ich, sollte man da nicht, also ich glaube,
dass in Deutschland schon sehr viel rechts gedacht wird. Und nicht nur im Sinne
von, ich bin verwirrt, sondern auch in dem Sinne, ich will keine Migration haben.
Also ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass die AfD das nicht aktualisiert, was sie an Umfragen hat.
Aber wir kriegen nächstes Jahr eine sehr gute Ostdeutsch-Show geliefert,
die es in sich haben wird. Ja.
Was ist denn das Wahlversprechen von Krah an die Deutschen?
Was ist heute die wichtigste Botschaft, die Sie,
sich als AfD-Exponenten zu eigen machen, das ist unsere Message im Wahlkampf.
Die Message ist, dass ein Deutschland möglich ist, wo man das,
was man selber ist, sein kann, ohne sich angegriffen fühlen zu müssen.
Wer eine Familie haben möchte, wer Kinder haben möchte, wer ein glückliches
Leben haben möchte, in Frieden, in Wohlstand, in Rechtssicherheit und ohne Angst,
das ermöglichen wir euch
Und wir garantieren dafür, dass euer Frieden und euer selbstbestimmtes Leben
nicht von linken Ideologen oder irgendwelchen globalen Konzernen in ihrem Gewinnstreben
beeinträchtigt und kaputt gemacht wird.
Deutschland aber normal. Ist der beste Wahlspruch ever auf Deutsch, den ich je gehört habe.
Also trifft es irgendwie so auf den Punkt, man weiß genau, was sie wollen,
und das funktioniert gut. Aber ich will trotzdem...
Ja, das stellt man so politisch in den Raum, und man weiß, das greift einige
Klientel gerne auf und wir sehen das ja auch bei Twitter und so weiter.
Nur das, gegen was er sich stellt, also dieses Vogue und so weiter und so fort,
die Unternehmen, die er hier auch immer meint, die so diese extrem Vogue-Schiene
fahren, also Disney, klar, die ist dann nochmal so rein importiert nach Deutschland,
aber auch schon allein mal eine Speisekarte zu schreiben.
Man macht eine Marktforschung und schreibt eine Speisekarte und dann steht da
irgendwie wie draußen Sternchen und hier alles safe und Trüffel und Trüffel
statt Fleisch sozusagen irgendwie so, dass man so diesen Shift macht,
die Haferkörner da in Wasser auflöst.
Das ist Marktforschung und diese Marktforschung ist nicht im Blindflug,
sondern die trifft wirklich auf den Zeitgeist.
Die Leute, wenn man denen jetzt kommt und das ist ja auf die Spitze getrieben,
nein, du wirst mit 300 kmh auf der linken Spur der Autobahn mit deinem 5er BMW,
der 20 Liter verbraucht fahren dürfen.
Mache mal eine Marktforschung, ob das wirklich die Leute wollen.
Ob das überhaupt im Handlungsbereich möglich ist und so weiter.
Du sagst jetzt die Leute, also wir sprechen vielleicht von einer dünnen Mehrheit,
die das nicht will. Aber ich würde auch hier nochmal deutlich machen,
es gibt ganz viele, die das ärgert.
Also sonst würden ja diese Diskurse über solche Kinkalizien da,
da gibt es ja die Bild-Zeitung greift ja jeden Tag irgendwie sowas auf,
würden ja nicht in dieser Weise ventilieren, wenn es nicht ein Publikum dafür gibt.
Und ich glaube, das ist größer als fünf Prozent und noch größer als zehn Prozent.
Das will ich auch sagen. Nur der Punkt ist, den ich machen möchte,
wenn die sich so gegen die Mehrheitsgesellschaft stellen,
wissen Sie, Sie können sich jetzt selber sagen, wir wollen, dass alle Deutschen,
die das wollen und so weiter, also dieses inklusive Argument machen,
dass Sie eigentlich die wahre deutsche Alternative zu dem ganzen Mainstream
und da zählen alle Parteien dazu und so.
Nur Sie kommen erkennbar für alle und das wird ja auch immer wieder thematisiert
und daran würden sie auch noch dann irgendwann richtig leiden,
es ist dieses Höcke-Ding. Ja, jetzt sind es die ostdeutschen Landesverbände,
die gerade für ein Jahr nochmal das bestimmen, wegen den Wahlen und so weiter,
das ist alles eingepreist.
Aber dieser kleine, ich fühle mich von der AfD besser verstanden als von der
Mainstream-Gesellschaft, die mir ja auch mehrere politische Angebote hat und
ich kann mich gar nicht entscheiden.
Hat jetzt der der habe kräftig mir es
ist eigentlich in so eine und dann so abwehrbewegung es
sind es ist trotzdem auch wenn das anders betont
es ist die minderheit gegen die
große diffuse durcheinandergewirbelte mehrheit und dieser impetus der da drin
steckt für alle deutschen zu sprechen und so weiter das ist einfach nicht gedeckt
zum einen natürlich und zum anderen er kriegt das auch nicht argumentiert gegen
die die er eingefangen hat weil die irgendwann ein politisches Gespräch mit Freunden,
Nachbarn und so weiter und dann kriegen sie irgendwann schnell mit,
sie können es nicht auf die AfD-Themen lenken.
Also der Widerstand da ist nachbarschaftlich zu groß.
Ja und da bin ich mir nicht sicher, inwieweit man tatsächlich auch da tatsächlich
eine Spaltung erleben kann.
Also es ist ja jetzt so, wenn man eine der anderen Parteien wählt oder darin
Mitglied ist, gibt es ja keine großen Friktionen.
Da wird man sich vielleicht mal irgendwie austauschen mit und auch mal über
den oder jenen schimpfen.
Aber es gibt nicht diesen Bruch. Aber offenbar gibt es ja sehr viele,
die bereit sind, diesen Bruch herzustellen.
Und sagen, so mache ich nicht mehr. Wir haben das ja bei den Corona-Leugnern
schon gesehen, dass man da zu sehr vielem bereit ist, um wirklich den Bruch herzustellen.
Und sagen, nee, dann werde ich nie mehr in diesen Gesangsverein gehen.
Aber die haben das über Community-Building gemacht, nicht so sehr im Einzelkämpfen.
Und dann ist ja auch noch mal, was man wählt, ist ja geheim.
Das heißt, wer also dann geheim seine Stimme da lässt und sagt,
ich fühle mich aber auch nicht mehr als Teil der Gesellschaft und wir erleben
doch überall eine ganz große Ausdifferenzierung, eine Nischenbildung und ständig
entstehen neue rechte Sender, die extreme Reichweiten dann noch erzielen bei YouTube zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber Reichelt hat 100.000 Views und nicht 10 Millionen, weißt du?
Und auch wenn der Taka Karls in Amerika, der lädt die Dinger aufs Bitterhoch.
Aber Amerika ist doch ein gutes Beispiel, dass da das Verhältnis zwischen Republikanern
und Demokraten ja nicht mehr vergleichbar ist mit dem Verhältnis,
wie sie es in den 80er Jahren hatten, sondern inzwischen sind da ja auch chinesische Mauern dazwischen.
Trump ist aber eben kein Ultranationalist, anders als die AfD Leute.
Ja, aber die werden ja, also hier schreibt es in seinem Buch ziemlich ausdrücklich,
deswegen will ich das auch mal in den Kontext setzen, in dem man es betrachten
muss. Aber so wird er ja nicht wahrgenommen.
Also bei Höcke, da sind die Leute so ein bisschen komisch. Aber Aber sonst,
finde ich, spielt die AfD dieses, wir sind die wahre CDU, wir sind wirklich
bürgerlich, noch für viel.
Naja, also sonst würde nicht 20 Prozent sagen, also auch wenn sie es nur sagen,
aber sie könnten sich ja auch irgendeine andere Partei auswählen, um zu provozieren.
Aber dass sie das sagen, ist glaube ich schon bei den meisten Ausdruck dessen,
dass sie das nicht als so schlimmer finden.
Wir sehen das doch selbst jetzt auch bei den Freien Wählern.
Also eigentlich dachte ich, muss dann gar nicht mehr bei Aiwanger noch irgendwo
diskutiert werden oder so. Und trotzdem gibt es dann da bei den bayerischen
Freien Wählern, wenn sie sagen, ja, das ist eine Schmutzkampagne und so weiter. A.
Weil die auch keine Alternative haben.
B. Ja, aber dass man da noch, also ja, auch wenn es keine Alternative gibt,
gibt es ja so rote Linien, wo man sagt, gut, dann ist das jetzt,
dann muss die Alternative jetzt entstehen. A.
Ich will noch mal dran erinnern.
Die letzte Landtagswahl in Sachsen-Anhalt. B. Ich finde, das ist schon eine
ganz starke. Das sehen wir doch auch an Ballergebnissen.
Es gibt auch eine ganz starke Enthemmung in diese Richtung, dass man sagt,
naja gut, Gauland hat das halt mit diesem Vogelschiss und so,
aber trotzdem, also das ist nicht, da wird nicht eine rote Linie gemacht.
Wir kennen andere Debatten von roten Linien. Ich erinnere beispielsweise an
die Ausführungen damals von Möllemann, wo er so eine Kampagne gegen Michel Friedmann
gemacht hat. Und, und, und.
Wo sehr schnell so eine rote Linie klar war, wo man sagte, nee, geht nicht.
Und das ist heute in dieser Weise nicht mehr zu finden.
Also, ich will noch mal dran erinnern, Im Juni 2021 waren in Sachsen-Anhalt
Landtagswahlen und noch in der Woche vorher.
Wurde der AfD eine Prognose untergeschoben, die über zehn Prozent Abwich vom
echten Ergebnis. Und das ist einfach grotesk.
CDU und AfD sahen fast gleich aus auf Augenhöhe aus. Und dann waren mehr als
zehn Prozent Unterschied.
Oder, ich weiß nicht genau, ob es mehr als, aber es waren so,
ich lese hier die Überschriften, die Wahlforschung hat in Sachsen-Anhalt verloren,
Landtagswahl in Sachsen-Anhalt, die Niederlage der Demoskopie und so weiter und so fort.
Wir haben all die Phänomene, die du beschrieben hast, ich will sie auch nicht
runterspielen in ihre Gefährlichkeit und so weiter.
Aber die AfD hat sich anders als die republikanische Partei,
also die amerikanischen Demokraten haben sich halt verwandelt in so ein,
wir sind einfach nur die Demokraten. Die SPD hat es dann auch versucht,
wir sind nicht mehr die Sozialdemokraten, sondern wir sind die Demokraten,
wir sind offen für alles und so.
Und die Republikaner haben zwar einen grandiosen Schock innerlich durch diese
neue Herangehensweise Donald Trumps erfahren.
Aber es ist nicht diese krasse Hinwendung zu so einem ultranationalistischen,
ethno-pluralistischen, wir machen es jetzt mal richtig, All-in.
Die AfD hat sich tatsächlich von dieser, wir sind euroskeptisch,
dann haben wir so einen Flügel und dann sind wir nur noch dieser Flügel.
Und der Höcke ist immer noch nicht auf dem Parteitag aufgetreten nur in den Startlöchern,
um dann nach Erfurt, wenn er nämlich in Thüringen seine 33-prozentige,
ohne mich keine Verfassungsänderung-Mehrheit mehr und so, und ich zwinge CDU
und Die Linke zusammen in einem, wird es seiner Vermutung nach so viel Durcheinander
in Deutschland geben, dass er dann endlich Cash-in auf einem Parteitags erste
Mal eine eigene Rede halten kann.
Und dann gleich eine Bewerbungsrede für, und das machen wir jetzt in ganz Deutschland.
Und so sehr ich das nachvollziehen kann, dass man das aus diesem Inneren,
aber ich höre wie die über die Grünen reden und denen unterstellen,
dass denen das ja alles gelingt und sie das ganze Land verändert haben,
obwohl der Druck von woanders herkommt und sie auch nur darauf reagieren.
Ich halte das alles trotzdem, also trotz der Gefährlichkeit und der Dringlichkeit,
dass man darüber spricht und so für eine,
Auch super interessante Fan-Fiction, über die man auch mal reden kann,
mal diese Gefahr so ein bisschen ausgeklammert, das Phänomen mal an sich.
Ja, ich will jetzt auch hier nicht so einen Podcast machen, wo ich sage,
ist es fünf vor zwölf oder so etwas,
das halte ich auch für völlig übertrieben und das hat man jetzt auch jahrelang
mit der AfD so gemacht und hat sie zum Teil auch damit großgeschrieben als permanente
Gefahr und hat sich zumindest damit einen schlanken Fuß gemacht und hat sich
um viele politische Fragen dann nicht gekümmert,
weil wir haben ja noch die AfD jetzt als größtes Problem vor der Haustür stehen.
Das sollte man auf keinen Fall tun.
Ich habe jetzt gerade noch mal den Tweet.
Mit der Demoskopie hast du völlig recht.
6. Juni 2021 siegt der CDU Niederlage der Demoskopen in Sachsen-Anhalt.
14 Prozent Unterschied zwischen CDU und AfD statt Kopf-in-Kopf-Rennen,
wie es bis zum Wahltag hieß. Ja. Und das ist einfach, also man kann die AfD
sehr leicht hochschreiben.
Ja, ja.
Wir werden in Ostdeutschland Wahlergebnisse bekommen, die werden uns schockieren.
Die werden März den Kopf kosten und Lindner auch. Die CDU wird sich schnell
aufstellen müssen und so weiter.
Möge es so sein, dass das dann viel weniger für die AfD wird als in den Osten,
aber gut, ich würde nur noch einhacken, im Unterschied zu den Republikanern
kann man natürlich hier viel mehr mit der Deutschen, mit der einen Identität arbeiten.
Die Republikaner müssen natürlich ein Diversity-Publikum abdecken und das hat
ja Trump auch getan. Wir wissen viele mit latalen amerikanischen Wurzeln,
die Trump beispielsweise gewählt haben und wieder gewählt haben,
mehr sogar gewählt haben.
Und weißt du noch welche Sprüche sie angefangen hat? Was habt ihr zu verlieren?
Und das ist natürlich der Spruch gegen die Demokraten gewesen.
Während es in europäischen Ländern, wo das sehr viel homogener noch ist,
eher funktionieren kann. Also siehe Frankreich, wo man sehr große Fortschritte
von rechts gemacht hat. Oder dann in Italien, wo es sogar gelungen ist.
Aber es ist schon eine sehr ferne Welt und wenn du von Fanfaction sprichst,
dann fällt einem das natürlich ein.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal die Frage dieses Weltwoche-Moderators an.
Was ist heute das grösste Problem in Deutschland?
Und wo sehen Sie den Weg, wie man dieses Problem lösen könnte?
Was ist die wichtigste Priorität? Was müsste ins Zentrum dieses Wahlkampfs gestellt werden?
Kann ja jeder mal überlegen, wir haben ja heute schon ein paar Angebote gemacht,
Demografie, Kinder, Ungleichheit, Armut, das würde uns so alles einfallen.
Jetzt Antwort, Werner Patzelt, CDU-Professor. Prof.
Borz. Das größte Problem Deutschlands lässt sich nicht ins Zentrum dieses Wahlkampf
stellen. Es ist eine Daueraufgabe. das größte Problem dieses Landes ist.
Dass dieses Land und ein Großteil seiner Bewohner sich nicht mag.
Ja, wer wäre darauf gekommen? Wir lieben uns nicht als Deutsche.
Und das ist das allergrößte Problem. Sich nicht mag.
Okay, gut. Diese Weltwoche scheint wirklich ein radioser Krell.
Das ist doch der Wahnsinn. Ja, aber die Argumentation ist gut.
Wir haben euch nicht zu bieten. Also mit uns gibt es nicht mehr Kindergrundsicherung.
Wir kümmern uns auch nicht um den Klimawandel. Und ihr bleibt bei euren zwölf Euro Mindestlohn.
Aber was ihr jetzt stattdessen bekommt, ist die Freiheit, das Land,
das euch nichts gibt, trotzdem von Herzen lieben zu können.
Also der Patzelt, ich hab ihn ja ein bisschen vor Augen mit seinem Lockenkopf
und so weiter, der da mit seinen grauen Anzügen immer sitzt.
Und er ist ja auch immer da irgendwo in Sachsen unterwegs und so.
Oder der AfD erkläre, wir da so sitzen, dass wir uns nicht mögen.
Das kann ich wirklich gut glauben, wenn man durch Sachsen rennt,
dort wohnt und weiß, die halbe Stadt ist Tourismus-Schmiede.
Und wenn ich an der Frauenkirche stehe und mich umschaue, die haben einfach
drei Investoren aus Westdeutschland mir irgendwas hingesetzt und die Cola kostet
5,80 Euro und hier gehe ich eh nie hin.
Und da oben sitzt König Kurt.
Reins wurde immer wieder herausgearbeitet in diesen Gesprächen,
die Sachsen sind noch patriotisch und KRA pflichtet dem bei.
Atomausstieg und solche Dinge, sondern ihnen geht es ja eigentlich um das patriotische
Selbstverständnis dieses Landes.
Das müssen wir herstellen und das herzustellen ist im Osten einfach.
Da muss ich den Leuten nur sagen, verstellt euch nicht, lasst es raus, hört auf euer Herz.
Lass das raus, das ist das Angebot der AfD.
Die kommunikative Aufgabe im Westen ist deutlich schwieriger.
Das Wort Deutschland, Nation und Nationalstaat wurde im Giftschrank gelagert.
Auch historisch. Da ist der Rheinbund in der Geschichte.
Der Rheinbund. Deswegen Fanfiction. Wir alle denken mit Schrecken an das Jahr 1806 zurück.
Mit dem Rheinbund, in dem sich dann ja 1813 schon so ziemlich auflöst wieder.
Das war unser Schreckensjahr und deshalb lieben wir uns nicht.
Gerade hier, wir, die am Rhein und am Main leben, Wissen ist nur zu Genüge.
Wenn wir doch nur mit voller Inbrunst mal wieder Volk sagen dürfen,
ohne die Volksaktie oder den Volkswagen nur zu meinen, werden wir alle viel
glücklicher mit uns selbst.
Ja, das ist das Angebot, das gemacht wird und die Sachsen sind da ganz weit voraus.
Dresden ist das Pflaster, wo Meinungsfreiheit herrscht?
Und wo man auch Meinungen vertreten kann, die in diesem links-grünen gutmenschlichen
westdeutschen Mainstream undenkbar werden. Wo man also ein Bürgertum erhalten
hat, das eher in der Tradition der Weimarer Republik steht.
Und wir haben ja auch den Roman Der Turm, der das wunderbar beschreibt.
Das heißt, Sachsen ist zurzeit ein Biotop der Freiheit.
Ja, dann gehe ich mal in die Dresdner Neustadt, stelle mich auf die Straße und rufe Ausländer raus.
Wir sind das volk mal gucken was passiert dann könnte doch ein schlägerei von
links kommen ja also das ist ja wirklich grotesk ja es ist absurd er versucht
jetzt mal konservatismus zu definieren.
Und der unterschied zu allen ismen ob es ein liberalismus oder ein kommunismus
ist die glauben sie können jedes mal aufs neue und völlig losgelöst von raum
biologie und zeit die welt neu geschaffen.
Sie fühlen sich heute nicht als Mann, dann sind sie halt eins von den 42 anderen Geschlechtern.
Sie meinen, dass sie alle Traditionen abreißen müssen und dafür irgendetwas
Neues hinstellen. Tun Sie es einfach. Sie brauchen keine Ehrfurcht haben.
Sie sind an nichts gebunden.
Der Konservative weiß um seine Bindung und aus dieser Bindung an das,
was da ist, schöpft er Kraft und schöpft er vor allen Dingen eine unglaubliche
Freiheit, die Freiheit, diesen ganzen Moden zu widerstehen.
Weil er sagt, die Moden kommen und gehen.
Aber Kultur, Geschichte, Biologie, Natur, das bleibt. Ich muss nur lang genug
warten, dann behalte ich schon Recht.
Das ist die Absage an den liberalen Lebensentwurf.
Ja, das ist der TNT-Niveau. Den modernen Lebensentwurf. Und was er hier möchte,
ist, diese Rückbindung herzustellen.
Auch an die Natur, an die Biologie, sagt er dann sogar.
Also da schwingt auch noch so was anderes mit, das ist mir auch beim Lesen des Buches aufgefallen,
dass es immer wieder so Passagen gibt, bei denen er sich nicht so ganz traut,
aber es ist schon als Doc Whistle Verfahren zu lesen, okay, wir könnten auch
noch mal vielleicht über Gene und so etwas sprechen.
Also das geht noch mal in diese Richtung. Es bleibt nicht nur bei diesen Ideen,
ja, 52 Geschlechter oder so, sondern es gibt auch noch mal so was anderes,
gegen das man sich stellen muss oder beziehungsweise mit dem man noch mal den
eigenen Konservatismus begründen kann.
Und er hat auch hier noch mal als Politiker so eine philosophische Komponente
reingebracht, dass er eigentlich den Konservativen als Wahrheitsträger ansieht.
Sie nehmen eben eine große Kraft daraus, wenn Sie sagen…,
Meine Überzeugungen basieren auf Dingen, die immer gelten und immer richtig
sind. Ich muss nur lang genug warten.
Ich setze mich für das Richtige ein und ziehe daraus die Kraft.
Meine innere Freiheit kommt nicht aus dem Gesetz oder aus einem Gehaltscheck.
Sie kommt aus der Wahrheit, wenn wir das mal ganz hoch tragen müssen.
Wir haben da eine Rückbindung an etwas Transzendentes. Dazu kommen wir gleich noch.
Ja, weil jetzt mal, wenn man so was, man sitzt irgendwo abends gemütlich zusammen,
jemand fängt an so zu reden.
Er redet ja hier für ein rechtsintellektuelles Milieu.
Also das ist ja nicht das Milieu, das er jetzt auf der Straße sagt.
Also wir hören das uns jetzt gleich an, denn er war auch in Schneiderode bei
den Kubitscheks zu Gast und das habe ich mir dann auch noch reingezogen.
Er schreibt es auch in seinem Buch, da heißt es ziemlich am Anfang,
dass rechte Politik auch ohne Intellektuelle geht, bedeutet nicht,
dass sie nur ohne Intellektuelle geht.
Auch die Rechte braucht ihre geistigen Vordenker und sei es nur,
weil sie erklären können, was Linke und Liberale ausgeheckt haben,
um die natürliche Ordnung einzureißen.
Und hier beginnt das Problem, weil rechte Politik nicht auf eine intellektuelle
Begründung angewiesen ist, bleibt politisch rechte Intellektualität oft Stückwerk
und gibt sich wenig Mühe.
Was hier vorausgesetzt wird ist, ist, dass der Konservatismus oder der Rechte.
Grundsätzlich der Wahrheitsträger ist. Und diese Wahrheit muss nicht mehr theoretisiert werden,
muss nicht mehr mit irgendetwas groß begründet werden, sondern es handelt sich
eigentlich um Setzungen, die vorgenommen werden, Prämissen, die da sind und
die unhintergebar sind.
Eigentlich Dogmen. Und deswegen braucht man nicht zu intellektualisieren.
Und darunter leidet aber dann, gebt er zu, auch der intellektuelle Diskurs unter
Rechten, weil man sich immer schon so sicher sein kann, dass die Familie das
einzige Erstrebenswerte ist, dass die Identität das wichtigste von aller Welt ist.
Deshalb gibt es keine entsprechende intellektuelle Rechte-Theorie,
aber es gäbe dann doch einige wichtige Rechteautoren.
Also es nennt dann zum Beispiel Mola oder Karl Schmitt.
Also der Gedanke, der da drin steckt, ist ja wirklich charmant und auch,
sagen wir mal so, für den Urlaub, also für die Unterbrechung des modernen Alltags genau richtig.
Man fährt irgendwo hin, wo man den Regeln der singulären Vernunft folgt.
Eppe und Flut, es ist entweder Eppe oder Flut, je nachdem geht man zum Strand.
Es ist Sommer oder Winter, je nachdem stellt man sich drauf ein,
was man erlebt. erlebt. Also man gibt sich so ein bisschen hin.
Aber ihr würdet es ja ausweiten auf Konstanten, die auch sonst uns abträgen. Genau.
Und hier hat man ja dieses ganz allgemeine Problem. Deswegen ja auch diese ganze,
okay, wir haben zuerst eine zivilisatorische Entwicklung und dann irgendwann
recht spät so eine Soziologie, die das so reflektiert.
Und die kam mir dann irgendwann ganz schnell drauf zu sagen,
ja, die Aufklärung brachte irgendwie
so Rationalitäten mit und die gab es aber nicht mehr im Singular.
Also während man als Feld- und Wiesenexperte, nämlich man streut halt einfach
durch die Landschaft und pflückt sich etwas. Man nimmt halt,
was man kriegen kann. Der Gott wollte, dass du Bären isst, also waren da gerade Bären und so.
Dann fing man aber irgendwann in Dessas zu werden. Man hat Sachen angebaut.
Man hat sich die Frage gestellt, Was baue ich denn jetzt eigentlich an?
So, es gab Bauernregeln. Es gab da irgendwann diesen Nobelpreis für diese Entdeckung,
egal welche wirtschaftlichen, ökonomischen Gedanken und Theorien man so entwickelt,
es gibt immer den Gegenentwurf.
Eine Bauernregel und die andere. Also unterschiedliche Rationalitäten,
die ja in welchem Verhältnis zueinander eigentlich, welche ist ein richtiger,
welche ist ein falscher und so.
Nur, jetzt kann man sagen, okay, der Mensch hat irgendwie ganz schön viel Gedankenkraft
da reingebracht, um diese unterschiedlichen Rationalitäten zu entwickeln bis
hin zu dieser absoluten Funktionaldifferenzierung, Arbeitsteilung und so weiter
und so fort. Dieses moderne Leben, wie wir es haben.
So, das kann natürlich überfordern, nur jetzt dann einfach, dass das Gegenangebot
ist, aus diesem Reflektionsdiskurs auszusteigen und wieder zurück zur singulären Vernunft zu gehen.
Heißt dann aber auch, auf alle Vorteile, die das mit sich brachte, zu verzichten.
Und wir haben die singuläre Vernunft aus Gründen hinter uns gelassen,
weil sie nicht leistungsfähig genug ist.
Es reicht nicht nur aus Erde und Wasser Lehm zu mischen und dann so eine halbhohe
Mauer, die gegen Wind schützt. Nee, wir hätten gerne 300 Meter hohe Türme,
in denen wir Bankgeschäfte machen.
Ja, das wären die bösen internationalen Konzerne, sagt Herr Krah.
Und diese Abstriche müsste man aber dann gleich hinterher schieben im Gespräch die ganze Zeit.
Die Kubitscheks leben auf einem Hof und sind dann für ein paar Monate Selbstversorger
und haben ihre Ziegen dort und vermutlich haben die auch alle halbdeutschen Namen.
Die ringen sich darüber auf, dass irgendwer irgendwem das Auto wegnehmen will.
Die wollen uns die ganze Zivilisation nehmen.
Ja, das ist definitiv ein Paradox, aber ein Paradox, das uns glaube ich auch
über diesen engen politischen Rahmen hinaus,
ja während dieses Podcast, den wir zusammen machen,
immer wieder verfolgt, dass Leute plötzlich die moderne Art Akta legen und sagen,
ich sag euch jetzt mal ganz genau innerhalb von fünf Minuten,
wie Frauen sind, wie Männer sind.
Und das sind ja lauter Sinnangebote, sehr reduktionistisch, die laufend gemacht
werden, diese ganzen evangelikalen Bewegungen, die wir überall haben.
Im Prinzip funktioniert das ja nach dem Versprechen immer.
Ja, die Moderne ist eigentlich doch uns ein bisschen zu anstrengend geworden.
Hier bieten wir einen Ausgang.
Und dieses Versprechen der Moderne, muss man aber sagen, ist ja eines,
das sich besonders dann gut für einen erfüllt, wenn man ökonomisch gut ausgestattet
ist. Das ist jetzt bei Krah und so natürlich der Fall.
Er ist, glaube ich, Rechtsanwalt und da sind ja auch einige anderen der AfD,
um die man sich jetzt keine Sorgen machen muss.
Aber es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung,
wir hatten ja eben Zahlen gehabt, diese Freiheitsversprechen,
die da sind, nur sehr partiell überhaupt leben kann, weil gar nicht die finanzielle Ausstattung da ist.
Das heißt, die haben von diesen Errungenschaften der Moderne wenig,
die sehen zwar das Hochhaus, werden aber nie da reinkommen.
Und für die ist es durchaus ein sehr hübsches Angebot zu sagen,
na, das war doch eh nie für euch gedacht und da sitzen die Grünen drin oder
wer auch immer da drin sitzt jetzt oder George Soros, ja, das müssen wir mal
wieder alles abbauen, runterreißen.
Wir machen jetzt mal wieder so wie früher, denn da haben wir doch noch alle gut zusammengelebt.
Alle zurück in die Hütte.
Im Prinzip schon, ja. Deswegen gehen wir jetzt nach Schnellroder,
habe ich mir auch angesehen.
Er war zu Gast bei Götz Kubitschek und Ellen Kositzer. Das ist die Frau von Götz Kubitschek.
Du weißt, das Ehepaar sieht sich. Und wir sind jetzt hier und erst mal sagt
Kral, wir dürfen keine Angst haben vor unserer eigenen Argumentation.
Bislang war es ja so, dass man sich immer so ein bisschen vor seinen eigenen
Argumenten gefürchtet hat. Man ist immer mit sekundären Argumenten nach vorn
gegangen. Also der Klassiker ist immer, wir sind gegen illegale Masseneinwanderung.
Heißt das, wir sind für legale Masseneinwanderung? Die Antwort lautet doch,
wir sind gegen Masseneinwanderung.
Und zwar unabhängig von der Frage, ob ich sie für legal erkläre oder ob sie illegal ist.
Also da soll man sich quasi radikalisieren. Nun gibt es ja rechte...
Also kein Tourismus mehr, oder was?
Ja, Tourismus natürlich schon. Ich habe ja...
Illegal, legal, temporär, auf Dauer.
Es gibt ja auch so ein Interview mit den Kubitscheks in dem Buch Die Angstmacher,
ist das, von Thomas Wagner nachzulesen.
Da erzählen ja die Kubitscheks, dass sie so viel gereist sind und dass sie dadurch
erfahren haben, wie anders die Kulturen sind. Also das war die Schlussfolgerung daraus.
Naja, finde ich aber zumindest mal interessant, also kontraintuitiv,
weil die intuitive Antwort ist immer ja, die Leute sollen reisen,
dann lernen sie andere Kulturen kennen und dann sagen die, ja haben wir gemacht
und da haben wir gesehen, wie unterschiedlich wir sind.
Naja, sei es drum. Nun gibt es rechte Bindendiskurse selbstverständlich und
wo will man eigentlich hin?
Ich will das im Salon noch mal ein bisschen dann zeigen mit Wirtschaftspolitik
und Europa, also er tritt ja jetzt auch für Europa an und ist jetzt kein dezidierter
Europa Gegner oder jemand der sagt, dass wir, wir renationalisieren uns völlig.
Es gibt aber Stränge in der Partei jetzt bei der AfD, die sagen wir brauchen
eine totale Loslösung aus Europa und wir brauchen nur noch die Nationen jeweils.
Anekdotisch der Parteitag ging ja drunter drüber und hat auch sehr viel länger
gedauert als und so weiter und die hatten ja zwischendurch sogar beschlossen
aus der Europäischen Union auszutreten, bis sie feststellten,
ah ne Formfehler müssen wir noch mal korrigieren.
Geblieben ist dann dieses Völkerbund Gedankenexperimente und so weiter und so
fort, also die sind schon.
Jaja, aber er schildert das jetzt ganz gut. Also er ist da kein Anhänger von.
Also er will nicht die totale Renationalisierung, aber diese Strömung gibt es
tatsächlich in der Partei und er beschreibt das jetzt so.
Das ist auch schwer zu verstehen, aber es gibt natürlich, und das weiß,
glaube ich, niemand besser als das Institut in Schnellrother.
Es gibt der rechte Binnendiskurse.
Und was wir zurzeit erleben, ist eine Welle, die ich auch in Brüssel sehe,
dass sehr, sehr gut finanzierte Institutionen kommen und die vertreten das Konzept
des NETCON, des National Conservatism, gibt es da auch immer eine sehr schöne
Konferenz in sehr schönen Hotels.
Und da sagt man eigentlich, wir brauchen die komplette Renationalisierung,
also überhaupt gar keine Europapolitik mehr.
Und das Erstaunliche ist, dass dann diese ganz vielen kleinen Nationalstaaten,
die dann völlig allein dastehen würde, sich selbstverständlich sofort unter
den großen Mantel des Bruders USA schlüpfen. Daher kommt auch die Finanzierung.
Denn das sind diese beiden Strömungen, die man in der AfD erkennen muss.
Also es gibt einmal die, die sehr transatlantisch ausgerichtet sind und auch
entsprechende Verbindungen knüpfen. Zum Beispiel dann auch vor ein paar Jahren zu Milo Yiannopoulos.
War dieser sehr schillernde Trump-Aktivist.
Dann zu anderen Republikanern, also die machen dann auch so Konferenzen, nahmen die ein.
Und die sind auch im Übrigen jetzt im Bezug auf den Krieg in der Ukraine auf NATO-Seite durchaus.
Also das ist ganz interessant zu erleben. Im Prinzip können wir das bei Meloni ja auch sehen.
Meloni ist ja keine, die sich gegen diese Intervention da richtet.
Also da unterscheidet sie sich von anderen rechten Strömungen.
Und dann gibt es die, und das ist eher so der Kreis, der sich um Schnellroda bildet,
die also sehr stark anti-transatlantisch sind,
sagen wir, und die so ein Kerneuropa wollen oder so eine Festung Europa und
auch viele Teile der identitären Bewegung ist ja auch schon diese Bewegung als
eine sehr europäische Bewegung zu verstehen.
Zwar gibt es die in den einzelnen europäischen Ländern, aber man ist ja doch
innerhalb Europas dann sehr gut vernetzt und das geht eher in diese Richtung.
Nichts ist so internationalisiert wie das neue rechte nationale Denken.
Selbst er hat es schon, despektier dich, da gibt es dann auch so Konferenzen
in tollen Hotels, da treiben die sich immer.
Jaja, so jetzt ein Thema, wir haben es eben gesagt, wir haben zu wenig Leute
hier. Wir müssen eigentlich mehr reinlassen ins Land.
Und das wirklich nur unter dieser, die Liberalen und so weiter wollen ja immer
die Volkswirtschaft, der Wohlstand und so weiter, nur unter diesem Aspekt haben
wir das nur besprochen. Wir zwingen niemanden zu irgendetwas,
weder zu Kinderkriegen noch und so.
In Schnellroda denkt man sogar schon über Remigration nach.
Aber im Moment sind wir wieder in so einer Entweder-Oder-Zeit.
Es geht tatsächlich um die Substanz.
Da muss man eben mit Leuten arbeiten, die auch bereit sind, harte Dinge zu sagen
und darüber nachzudenken, wie harte Dinge umgesetzt werden können.
Und das zeigt sich alleine schon an diesem Zurückzucken,
wenn es beispielsweise um den Begriff der Remigration geht,
der ja im Moment gesetzt wird und der ventiliert wird Und der von Sellner ausgearbeitet
in seinem Buch eben jetzt nicht so ein brutales Ereignis ist,
aber ein hartes Ereignis, weil er eben sagt, wir haben eineinhalb Generationen
Zeit, die können wir uns auch lassen, aber klar sein muss, dass die Fließrichtung sich umkehrt.
Martin Sellner hat, also dieser Identitäre aus Österreich, hat das ja dann niedergeschrieben,
ausgearbeitet. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen hochtragend.
Er hat dann mal so aufgeschrieben, wie das so in Zukunft sein wird.
Und dann seht ihr wieder tolle Volksfeste überall. Und dass dann die,
die gekommen sind, wieder in die Heimat zurückgeschickt werden und auch gerne gehen.
Das ist die Idee. Man macht ihnen ein Angebot. Man macht ihnen ein tolles Angebot
und genauso wird es auch dann von KRA aufgeriffen.
Aber die sind doch auch noch fasziniert davon, dass es halt hart ist,
das Vorgehen, oder? Diese Härte.
Ja, ja.
Da könnt ihr ja genauso gut sagen, es wäre so, komm, wir schaffen das,
es wird aber hart. Ja. Also das Hartsein für sich reklamieren.
Das finden sie toll. Man hat ja zumindest bei Kubitschek doch eine große Vorliebe für die Preußen.
Absolut.
Und dann muss es hart sein. Während Krader relativiert, er ist ja Katholik und
Menschenfreund, das ist ja gar nicht hart. Das ist eigentlich ein Dienst am Menschen.
Remigration ist gar nicht hart, weil wir ja auch den Leuten was Gutes tun.
Ich bin jetzt, ich bin ja Reiseherfiel und ich gehöre ja zu den Menschen, die auf Flixbus fahren.
Irgendwann bin ich jetzt mal nachts um drei am Karlsruher Hauptbahnhof gestrandet.
Und da lief dann ein offenbar aus Ostafrika eingewanderter oder hergelockter,
wie immer man das nennen möchte, lief dann, es war ziemlich kalt,
ohne Strümpfe in Badelatschen durch diesen Hauptbahnhof und sang irgendetwas.
Ist dieser Mann glücklich hier? Natürlich, der gehört ja nicht her.
Tja, ich kann durchs Frankfurter Bahnhof zurückgehen.
Das ist Satire.
Nein, das meinen die ja nicht als Satire.
Ich weiß, er meint es ernst.
Ja, ja, man kann es nur satirisch auffassen.
Ein ausgewanderter oder hergelockter.
Und ich meine, die sind ja nur in diesem Modus unterwegs. Und klar,
du wirst überall sehr viele unglückliche Menschen finden, aber die kommen allerdings
nicht aus Zugebiet Afrika.
Das können wir allerdings sehr gut, die Zugewanderten so im Unglück zurücklassen,
dass sie einfach, wenn man sie sieht, man Mitleid bekommt und denkt,
ja stimmt, eigentlich willst du zurück nach Zimbabwe.
Und wir hatten ja diesen einen Text gelesen, selbst Dänemark oder so,
das glücklichste Land der Welt, wo die dann sagen, nee, ich fahre so gern zurück
nach Zimbabwe. Da sind zwar alle arm, aber ich werde angelächelt am Flughafen.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich meine, das ist ja eine trostlose Sache, wenn du in der Hauptstadt,
im Bahnhof sowieso, die sind ja auch so eingerichtet, dass man nur scheu aneinander vorbeischauen kann.
Ich bin auch immer wieder froh, dass ich zurück nach Frankfurt nach Hause fahren darf.
Es ist grauenhaft, aber das hat andere Gründe.
Nun ist es ja so, dass es noch eine Strömung bei den AfDlern gibt,
nämlich die rechten Libertären.
Die finden sich zum Teil auch in der FDP, aber die finden natürlich auch Anklang bei der AfD.
Und die Libertären sehen jetzt jemanden wie Kran nicht so gern.
Der ist ja katholisch, hat so ein gewisses Wertegerüst, Er findet auch den Staat
recht gut. Auch Kubitschek ist mit seiner Preußen-Vorliebe auch jemand,
der den Staat als starken Akteur sehen will. Trotzdem gibt es aber diese Libertären.
Auf die wird von Ellen Kusezah angesprochen.
So einen Weg, einen Modus wie Wendy mit den Libertären finden?
Oder ist das ein Weg in die Egozentrik, ins Individualistische? Das muss man austesten.
Zunächst einmal, was die Zittelmann-Kritik angeht, ich kann jedem nur erzählen,
mein Buch zu lesen, Politik von rechts, das ist hier im Hause erschienen,
und sich das Kapitel zur Wirtschaft durchzulesen.
Also wer mich danach noch für einen Sozialisten hält, mit dem rede ich mal über
einen Sozialismusbegriff.
Insofern stehen Sie breitbeinig da, mit der einen Seite Antikapitalismus,
mit der anderen Seite Libertäre.
Das ist schon faszinierend. Das ist doch lustig, oder? Ja, das freut den Politiker in mir.
Aber ein paar Dinge sind mir schon ganz, ganz wichtig. Und das heißt,
der Markt selbst ist keine Moral.
Also wer das glaubt, wer glaubt, also wer mit Ayn Rand glaubt,
das Habgier und das Streben nach Profitmaximierung, dass das schon die Moral ist.
Mit dem stimme ich nicht überhaupt.
Ja, davon grenzt er sich ab.
Geil. Jetzt haben die also diese libertäre Strömung, gegen die sie sich eigentlich
wenden möchten mit vollem Herzen.
Ja. Geht aber nicht, weil es durch Zufall auch bei manchen Sprüchen noch so
ein bisschen ihre eigene Klientel ist.
Ja, die sind ja auch gegen die Gutmenschen, gegen die Grünen.
Und sie müssen aber auch mit denen noch irgendwas auch zu tun haben.
Und ja, es stimmt ja schon, auch so staatliche Eingriffe sind mitunter übel.
Das würden Sie ja sagen, zum Beispiel jetzt bei Corona hat man das ja gesehen.
Und dann gibt es auch diese Überschneidungen wieder bei der AfD.
Aber Sie müssen das unter einen Hut bekommen. Also mit anderen Worten,
was man hier natürlich erleben kann, ist eigentlich den Vorwurf,
den gerade CDU macht in verquerer Form.
Nämlich, wenn er sagt, die CDU muss neutralisieren, Also muss da jemand von
rechts außen mit dem Herz-Jesu-Sozialisten und weiß ich nicht wem zusammenbringen,
ja, dann müssen die neutralisieren und Krah muss jetzt auch sehen,
weil das eigentlich natürlich ein katholisches Weltbild und ein libertäres Weltbild
können nicht zusammengehen.
Also das ist völlig klar. Jetzt mal von abgesehen, dass auch ein katholisches
und ein rechtes Weltbild nicht zusammengehen können eigentlich,
aber das wird man Krah nicht mehr verklickern können.
Aber dass zumindest diese beiden Grundsätze nicht zusammengehen,
das ist so fundamental, dass man eigentlich sagen müsste, uns verbindet gar nichts.
Aber da man natürlich die rechte Identität über alles stellt und dann auch noch
die Biologie und die deutsche Natur und was weiß ich, schafft man eine Gemeinsamkeit,
wo keine ist. Und das ist, wenn man nicht in der Lage ist.
Menschen als Menschen anzusehen, sondern immer in Volksgruppen und Lager denkt.
Denn natürlich verbindet eigentlich den Katholiken, den deutschen Katholiken,
mehr mit dem katholischen Ostafrikaner als mit dem libertären AfD-Anhänger.
Aber das kann er natürlich nicht sehen.
Wir sind natürlich offen für alle möglichen Ausflüge, Gamescom und so weiter.
Wir werden aber nicht zu einem AfD-Parteitag gehen.
Nein, auf keinen Fall.
Es lohnt sich aber unter dieser Einfragestellung die alten Parteitage sich nochmal
anzuschauen. Die AfD hat zum Beispiel nie hinbekommen, das Thema Rente mal zu thematisieren.
Weil du diese ostdeutschen Landesverbände hast, die natürlich mit diesem DDR
und so weiter, ja wir brauchen diesen großen kollektivistischen,
bei uns fällst du nicht tiefer als in staatliche Hände. Die staatliche Hände,
der Staat kümmert sich um deine Rente, du gehst hier nicht verloren.
Und dann diesen baden-württembergischen Gegenpol, Meuten und so.
Rente, also jeder auf eigene Faust, okay, hier gibt es kein Staat,
wer Menschheit sagt und so weiter.
Und die haben das ja nie hingekriegt, die haben ja wirklich diese Tagesordnung,
Journalisten alle schon so, und morgen denn Rente?
Und dann am Morgen aufgewacht, Thema gestrichen. Und dann wollten sie es irgendwann
in so einen eigenen Land auslagern, in so ein Themenkonvent oder sowas.
Haben das dann auch nicht gemacht.
Bei manchen Sachen wissen sie genau, das sind unsere Stolpersteine.
Die einen kommen mit der singulären Vernunft, zu der sie zurückwollen,
die anderen mit dem Hyperindividualismus.
Das kriegen sie nicht zusammen. Und entsprechend bauen sie auch ihr Programm.
Und dieser Parteitag jetzt, den sie da hatten, der war ja so drunter und drüber.
Es war ja schlimmer als jeder Piratenparteitag früher, der nur mit Tagesordnungsanträgen
bombardiert wurde und sich alle auf den Füßen standen.
Höcker ist wieder ein bisschen mehr ins Zentrum herangerückt und so weiter.
Aber man hätte das eigentlich nochmal, hätte man vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Zeit gekostet.
Das war ja um ihn herum wohl auch eine ziemliche Schlammschlacht,
hat er zuerst dabei den Kubitscheks erzählt.
Krah grenzt sich nun vom Liberalismus nochmal ab.
Der klassische Liberale kennt das Individuum und die Menschheit.
Aber wir können auch die ganzen Zwischenthemen.
Und wir haben eine Familie, die Verbundenheit zwischen ihm und ihrem Sohn.
Basiert nicht nur auf ihrem freien Willen, sondern sie basiert auf einer ganz
klaren biologischen Realität.
Und die Zusammenhang, dass wir beide uns besser verstehen, oder wir drei,
weil wir natürlich eine dieselbe Sprache sprechen, weil wir ähnlich sozialisiert
sind, weil wir auch einfach ähnlich in vielerlei Hinsicht sind,
allein wahrscheinlich schon von unserem Phänotyp und von unserer Physiognomie. Das sind Realitäten.
Das hat aber noch gut gerettet.
Man merkt ja schon Phänotyp und Physiognomie.
Ja, das sind die eigenen Grundbegriffe.
In welcher Richtung man hier noch gerne vielleicht weiter argumentieren würde.
Aber jetzt muss man so ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Wir hören hier nochmal in dieses Ende rein, denn das ist ja wirklich interessant.
Sondern sie basiert auf einer ganz klaren biologischen Realität.
Und die Zusammenhang, dass wir beide uns besser verstehen oder wir drei,
weil wir natürlich eine dieselbe Sprache sprechen, weil wir ähnlich sozialisiert sind.
Ähnlich sozialisiert.
Gleiche Sprache, ähnlich sozialisiert. Also bevor wieder so auf seinen Modus.
Ja, die Physiognomie, die gehen, und so weiter.
Genau, kam er erst mal auf Sprache und Sozialisation.
Und da muss man ja sagen, Sprache kann man lernen. Sprache kann man jedem beibringen
und die Sozialisation, man muss nur das Bildungssystem mal öffnen und entsprechen,
dann kann man jeden in jeden rein sozialisieren.
Also da sieht man schon, ja, eigentlich, also es kostet Ihnen auch Arbeit,
immer wieder auf, nein, ich wollte ja auf meine ursächliche Vernunft zurückkommen
und so weiter, weil dann schiebt das natürlich hinterher.
Wir auch einfach ähnlich in vielerlei Hinsicht sind, allein wahrscheinlich schon
von unserem Phänotyp und von unserer Physiognomie. Das sind Realitäten.
Und das Versprechen des Liberalismus, dass genau Phänotyp und Physiognomie keine
Rolle zu spielen haben, sondern dass man sich hinein sozialisieren kann.
Dass man offene Bildungssysteme hat, dass man andere Sprachen erlernen kann
und diese dann vielleicht auch für sich gewinnbringend einbringen kann im Job.
Da müsste man jetzt eigentlich, wenn man zuhört und in einer anderen Partei
als in der AfD ist, daraus lernen, nämlich nicht zu sagen, Was ist noch mal das AfD-Thema?
Ach, Flüchtlinge, was können wir noch mal persönlich gegen Flüchtlinge tun,
damit wir auch ein paar AfD-Wähler bekommen? Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Wie gesagt, egal, was ihr macht, man wird immer sagen, aber die AfD geht einen
Schritt weiter. Also es ist da nie im Blumentopf zu gewinnen.
Zu fragen ist, wie kann man eigentlich an dem liberalen versprechen,
das ja ein unglaubliches eigentlich ist. Also du kannst nämlich da tatsächlich
sein, wer du willst. Du kannst dich entwerfen und wirst nicht irgendwo festgebunden
an den Rheinbund von 1806.
Das ist das Versprechen, das aber nur dann wirklich trägt, wenn es auch ausgelebt
werden kann. Und nicht nur jeden vorbehalten sind, die mit 10.000 netto im Monat
sagen, ich verwirkliche mich. Sondern es müssen auch die anderen sich verwirklichen können.
Da liegt das große Versprechen des Liberalismus. und damit auch die Möglichkeit,
sich gegen die AfD politisch zu stellen, indem man dieses Versprechen wahrwerden lässt.
Es ist deshalb vielleicht auch sehr kurz gegriffen, Wenn wir momentan.
Ein zu simples FDP-Bashing erleben. Wir haben auch schon dazu angeleitet,
in einem Live-Salon die FDP zu hassen. Und wir rufen immer wieder gerne dazu auf.
Aber ich halte es für sehr schwierig, wenn das jetzt nun in Büchern geschieht,
in Zeitungsartikeln, laufen bei Twitter, wenn man sagt, ja, Freiheit,
Eigenverantwortung, das ist alles FDP. Das geht nicht.
Also ja, man kann sagen, es kann nicht wirklich Ausdruck von Freiheit sein,
wenn man mit 200 Sachen über die Autobahn brettert.
Und ja, es werden auch irgendwo sinnvolle Einschränkungen vonnöten sein.
Aber erst einmal festzustellen, dass Einschränkungen Einschränkungen sind und
für viele auch als solche empfunden werden.
Und dass man dann schon ein gutes Gegenangebot machen muss, zum Beispiel eine
gute Infrastruktur für einen alternativen Verkehr.
Das müsste doch logisch sein. Und es müsste auch klar sein, dass nur mit einem
Verzicht eigentlich nichts gewonnen werden kann.
Und ich fand es dann erstaunlich, dass hier in diesem Gespräch bei den Kubitscheks
plötzlich auf ein Buch verwiesen wird, Das ist nicht von einem rechten Denker
handelt, sondern das von Lepinis ist, wo es um den Verzicht geht.
Das ist bei Surkamp erschienen und ein Buch, das sehr gehypt wurde.
Und da gibt es auch vieles, was sich daran so angeschlossen hat an dieser Argumentation.
Man muss den Verzicht klar machen und so weiter.
Und interessanterweise gibt es aber da gar keinen Dissens bei der AfD.
Wir hören hier mal rein. Das ist jetzt ein längerer Clip, aber wir sollten den
mal so ganz in der Argumentation nachvollziehen.
Zu sprechen, was jüngst auch der Politikprofessor, glaube ich,
im Berlin-Lehrter Philipp Lepenys in seinem Buch Verzicht und Verbot skizziert hat.
Dass es sich bei dem liberalen Bürgertum, das im 19. Jahrhundert stark wurde.
Eben um Leute handelte, die zum einen natürlich die Chance zu wirtschaften und
zu individuellem Erfolg zu kommen sehr begrüßt und gefördert haben,
die aber auf der anderen Seite eine so starke Rückbindung hatten,
dass das Ganze nicht in so eine Schweinchen-Schlau-Mentalität abgerutscht ist.
Der Verzicht, also das heißt die Askese, für die Allgemeinheit war mindestens
so wichtig, wie der gesunde Egoismus Erfolg zu haben.
Und das ist aus meiner Sicht eine Schlüsselfrage, über die wir in Zukunft auch
zu sprechen haben. Woher kommt denn überhaupt so etwas wie eine überindividuelle Rückbindung?
Mohler würde sagen, das ist die Erziehungsleistung von Jahrhunderten,
die in anderthalb liberalen Generationen zugrunde geritten wird.
Möller-Vandenbrouck. Ja, also Mohler-Vandenbrouck.
Unsere Antwort wäre mit Sicherheit die, dass die Rückbindung an den Glauben
und an ein anderes Menschenbild als das liberale Menschenbild unbedingt notwendig ist.
Ja, diese Frage der Rückbindung, wir wollen jetzt nicht wieder Böckenförde hier
hervorholen, aber das ist etwas, was sich ja tatsächlich stellt.
Und wenn man aber sich nochmal diesen liberalen Entwurf ansieht,
dann muss das natürlich nicht in eine absolute Ego-Gesellschaft münden.
Ich habe bei manchen auch jetzt im linksliberalen Spektrum den Eindruck,
dass sie den Verzicht als solchen einfach mal abfeiern.
So wie wir das ja dann bei dem Corona-Diskurs erlebt haben.
Also wenigstens greift man jetzt mal durch, jetzt muss man mal auf was verzichten.
Auch wenn es nicht mehr nötig ist, sagen wir, da tragen wir aber dennoch noch
Risiken oder so was. Also das ist da so eine Glorifizierung des Verzichts,
die wir jetzt hier wiederfinden, weil man sagt, zurückgebunden an und deswegen
unterwerfen wir uns und so.
Ich plädiere ja immer mal wieder für den linken Hedonismus und will jetzt hier
die Chance nicht nutzen, um zu sagen, wir brauchen mehr Egoismus.
Aber ich finde, dass man sich schon mal darüber Gedanken machen muss.
Wie weit man eigentlich den Verzicht als politisches Programm jetzt sich auf
die Fahnen schreiben will.
Denn man ist da in einem ganz merkwürdigen Feld.
Also bei den einen, die sagen, ja, wir sind da eh rückgebunden an irgendwas
viel Größeres und müssen uns dem unterwerfen.
Oder, ich denke, ich habe es ja auch noch nicht gelesen, wir werden es in unserem
Salonbuch, was wir der Zukunft schulden, dann auch bemerken,
dass es da auch dann heißt, ja, wir sind ja so als Menschheit da,
noch mal in ganz besonderer Weise befragt.
Ja, aber ich würde auch generell dieses Verzichten, das ist so ein Diskurs,
der sehr schnell, also wenn wir jetzt mal so von Tempolimit und so Dingen mal weggehen.
Also es gibt ja so ein paar Sachen, wo man sagen kann, okay,
da wäre Verzicht jetzt angebracht.
Aber wenn wir uns ansehen, wie arm die meisten Menschen in Deutschland sind
oder wie wenig auch bei denen,
die ein bisschen mehr verdienen, verdient wird, wenn wir das uns ansehen,
ja, Dann ist halt die Frage, wie weit kommen wir mit diesem ganzen Verzichtsdiskurs.
Man kann damit immer alle ziemlich gut ruhig stellen. Ja, das haben wir ja jetzt gemerkt.
Es gibt auch deshalb dann natürlich keinen herrlichsten Herbst,
weil man gesagt hat, ja, wir müssen jetzt aber auch alle zusammenreißen.
Wir haben ja da den, wir kämpfen ja da einen Kampf für unsere Demokratie und
deswegen können wir auch jetzt leider kein Geld für Heizung,
für Heizkosten ausgeben.
Und das, finde ich, ist etwas, was immer dominanter wird.
Und das sorgt am Ende natürlich dafür, Die, die haben, verzichten ja nicht plötzlich.
Die geben ja auch nicht 3000 Euro ab im Monat, sondern die machen einfach ihren
Lebensstil weiter. Rufen den anderen aber noch mal zu, verzichtet doch.
Das war doch damals bei diesem Paket da für die Familien.
Da wurde so eine lachhafte Summe von der Bundesregierung, also schon von der Ampelkoalition.
Und dann haben all diese Leute, ich will die Klavierspielen modeln und sonst
was tun, haben ja dann bei twitter waren sich einig haben sie gut gemacht wo
man sagt gut dafür spielt ihr auf dem klavier nicht einen ton für den betrag der da gegeben hat.
Die schlechtesten Diskurse sind alle verlogen, wenn ich drüber nachdenke.
Mal beginnen bei dem Kaloriendefizit. Also für das will man wirklich was haben.
Nach welchen Vorstellungen auch immer, den etwas besseren Buddy,
wenn man verzichtet auf Ausgaben, dann nur, um das Geld zu sparen für andere
Sachen, die man dann schon im Kopf hat.
Und so vererbt sich das auch auf die politischen Verzichtsdiskurse.
Die sind alle so ein bisschen… Es sei denn, man… Passt aber gut rein in das,
was die AfD so diskutiert.
Ja, es sei denn, man rückbindet es an Gott und sagt,
das mache ich fürs jenseits oder hier die longtermism Leute sagen,
das mache ich als Opfer für die Menschheit als Ganzes, damit es der in tausend
Jahren noch gut geht. Das ist also diese Idee da.
Jetzt kommt etwas sehr Interessantes. Die AfD will ja nicht antibürgerlich sein,
sie möchte aber so ein besonderes Bürgertum adressieren und Kubitschek versucht
sich dem jetzt mal anzunähern.
Das sind Leute, die weder dem Geld noch dem Erfolg Macht über ihr Leben einräumen.
Also wir hatten jetzt eben diese Liberalen, die sind egoistisch,
geldgetrieben, die denken nur an sich und jetzt gibt es da noch so andere,
will er irgendwie uns deutlich machen.
Die tatsächlich den Sinn ihres Lebens, die Erfüllung ihres Lebens außerhalb
dieser Ego-Maschine oder dieser Selbstoptimierung finden und das fasziniert mich immer wieder.
Ja, Leute, die die zivilisatorischen Errungenschaften schon abgestreift haben
und wieder zum wahren Kern des Ich-liefer-mich-der-singulären-Vernunft,
Gott, Natur, was auch immer aus, das fasziniert ihn natürlich.
Zeigt mir aber nur, ja, weil er selber immer noch in dem Haus lebt,
immer noch ein Girokonto hat, immer noch Geld verdienen möchte.
Ja, beziehungsweise du denkst weiter als er, er bietet uns jetzt die Schwundstufe dessen an.
Also er will jetzt sagen, aber was sind denn jetzt, er spricht ja von Bürgern,
also welche Bürger können das denn sein? Und jetzt kann man sagen,
gut partiell dominiert ja auch bei einem liberalbürgerlichen Lebensentwurf nicht alles die Ökonomie.
Man hat Nachbarschaftsverbindungen, familiäre Verbindungen, engagiert sich vielleicht irgendwo.
Du bist ja, was bist du, Schriftführer des Schwimmvereins?
Ich bin der zweite Vorsitzende.
Du bist der zweite Vorsitzende. Ist das eine Aufgabe, wo man nur den Titel hat?
Also der erste Vorsitzende im deutschen Vereinswesen ist immer für die Außendarstellung,
der geht dann zum Sportkreistag und macht so ein bisschen die politische Bande.
Der zweite Vorsitzende ist typischerweise für die Mitgliederorganisationen intern zuständig.
Wenn er flankiert wird durch Schriftführer und so weiter, ist er da ziemlich
entlastet, führt also die Mitgliederliste und hat ansonsten das Anberaumen von
Vorstandssitzungen, Mitgliederversammlung wird dann sozusagen vom Schriftführer schon mit vorbereitet.
Also es gibt eine klare Aufgabenverteilung. Ich bin nicht nur der Herr Steinmeier
des Vereins, sondern ich muss Excel-Tabellen kopieren.
Also du engagierst dich in der außerekonomischen Sphäre.
Genau. Ich kriege dafür gar kein Geld. Ich habe es sogar abgelehnt.
Also du bist jetzt der Adressat für Kubitschek eigentlich.
Ganz klar. Denn Kubitschek erzählt jetzt Folgendes und ich habe es zwei,
dreimal schon gehört, weil ich es so lustig finde.
Also wenn es die Kubitscheks nicht wären, würde ich sagen, es ist fast rührend.
Also, dass es Leute gibt, wir waren letzten Winter in zwei Mendelssohn-Oratorien
in Merseburg in einer tausend Jahre alten Kirche und das Tolle war,
also Stücke, die auch nicht oft aufgeführt werden,
das war großartig, die Solisten waren von außen eingekauft,
das Orchester war aus Merseburg, der Chor war aus Merseburg und Merseburg ist
jetzt nicht Regensburg oder so, sondern das ist eigentlich eine Stadt,
wo man sagt, die bürgerliche Schicht ist eigentlich auch dünn.
In der Pause, wenn es dann hier Unstrutwein und ein Schnittchen gab,
hat man exakt den Dialekt aus der Region gehört.
Da kamen dann die Sängerinnen und die Sänger und die Geiger und die Cellisten
und haben gesagt, gib mal her, Junge, ich sprauche mal schnell und so.
Ich kann das ja nicht nachmachen.
Ganz toll. Und das ist eine Schicht, die also Abend für Abend für Abend in die Probe gesteckt hat,
um in dieser Kulisse dieses tausendjährigen otonischen Domes diese Stücke zu Gehör zu bringen.
Und das sind Leute, die ihre Lebenserfüllung nicht dem Geld,
dem Erfolg, der Selbstoptimierung und so weiter unterwerfen.
Ja, und die wählen alle nicht die AfD, die da gesungen haben.
Lass mich das mal.
Würde ich schon fast die Hand für ins Feuer legen.
Das ist ja da meine Region Thüringen und so. Und so, ne?
Ja.
Nun ist ja so, es gibt ja diese, warum werden Menschen so Neonazis und sowas
und ich habe mich ja auch lange darüber gewundert, aber es scheint zu stimmen.
Ekel. Man ekelt sich einfach vor anderen Menschen und macht daraus ein politisches
Programm. Und wenn er jetzt nachefft.
Bei H.P. Lovecraft diesem Schriftsteller ist das tatsächlich auch so dokumentiert.
Der Ekel hat ihn dahingetrieben. Gibt's einen interessanten Essay von Michel Wayback.
Der Andreas Dingsda-Bums, der bei Thilo immer mal wieder, Kemper.
Man hat das ja auch bei Thilo nochmal betont oder auch der, wie heißt der Philosoph?
Philipp Högl oder so. Also diese ganzen Typen, die das dann so aufgreifen.
Und wenn ich jetzt Kubitschek höre, wie er das so nachäfft, sag ich mal,
wie er da angesprochen wird mit diesem ostdeutschen Slang und so weiter.
Ich will nicht übertreiben, aber wenn ich in Thüringen bin und mein hart abtrainiertes Thüringisch,
mein schönes Hochdeutsch, wird dort wiedergespiegelt mit Menschen,
die mich plötzlich so ostdeutsch, So wie er das so dieses flefelhafte,
ja gib mal her, ich komme gerade von der Bühne, ich brauche jetzt mal schnell
und so weiter, ich muss mich hier stärken, du musst darauf verzichten.
Dann überkommt mich so ein bisschen Ekel. Ich will mein Essen nicht mit Leuten
teilen, die mir mit Mundart und so weiter.
Ich weiß, wie das jetzt einige hören, aber ich will ausdrücklich dazu sagen,
ich habe auch mich lange gefragt, ist es wirklich der Ekel?
Weil das hieße ja, wir können jetzt nicht einfach ein politisches Programm dagegen
entwickeln, sondern wir müssen ja wirklich mit rudimentären,
basalen Emotionen umgehen lernen.
Aber das war ja jetzt auch gar nicht der Punkt von seinen Äußerungen.
Er wollte doch nur damit sagen, wenn man dort ist, dann merkt man,
man ist unter sich. Die sprechen, so wie man in Merseburg eben spricht und das sei so schön.
Ja, und daraus eine Schönheit abzuleiten.
Also das ist so ein enger Korridor, der es ihm ermöglicht, Schönheit zu erleben
und ich möchte genau diesen Korridor markieren, als das ist für mich genau das Abschreckende.
Ich will nicht nach Merseburg und dort thüringischen Slang hören,
der mir ein Brot aus der Hand nimmt, weil man auf der Bühne kack Musik singen muss.
Nein, aber wieso? Nein, das finde ich jetzt Quatsch. Also ich meine,
dass du das nicht hören willst, das ist so wie Pierre Bourdieu das beschreibt.
Und es gibt ja diese Dokumentation über ihn, Soziologie als Kampfplatz und dann
schnappt er irgendwo den Dialekt auf aus der Region, aus der er eigentlich kommt
und sagt, ich kann das nicht hören und geht dann weg.
Und das ist aber dein persönliches Problem. Aber hier geht es ja um was ganz anderes.
Hier will ja jemand sagen, hier sind die noch alle unter sich und konstituieren
sich als Bürger und sprechen ihre Sprache.
Da würde ich sagen, ja, das findet man aber, da die meisten Menschen in Deutschland
kein Hochdeutsch sprechen können, außer in Hannover vielleicht, an jeder Ecke und Kante.
Und ich würde hier ganz klar einwenden, in Koblenz beispielsweise gibt es laufend
solche Konzerte von semiprofessionellen Sängern oder Musikern,
die sich Abend für Abend oder paar Mal die Woche treffen,
diese Sachen einstudieren und dann das nicht kommerziell aufführen.
Und ja, die werden auch eher Kovalensa Platt sprechen als Hochdeutsch.
Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass die sagen, wir sind hier eine Gemeinschaft und
wir sind hier die Volksdeutschen, sondern die wollen mit diesem ganzen AfD Mist,
soweit ich das beurteilen kann, nicht zu tun haben.
Er sagt ja selbst so schön, die haben die Sänger eingekauft.
Ja klar, die Spitzenkräfte, die man dann braucht, um so ein Oratorium einzukaufen,
die sind nicht aus den eigenen Reihen rekrutiert, sondern dann braucht man Sänger
aus dem Umland oder dem Ausland.
Und ich sehe hier aber eigentlich jemanden, der ...
Nicht mehr am normalen bürgerlichen Leben teilnimmt.
Denn er stellt das als so etwas Besonderes heraus. Wir waren da in Merseburg
und dann gab es Mendelssohn-Oratorien.
Dabei ist das Deutschland aber normal. Also das ist eigentlich das,
was laufend stattfindet.
Jetzt hier die Kulturschiene, wir können das auf die Sportschiene auch ausbreiten
oder auch auf andere Bereiche.
Mal davon abgesehen, wie viel Engagement es gibt, zum Beispiel in der Flüchtlingshilfe
und so, wo auch im Dialekt gesprochen wird und sagt, nu jetzt machen wir mal
und dann hilft man den Leuten, die hier nach Deutschland angekommen sind.
Und dies ist ein ganz klares Zeichen dafür,
dass die AfD überhaupt nicht erkannt hat, dass es ein Bürgertum gibt,
das sich engagiert und es sind nicht alles nur bürgerliche, sondern auch andere
Leute engagieren sich ja.
Das nur überhaupt nichts mit AfD oder so zu tun haben will und sich nicht hier
sagt, oh, welche unglaubliche Identität hier in diesem tausend Jahre alten Dom,
sondern die singen gerne und singen gerne Mendelssohn.
Und wenn man ein bisschen was von Mendelssohn weiß, dann müsste man auch nochmal
merken, dass das vielleicht nicht der beste Kronzeuge für Nationalismus im Kubitschek'schen Sinne ist.
Aber gut, Also man sieht hier eigentlich, dass Sie ein Publikum adressieren,
das Sie aber gar nicht adressieren können.
Also ich will meinen Punkt noch mal nachschärfen. Auch auf die Gefahr hin,
dass ohne diese Nachschärfung einige Hörer das falsche Heimat bekommen haben.
Denn klar, es ist natürlich alles eingepreist. Er betont hier über eine Szenerie,
die er beschreibt, ein Heimatgefühl, ein Heimatgefühl.
Das ist ein Heimatgefühl, das er für sich reklamiert, das aber genauso gut ohne
AfD-Gedankengut existieren kann.
Manche Menschen fühlen sich wohl, wenn sie unter ihresgleichen sind.
Beziehungsweise treffen sich da und singen. Das ist deren Verbindung.
Man muss es nicht übertreiben. Ich hab rausgehört, was er im Umkehrschluss mir sagen wollte.
Das sieht er dann. Er sieht dort nicht Menschen, die gut Mendelssohn singen.
Es sind hier noch richtige Deutsche, die meine Sorge zwingen.
Genau, also ich höre da bei ihm so ein Ethnopluralismus, aber auf das Kleinste.
Die Meseburger Kirche und zwar zu einer bestimmten Veranstaltung.
Das ist sein Wohlfühlfokus.
Tausend Jahre alt.
Genau, und ich will nochmal markieren, für mich ist es genau der Umgedrehte.
Ja, du bist sehr liberaler Lebensentwurf. Du möchtest die Wurzeln kappen.
Genau, ich will gerade nicht in Thüringen in einer Kirche mit lauter Thüringern,
die mir thüringisches Lied gut singen.
Aber das ist ja völlig...
Warte, jetzt kommt der Punkt. Mir ging es nur darum, bei allen Diskussionen
zur AfD und wir dann immer mit diesem, ja, da fehlt halt noch ein bisschen Bildung,
man muss das aufklären, man kann es ja mal politisch diskutieren und so weiter und so fort.
Ich habe jetzt an diesem Statement von ihm gemerkt, Nee, wir sind hier auf so ner, also die...
Unterschiedlichkeit seiner und meiner Herangehensweise sind so rudimentär basal
irgendwo emotional verordnet jenseits jeder Anfänger von innerlicher Diskussion.
Wann orientiert man sich an Phänotypen? Das ist ja nicht die Frage oder an Biologie,
die hier die ganze Zeit aufgerufen wird. Das ist ja nicht die Frage,
eine Argumentation, die ich mir stelle, passt mir der Phänotyp?
Da würde man erst mal sagen, was ist das für eine verrückte Kategorie.
Aber für diese Leute mit dieser Weltsicht, ist das die entsprechende Kategorie
und die sehen nicht, sind gute Sänger oder Mendelssohn ist hier ein bisschen
schwierig interpretiert, sollte man vielleicht eher so und so machen.
Also es wird nicht mit dem Konzertkritiker-Blick drauf geschaut oder so oder
mit dem Blick des Connoisseurs,
sondern man blickt darauf, sehen die so aus wie ich, reden die so wie ich,
sind das so richtige Ostdeutsche oder sowas.
Und das ist eine völlige Verschiebung.
Dein Entwurf, um den jetzt, also ich will den nicht verdammen,
aber ich will den in dem Sinne rechtfertigen, Nämlich du verkörperst ja den
liberalen Lebensentwurf, zu dem auch gehört, dass man sich entscheiden kann.
Ich bin da geboren, da wird so gesprochen, das habe ich auch in den ersten paar
Jahren, als ich mich nicht wehren konnte, so noch aufsaugen müssen.
Aber jetzt habe ich damit nichts mehr zu tun.
Genauso wie wir jedem Zugestehen, der sagt, ja, ich bin so auf die Welt gekommen,
da hat man so am Anfang gesagt, das ist ein Junge, ich fühle mich nicht entsprechend.
Also nehme ich so eine Angleichung vor und bin jetzt das,
genauso wie wir auch jemandem zugestehen, der nach Deutschland kommt und der
sagt, ich habe mit meiner Vergangenheit nichts zu tun, ich bin jetzt hier,
ich arbeite hier, ich fühle mich wohl in Deutschland, fertig.
Und da muss man nicht nochmal dreimal nachfragen, ja, aber wo kommst du denn
wirklich her und wer bist du denn? Und wenn ich im Taxi sitze und da spricht
jemand Kölsch, aber ist nicht weiß, ist der dann Kölner?
Spielt keine Rolle mehr diese Frage, ja, all das, was so debattiert wurde.
Und das ist der liberale Lebensentwurf.
Ich glaube, bei dir ist die Abwehrbewegung sehr drastisch, dass die so sehr ins Auge fasst.
Aber jetzt für mich gesprochen, gut, ich kenne auch Orte meiner Kindheit,
da könnte man mich auch nur unter Gewaltandrohung wieder hinbringen.
Genau, für den Fall, dass die Thüringer zuhören. Ich habe damit keinen missionarischen
und zeithistorischen Entwicklungsgedanken.
Liebe Thüringer, ladet doch mal, Stefan hat ein Buch geschrieben,
ladet doch Stefan mal ein, so eine schöne Diskussion über Demografie und Ostdeutschland.
Ja, ich stehe zur Verfügung. Das ist wahrscheinlich die einzige Einladung,
wo ich dann sage, können wir das nicht remote machen?
Ja, ja, da musst du dann hin.
Aber dann bringe ich Geschichten mit. Ich 5 Stunden in Thüringen,
ich bringe Geschichten mit. Gefühlsgeschichten. Es werden alle weinen, die das hören.
Wir werden jetzt noch die ganz großen Fragen eröffnen, nämlich...
Es hat sich schon angedeutet, wenn bei den Liberalen keine Rückbindung da ist,
welche ist es dann bei den Rechten?
Dann kann man sich auf diese Jahrhunderte, Jahre von Erziehungsleistungen stützen
von Mola, was hier genannt wurde, oder den Phänotyp, die Identität, was auch immer.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch Gott. Und das ist für Ellen Kositzer ein großes
Thema. Ja, wir hören sie jetzt hier und das können wir schon gucken,
ob du das mit nach Thüringen bringst dann.
Ja, aber ich gebe zu bedenken, da gab es jetzt einen Artikel von Claudius Seidel,
ich weiß nicht, ob FAS oder FAZ, der hat im Netz auch ein bisschen für Häme gesorgt,
der ist durch die neuen Länder gefahren und hat konstatiert,
dass hier fast eine Kulturfeindlichkeit vorherrsche und der sagt,
es liegt auch daran, dass hier nicht mal geglaubt wird, dass diese fünf Länder
vom Christentum völlig abgeschnitten sind.
Und ich finde, da hat er einen Punkt. Also auch die Kulturfeindlichkeit bei
all unserem schönen Merseburg-Erlebnis, die ist mit Händen zu greifen.
Und die hat ja auch sympathische Seiten, die Kulturfeindlichkeit.
Aber es wurzelt sehr tief und es ist was sehr Trauriges.
Und ich bekenne, dass ich täglich für die Christianisierung von Ostdeutschland bete.
Darauf.
Okay.
Das lass mir einfach.
Ich hab jetzt leider diese Textgrundlage nicht. Ich hätte jetzt gerne Claudius
Seidels Text im Hinterkopf und könnte so ein bisschen.
Ja.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das einfach so ein. Also klar,
Claudius Seidel als Bayer und so.
Willst du uns wenigstens den Salon mitbringen, den Claudius Seidel Text.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
Du hast doch die FAZ hier. Das wäre doch schön, wenn du uns den Claudius Seidel
Text mitbringst, dass wir das nochmal gucken und auf uns den Gebet von Erlen
Kosezahn schließen müssen.
Einerseits ist es auf der Hand, dass da so ein Argument drin ist,
aber Claudia Seidel würde es ja nicht so platt schreiben, dass das so...
Naja, es ist ja nun mal so, dass die beiden Kirchen schon auch für die Kulturleistungen
mitverantwortlich sind,
die so erbracht werden, beziehungsweise bieten sie zum einen Gebäude an,
in denen man dann Mendelssohn-Oratorien aufführen kann.
Zum anderen beten sie natürlich auch durch die Kirchenmusik zum Beispiel unglaubliche
Außen-Ausbildungsstellen für Musiker an.
Also dass die Kirchen beide wichtig
sind für die Kulturlandschaft in Deutschland, ist nicht zu leugnen.
Das ist ganz entscheidend. Und da, wo der Glaube sehr rudimentär nur vorhanden
ist und wo die beiden Amtskirchen keine große Rolle spielen,
fehlt das selbstverständlich.
Wenn das nicht aufgefüllt wird durch etwas anderes und das ist ja nicht geschehen,
dann ist da auch ein Kulturdefizit da.
Das ist ja mal ein rein funktionales Argument. Das ist kein transzendentes Argument,
denn die meisten Leute, die in religiöse Konzerte gehen, haben gar keine besondere
Bindung zur Kirche oder zu Gott, vielleicht auch gar nicht.
Ich kenne viele Leute, die in Kirchenchören oder in solchen Chören singen,
die geistliche Werke aufführen, die entweder aus der Kirche ausgetreten sind
und oder überhaupt keinen Bezug zu Gott haben.
Aber meine Erfahrung sagt mir zum einen, ich mache mal zwei Punkte,
zum einen, jedes Mal wenn ich Schlaps und Schlumbo, der Traumzauberbaum und so weiter.
Westdeutsch aufgewachsene Menschen kennen das nicht aus ihrer Kindheit und sind
sprachlos darüber, mit was für geiler Kindermusik wir im Osten beschallt wurden.
Also durchgehende Erfahrung damit. Zweitens,
ich habe es damals nicht so reflektiert, aber ich komme aus Jena.
Ich habe so nah an der Kulturarena dran gewohnt, die da monatelang tobt,
jeden Sommer, dass ich Freikarten hatte für die Eröffnungstheaterspektakel, die da gemacht wurden.
Also ich kenne das in- und auswendig, das Theaterhaus Jena, eigentlich gar kein
richtiges Theater, weil nur noch die Bühne übrig blieb, das Gebäude selbst weggesprengt und so.
Hatte dieses Ensemble René Marek, Reinhard Grebe und so weiter da zu meiner
Schulzeit. Ich habe alles gesehen, was die gemacht haben.
Direkt vor den Toren der Stadt.
Institutionell prägend für ganz viele Theater im Übrigen auch für Westdeutschland.
Dieses große Festival. Ich war natürlich selten da, weil es ein bisschen Entfernung
und so, aber wir hatten Woodstage, kleine Rockkonzerte, Rammstein 96 da auf der Bühne und so weiter.
Ich habe das alles erlebt und das ist alles sehr viel Kultur,
sehr viel prägende Kultur.
Es hat genau gar nichts mit irgendwelchen christlichen Hinterlassenschaften.
Ah ja, wir können ja mal die Kirche umwidmen und als Veranstaltungsrahmen,
sei es so oder eben wirklich christliche Prägung und so.
Also ich Ich bin nicht jetzt kulturell depriviert aufgewachsen und sehr viele
andere Menschen da auch nicht. Ja, ja.
Und Dresden und Leipzig sind nun ideale Orte, um Bach und Co. zu hören.
Ich kann mir sehr vorstellen, dass man, wenn man heute, deswegen ja auch meine
Trauerei, wenn ich eben nicht nach Jena fahre, sondern durch die Ländereien,
dass man in den Dörfern nichts mehr vorfindet. Ja, das stimmt.
Also wenn Claudius Seidel jetzt eine Tour durch den Osten macht und dann irgendwie
feststellt, hier ist ja nichts.
Ich würde sagen, der Schluss mit irgendwas ist mit den Kirchen,
ist ein bisschen zu voreilig, denn da ist glaube ich so mehr Treuhand, so in die Richtung.
Ja, wir sehen uns den Text an. Ich glaube jedoch, dass gerade so auf diesen
Dörfern das kulturelle Leben durch die Kirchen, also durch Kirchenchöre oder
Orgelmusik schon noch in anderer Weise da war.
Das schwindet natürlich auch im Westen
zunehmend, aber da, wo es gar nicht ausgeprägt war, ist es sowieso so.
Aber überhaupt, dass hier die Musik herangeführt wird, also Mendelssohn,
klar, sowieso schon lachhaft, aber auch die Musik als solches.
Also ich habe jetzt eigentlich den August nicht mit Urlaub verbracht,
aber ich habe mir doch sehr viele Konzerte angesehen. Zum Beispiel Hilary Hahn
war in Wiesbaden im Kurhaus zu Gast.
Dann Kent Nagano hat Rheingold dirigiert, übrigens mit einem Dresdner Orchester.
Und wenn man natürlich sieht, wer da eigentlich zusammenkommt,
wer Musik macht, was das für unglaubliche Geschichten sind. Es ist...
So international, also jedes Programm eines Musikfestivals,
ich rede jetzt nur von der klassischen Musik, da kann ich es beurteilen,
ist eine Ohrfeige ins Gesicht der AfD,
weil die sagen, hier spielt ein Skandinavier, der beste Bach-Interpret kommt
gerade hier aus Ostafrika und der spielt mit einem Israeli zusammen,
die auf historischen Instrumenten, die in Dresden gebaut wurden,
Also es geht nur so, es kommt alles die ganze Zeit vermischt und man trifft
sich aber nicht über irgendeine Identität, Phänotypen etc., sondern über die Musik.
Und das ist so interessant zu erleben und deswegen, ja, da sieht man aber auch,
dass man doch auch sehr isoliert lebt.
Also wenn die Kubischeks mal noch in anderen Konzerte gehen würden,
wenn die mal schauen Wer gibt denn eigentlich so regelmäßig Konzerte im Gewandhaus beispielsweise?
Dann werden sie auch mal auf andere Phänotypen treffen und werden erleben,
dass auch die ganz gut in der Mendelssohn-Interpretation sind.
Wir kennen junge Menschen, die einfach gerne in Leipzig leben.
Wundern uns darüber, aber es ist wie es ist.
Du wunderst dich darüber. Das muss ich jetzt rausnehmen.
Ich habe Leipzig jetzt tolle Aufführungen immer mal erlebt, wenn ich da war.
Ich werde das auch weiter verfolgen.
Weiter verfolgen.
Jetzt kommen wir zum letzten Clip, denn es muss ja noch eine Antwort folgen
auf Kosizzas Christianisierungsidee des Ostens, Krah sagt.
Wir haben da ein großes Defizit und wir werden ran müssen. Vielleicht auch aus
einem Grund. Wir gehen in harte Zeiten. Wir werden das nicht verändern können.
Was uns droht sind Fragmentarisierung, staatlicher Kontrollverlust,
eine eine Infragestellung und Korruption aller Institutionen,
die wir für selbstverständlich halten.
Was wird bleiben? Es wird das bleiben, was letztlich archaisch natürlich ist.
Es bleibt die Familie, es bleibt nicht das Individuum, es bleibt die Familie
und es bleibt der Glaube.
Und in einer Zeit, wo es kein Glauben mehr gibt, wird es für diejenigen zum
Nachteil werden. Insofern ist es eine Überlebensstrategie, wenn wir tatsächlich
auch denjenigen, die noch überhaupt Glauben verkörpern können,
die noch nicht glauben können, dass sie
den Weg und die Türen öffnen.
Da sind wir mal gespannt, ob die AfD dieses Thema aufgreift.
Ich weiß, dass Andreas Kemper immer mal wieder auf so ultra-katholische Seilschaften
in der AfD verwies, die aber doch relativ gering sind.
Von Storch ist natürlich eine Vertreterin und Krah jetzt auch,
aber inwieweit man damit nochmal irgendeinen Blumentopf gewinnen will.
Und es ist interessant, dass die Kubitscheks eigentlich hier Krah so ein bisschen
herausfordern, Sie sagen, du kämpfst nicht so richtig für den Glauben,
was du ja eigentlich als guter Katholik tun müsstest.
Aber er muss natürlich Parteistratege bleiben. Und jetzt hat er die Libertären,
wenn er denen jetzt auch noch mit dem lieben Gott ankommt, dann ist es aber ganz aus.
Also das ist ganz interessant, dass es hier noch mal auftaucht,
was in der Logik der Sache eigentlich liegt. Also wenn man sich so sehr abarbeitet
am Islam, das ist ja das große Thema der AfD.
Man aber selbst da nichts anzubieten hat und aber auch die Kirchen von einem
ja nichts wissen wollen. Also man wird jetzt nicht wieder AfD-Bischöfe oder so stünden.
Dann hat man Probleme und er sagt dann auch an einer Stelle,
ja der Kardinal Marx und der Papst Franziskus, die sind ja beide gleich schlimm.
In seinem Buch bezieht er sich dann als Vorbild auf Edmund Burke.
Das ist dieser ganz konservative, ich glaube der auch Impfgegner,
der mit der der Kappa Magna immer rumläuft.
Der so 15 Meter Schleppe hinter sich hat und hat dann immer so junge Männer, die ihm die tragen.
Also das ist so dieses vorkonziliarische Katholische, was er haben möchte.
Naja, ich wünsche ihm nicht viel Erfolg damit, aber ich beobachte das mit einem gewissen Amüsement.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen schade, dass es halt immer gleich so Menschenhasser
sein müssen, weil man deswegen nicht so unvoreingenommen auch mal amüsiert an
deren Quatsch herantreten kann.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wir greifen das im Salon nochmal auf mit seinem Buch.
Haben das jetzt gut versucht. Okay, ich habe gesehen, du hast Olaf Scholz Clips.
Die wollte ich uns nicht vorenthalten.
Ja, also dann pass auf, ich habe eigentlich noch einen großen Brocken,
aber das schaffen wir heute nicht. Das müssen wir uns aufhören.
Aber ich will mal das so machen. Also es sind zwei Scholz Clips.
Er war zu Gast im Hotel Matze. Ich wollte es mir eigentlich nicht anhören,
dann habe ich mir aber doch in dreifache Geschwindigkeit reingezogen.
Sehr gut. Glaubst du, du hast was verpasst wegen dreifacher Geschwindigkeit?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Ich hätte auch nichts verpasst, wenn ich es mir gar nicht
angehört hätte. Aber doch zwei Clips wollte ich bringen.
Wir hatten jetzt eben schon die etablierten Medien, also die öffentlich-rechtlichen
kritisiert, dass sie die ganze Zeit so gucken haben, wie geht es euch denn?
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
Hotel Matze macht nichts anderes in seinem Podcast, als die Gelegenheit nutzen
nochmal nachzufragen, wie gehts euch?
Ja es ist ein bisschen so, also ich hätte jetzt nur mal kurz hingeleitet wieder
zur deutschen Politik, wir können ja gleich mal gucken zeitlich,
können wir nochmal über die Chips reden?
Nur die zwei Clips von Olaf Scholz, die können wir spielen.
Okay, dann binden wir die mal zusammen mit Olaf Scholz und seiner besten Freundin Clara Gajwicz.
Oh ja.
Clara Geiwitz war auf Mission. Sie ist Bauministerin.
Wo könnte man hinfahren? Wir kriegen das eingebunden in so eine Moderation im
Heute-Journal am 15. August. Es geht um Plattenbau, recht unverfänglich.
Die Platte kommt zurück. Im Westen als sozialistischer Einheitsbau verhöhnt,
stand sie in Ostdeutschland zunächst für Fortschritt, immerhin mit Zentralheizung
und fließend warmem Wasser.
Schon damals in den 70er Jahren war der Plattenbau das Rezept der DDR gegen Wohnungsnot.
Vorgefertigte Bauteile in Massenproduktion, zack, steht das Neubauviertel.
So, wir bauen aber so aktuell nicht. Wir verabschieden gerade mal so ein bisschen
das freistehende Einfamilienhaus.
Die Klimasünde schlechthin, wirklich Faktor 8, 9, Unterschieden von diesen,
naja, sagen wir mal fünf, sechs stückwägigen, nicht ganz Plattenbau,
sondern aber schon ein bisschen auf Höhe, ein bisschen auf enge und vor allem
klimatechnisch so auf passiv ausgelegt und so weiter und so fort.
Und im Rahmen dieser Berichterstattung.
Lass mich nur gerade einen Punkt bringen, man kann das Bild jetzt nicht sehen,
aber man kann sich vorstellen, wie dieser Plattenbau jetzt gerade aussieht,
der hier uns hier eingeblendet wird und man hat das dann auch noch in schwarz-weiß
uns eingeblendet, damit es noch ein bisschen grauer wirkt, als es ist.
Ich will nur mal zu bedenken geben, viele hören jetzt hier zu und die leben
irgendwo auf dem Land und da gibt es sowas gar nicht und dann ist eher ein-Familienhaus,
zwei-Familienhaus, Doppelhaushälfte, solche Konzepte sind da.
Und das hat ja auch da erst mal seine Berechtigung, sondern oder sagen wir,
es ist auch eine ganz große organisatorische Leistung, wenn man dort jetzt ein anderes bauen will.
Aber wir reden ja hier erst mal von Städten, wo das stattfinden soll oder den
mehr urbanen Raum, wo das passieren soll, wo das dringend nötig ist.
Und ich bitte doch mal darauf zu achten, wenn man demnächst durch irgendeine
Stadt geht, mal zu gucken, wie sehen vier- und fünf-Sterne-Hotels von außen aus?
Die sehen ziemlich genau so aus wie ein Plattenbau, die haben dann noch einen
etwas pompösen Eingang vielleicht. Aber wenn es sich nicht um ein Traditions
Grand Hotel handelt, dann sehen luxuriöse Hotels so aus. Das heißt...
Überhaupt sollte man mal darauf achten, wie sehen eigentlich die Städte so aus,
weil immer gesagt wird ja der Plattenbau.
Naja, sind die anderen Gebäude, die so gebaut werden so toll?
Ich bin kürzlich, will jetzt auch nicht die Kölner beleidigen,
aber ich war in einem Hotel in Köln, bin in den Aufzug gefahren,
konnte dann so auf den Dom rüber blicken und konnte aber auch so gucken,
wie die Kölner Häuser da so alle aussehen, dass da jetzt keine Platten bauten.
Aber schön, liebe Freunde, ist das auch nicht.
Ich glaube, in diesem Hotel war ich auch.
Deswegen sollten wir uns nochmal diesem Plattenbau-Thema ganz neu widmen.
Und für wie viele Leute ist es auch einfach wichtig, funktional und sinnvoll
zu wohnen. Und wenn Sie jetzt hier sagen, fließend Wasser, Heizung,
das war aber damals schon was.
Und dann kann man ja sagen, womit müsste man heute noch den Plattenbau ausstatten?
Das ist aber auch etwas, vielleicht mit einer internen Kinderbetreuung,
mit einer Gemeinschaftsküche, wo es auch so was gäbe, dass nicht jeder im eigenen
Topf herumrühren muss, wenn man zum Beispiel als Single lebt,
sondern wo man schon mehr eine Gemeinschaft haben könnte.
Also ich sehe da eigentlich ein wahnsinniges Potenzial. Mega.
Es ist mega das Potenzial für die Frage, was ist eine hässliche Stadt?
Wir haben Köln jetzt gesehen, ist natürlich schon erschreckend.
Die Tagesthemen waren mit ihr mittendrin.
Die Kölner lieben Köln schon sehr.
Ja, Köln ist ja auch toll. Also Ästhetik ist zweitrangig. Hier in Frankfurt
lege ich Wert darauf, dass es auch schön aussieht.
Aber woanders, ich weiß, nur in Frankfurt ist schön. Ich bin ja nur zu Gast dort.
In den Tagesthemen haben sie eine Mittendrin-Reportage aus Ludwigshafen gebracht.
Dort wird eine, die hässliche, also der Ugly City oder so Stadtführung gemacht.
Das ist so grotesk. Ich werde es mit Hans und Tilo gucken. Man glaubt es nicht.
Erstens, wie hässlich eine Stadt sein kann und zweitens, wie eine Stadtrundführung
da aussieht und dann noch der Journalismus dazu. Also da kann man sich auf einiges
gefasst machen. Die Maßstäbe für hässlich haben wir noch nicht.
Wir haben ein sehr gutes Kunstmuseum in Ludwigshafen.
Das kann sein.
Plattenbauten haben es in sich. Plattenbauten können aber auch von der Konzeption
her recht einfach sein. Das ist ja auch ihr Prinzip.
Clara Geiwitz war in Tokio.
Anfang Juli war die Bauministerin in Tokio. Serieller Wohnungsbau hat in Japan Tradition.
Clara Geiwitz ist gekommen, um zu schauen, was hier möglich ist.
Und in Deutschland eben nicht. Und in Deutschland eben nicht.
Zehn Fertighäuser am Tag kann Japans größter Hersteller bauen.
Klimaschonend und modern. Einer der Sachen, die in Japan klappen,
ist, dass man das ohne Baugenehmigung machen kann.
Innerhalb von drei Monaten, wenn das Haus fertig produziert ist,
kann es auch aufgestellt werden. Solche Formen von Typengenehmigungen wollen
wir auch gerne in Deutschland unterstützen.
Das Herstellen ist das eine, der Genehmigungsprozess in Deutschland ist das
andere. Also warum gibt's das nicht? Keine Ahnung. Das hätte man ja auch.
Also dafür fährt man eigentlich nicht nach Japan.
Tokio ist eine Stadt, ich kann es nur grob jetzt sowieso aus Zeitgründen,
aber guckt euch diese Arte Dokus an, die es da gerade gibt,
wie diese größte Stadt der Welt mit den höchsten Grundstückspreisen der Welt,
im ältesten Land der Welt es noch hinbekommt, Innovationen wirklich auf die Spitze zu treiben.
Es gibt in Tokio kein richtiges Stadtzentrum. Es gibt zwar diesen riesigen,
das Anwesen des Kaisers und so.
Ansonsten ist das, man kann es gar nicht beschreiben. Es ist so future.
Es ist so jenseits von allem. Es ist jeder Quadratmeter genutzt.
Es ist nicht nur auf, muss ausgebeutet werden, sondern hier wird einfach konzeptionell und so weiter.
Die Politik hat einen Daumen drauf. Es gibt hundert verschiedene Stadtzentren,
man fährt eine Straße weiter, man ist in einer anderen Welt,
man kann eigentlich nicht nach Tokio fahren und dort über deutsche Baugenehmigung reden,
sondern in dem Moment muss man sagen, ich habe hier gerade ein anderes Thema,
so irgendwie, dann sucht man sich eins der hundert Themen raus aus dieser absolut
faszinierenden Stadt, die eigentlich
schon ein kleines landwendig ein Kontinent ist. Sie kommt wieder?
Und eine Woche später, das war am 15., am 21.08.
Sagt sie das hier in den Tagesthemen zum Thema ... Ich hab zwar in Tokio einiges
gesehen, ich war letzte Woche da, aber jetzt in Deutschland ...
Sie wissen ja, wir bauen nur 135.000 Häuser gerade, obwohl wir 400.000 Wohnungen
bauen wollten und so. Klappt alles nicht. Das sind meine Vorschläge.
Die Krise im Wohnungsbau in Deutschland setzt sich fort. Denn nach Angaben des
IFO-Instituts gibt es in der Baubranche starken Rückgang von Aufträgen.
Bundesbauministerin Geiwitz kündigte ein baldiges Hilfspaket für die Branche an.
Um Bauen günstiger zu machen, stellt
sie auch die geplanten höheren Klimastandards für Neubauten in Frage.
Laut Koalitionsvertrag sollen diese ab 2025 gelten.
Es ist nicht auszuhalten.
Ein Strohfeuerkonjunkturprogramm und die Abkehr von Klimaschutzprinzipien.
Wo wir wissen, wie wichtig. Wir haben es in diesen Klimakonferenzen auch zu Genüge gehört.
Wir haben als Bürgermeister international gehört bei dieser beiden Konferenzen,
die reingeberufen haben, wie wichtig der Einsparbereich ist,
den man im Immobiliensektor erreichen kann.
Und es ist auch so verrückt, ich meine sie hat doch auch die Zahlen.
Wenn man heute das Rheinhaus errichten will und wahrscheinlich muss man dann
schon über ein Grundstück verfügen, dann ist das selbst auf dem Land,
ist man da mal eine halbe Million locker angekommen.
Dann hat man eine Zinslast von vier Prozent im Monat. Das heißt,
man hat ein, weiß nicht wie viel Eigenkapital, da haben Leute dann 100.000,
ne rein 400.000, das müssen sie abzahlen.
Dann sind sie da ja ganz schnell bei 2.800, 3.000 Euro. Und da soll das denen
jetzt was bringen, wenn die 20.000,
Euro sparen können, wenn da irgendwas an Klimaschutzmaßnahmen wegfällt,
von denen sie ja auch am Ende profitieren würden, wenn ein Haus besser isoliert ist oder oder.
Eine solche Augenwischerei, dass man sich überhaupt wagt, so etwas zu sagen,
wo wir ja überall die Klimakatastrophe vor Augen haben, man kann nur noch schreien.
Also angesichts Zinswende und so weiter, wir haben ja gerade eine Bautätigkeit,
eigentlich müssten wir ja jetzt öffentlich bauen. Ja.
So dieses private Bauen und dann nochmal konjunkturell mit Programmen da irgendwie
unter die Arme und so weiter, das ist ja alles Quatsch.
Die Baubranche, ich habe das ja da im Februar in Berlin erlebt,
die steht ja vor einem Trümmerhaufen, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Die wissen jetzt, okay, wir haben noch ein Jahr diesen Bauüberhang,
der ist jetzt auch schon ein halbes Jahr rum, danach sind unsere Aufträge flöten.
Niemand gibt gerade irgendwas in Auftrag, niemand kann irgendwas finanzieren
und so weiter, das liegt alles da nieder. Wir wissen, dass auf den Baustellen
ausschließlich nicht deutsch sprechende, nicht hier verankerte Tagelöhner sozusagen arbeiten.
Entlassen sind. Wenn die innerhalb von zwei Wochen nicht den nächsten Anschlussverwendungsauftrag
als Gewerk so bekommen, sind die weg. Die Baubranche zittert.
Also sie zittert wirklich. Ich habe sie zitternd auf der Bühne gesehen.
Sie haben Angst vor diesem Gastro-Effekt.
Einmal kurz gesagt, leider keine Aufträge mehr. Die Leute sind weg in alle Himmelsrichtungen.
Die kriegen die nicht wieder, wenn es dann ein Jahr später wieder losgeht.
So. Hier jetzt irgendwie so ein, ja da machen wir mal ein Konjunkturprogramm
und so weiter. Völlig falsch.
Der steht der Bauimmobilienweise auf der Bühne und sagt, eigentlich bräuchten
wir mal eine Halbierung der Grundstückspreise.
Wo du denkst, eine Halbierung der Grundstückspreise?
Wir haben 80 Großstädte in Deutschland, in jeder einzelnen davon reden wir hier
von mindestens zweifachen Milliardenbeträgen, die einfach mal gestrichen werden aus den Büchern.
Damit danach wieder eine wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit auf etwas.
Gedämmten Niveau beginnen kann. Und sie kommt ja einfach mit.
Und das inklusive diesem Eindruck aus Tokio noch.
Also als würde auch jemand daraus einen Anreiz jetzt hinaus machen.
Oh Gott sei Dank, die Umweltauflage ist weggefallen. Jetzt baue ich aber mal schnell ein Haus.
Es ist so grotesk. Es ist wirklich ganz traurig. Und damit sind wir bei Olaf Scholz.
Ja, was könnte man Olaf Scholz fragen? Wie würde man mit ihm ein Gespräch führen?
Ich würde sagen nicht so wie Matze Hielscher das tut. Ich habe nur zwei Clips mitgebracht.
Wir müssen einen Eindruck davon bekommen und ich möchte Politiker nicht mehr als Menschen erleben.
Musst du irgendwas wissen vor dem Gespräch? Ne. Das ist gut.
Ich fange mal an mit einer leichten Frage, aber sie ist ernst gemeint.
Wie geht es dir? Mir geht es gut.
Obwohl es für mich ja nicht anders ist, als für viele andere in unserem Land.
Ich bin bedrückt von dem russischen Krieg gegen die Ukraine,
der in unserer unmildbarsten Nachbarschaft stattfindet und jeden Tag bittere Realität ist.
Würdest du sagen, wenn es dir persönlich nicht gut gehen würde,
würdest du dann sagen, mir geht es persönlich nicht so gut? Also trennst du das so sehr?
Ich würde das sagen können. Ja. Aber man muss dann natürlich immer überlegen,
wie das ausgewertet wird. Aber trotzdem, wenn man schlechte Laune hat,
schlechte Laune hat, sollte man nicht dünnen.
Gegenteiligen Eindruck zu erwecken suchen es wird sowieso jeder merken. Ja wahrscheinlich.
Also man hat den Kanzler zu Gast.
Naja, man will ihn jetzt mal knacken.
Das besprechen wir, naja es ist doch eigentlich die Verwarnungsweise,
die wir jetzt bei den Tagesthemen und im Heute-Journal gesehen haben.
Wie geht es der Koalition? Und dann kann man doch noch gleich fragen, wie geht es dir?
Wie geht es dem Papa der Familie?
Ja, dem geht es gut. Auch wenn wir hier einen Krieg haben.
Ja, ich meine wie damals LeFloid, als er Merkel zu Gast hatte und so,
das ist jedes Mal dasselbe.
Aber deshalb kommt er natürlich gerne in diese Säule.
Ja, absolut.
Ich meine, das macht man mit Vorliebe.
Ich meine, der Matze will immer diese negativen, psychologischen,
wo ich mir auch denke, bei den Hälften der Gespräche, merkt ihr nicht,
dass es euch einfach vorspielt?
So, dass ihr einfach jetzt nur noch Worte aneinander reiht, damit es irgendwie
so eine Geschichte ergibt.
Wenn man weiß, man hat den Kanzler nur eine Stunde zu Gast, braucht man es gar
nicht versuchen tief zu graben.
Vor allem nicht mit dieser Einstiegsfrage, wie geht es denn eigentlich,
ich meine das echt ernst. Ja was denn sonst, Matze, du meinst das nicht ernst
oder was? Was ist denn das schon für eine Explizierung des absolut Selbstverständlichen
den Kanzler da zu haben und ich meine es nicht ernst, aber wie geht es?
Also es ist völlig grotesk.
Wir hören uns noch den zweiten Clip an.
Ich würde gerne mit dir heute ein bisschen über Kompromisse sprechen wollen.
Fangen wir mal mit der Definition an, was ist für dich ein guter Kompromiss? BK'IN DR.
GESCHWENSTEIN Fast jeder Kompromiss ist ein guter Kompromiss,
weil er zu unserem Leben dazugehört.
Wir können uns nicht immer alleine durchsetzen, nicht alles kann nach unserem Kopf gehen.
Das ist im privaten Lebensumfeld so. Ich habe das vor einiger Zeit mal so formuliert,
wenn eine Familie darüber redet, wo man in Urlaub hinfahren soll und einer sagt
immer mal Jorka, keine Kompromisse, dann ist das das ist für den Rest der Familie
nicht so schön und so ist es ja auch.
Im öffentlichen Leben und in der Politik Kompromisse gehören dazu und sie sind nichts schlechtes.
Was hätte er sonst sagen sollen?
Aber da muss es doch wirklich sein, dann hört man doch noch lieber Maximilian Krah zu, oder?
Also das ist ja gar nichts mehr. Ich finde auch schön, dass er das nochmal in
der Formulierung offenbar aufgreift, die er schon mal gemacht hat.
Also dass er dachte, das war so eine geile Analogie. Da versuche ich das gleich
nochmal zu bringen mit dem Urlaub und der Familie.
Ich bin entrüstet darüber, dass solche Gespräche stattfinden.
Ich finde es tragisch, dass wir einen Kanzler haben, der dann auch so darauf antwortet.
Ich finde, man muss eigentlich dann sofort in so einen Spaßmodus umschalten
und darauf entsprechend reagieren. Es ist ein Jammer.
Und ich möchte hier nochmal ganz deutlich betonen, mich interessiert nicht,
wie es Politikern persönlich geht.
Mich interessiert nur bei engen Familienmitgliedern und Freunden,
wie es ihnen persönlich geht.
Ansonsten gilt die Devise von Marlene Dietrich, ich gehe mich einen Dreck an.
Ja, sich selbst nicht so wichtig nehme, sich rausnehmen aus der Gleichung,
wenn man in einer Funktion agiert.
Und ich hasse solche Interviews und sie werden überall laufend geführt.
Es ist etwas, womit man die Politik entpolitisiert und eigentlich so eine Öffentlichkeit schafft,
die nur noch in einem Boulevardmodus eigentlich gucken kann,
wie geht's wem heute, wer hat sich gestritten, was ist wieder los,
wen das interessiert, der hat die entsprechenden Angebote, zum Beispiel bei
RTL, Sommerhaus der Stars, Dschungelcamp etc.
Kann man alles gerne konsumieren, aber bitte nicht im Bereich des politischen.
Ja, ich meine, wir alle spielen Theater. Wir kriegen auf diese Frage eine Antwort,
die wir nur erfüllen können. Welche Wortwahl dann und so weiter.
Wir sehen Olaf Scholz in dem Rahmen nicht.
Wir kennen ihn nicht, wir sind auf die Antworten nicht vorbereitet.
Wir kennen doch alle aus eigener Erfahrung, es ist ganz egal,
wie es einem geht, in der Öffentlichkeit schafft man es zu performen.
Das gilt insbesondere für so einen, das ist im Grunde die Jobbeschreibung des Kanzlers.
Ihn muss man auch nicht fragen, wie es Ihnen geht.
Diese Frage ist nur einleitend nochmal für Menschen, die gar keine Ahnung vom
Politikbetrieb haben, um ihnen noch ein bisschen besser zu suggerieren,
dass man es hier jetzt mal mit dem Menschen zu tun hat.
Oder würde ich sagen, ja, dann komm doch gleich zum Punkt, du hast ihn ja immerhin
eine Stunde und nicht nur, keine Ahnung, zehn Sekunden lang in den Tagesthemen
oder sowas, wo man ihn dann sieht.
Aber der Mensch hinter Olaf Scholz, ja, also dann würde ich sagen,
lade Anne Spiegel ein und führ mit ihr ein politisches Gespräch.
Sie ist aus diesem Posten rausgeflogen, weil sie sich für ihre Familie entschieden
hat, weil wir es auch nicht zugelassen haben, dass sie sagt,
mir macht mein Job so viel Spaß,
ich kann mich leider nicht um meinen schlaganfallgeplagten Mann kümmern.
Das sind ja immer die Fragestellungen, ja, um dann mal.
Ich verstehe diese Art der Personality-Gespräche ohnehin nicht,
aber vielleicht auch, weil ich einfach, also mich interessieren halt Leute in
meinem privaten Umfeld,
aber mich interessieren nicht die Gefühligkeiten von irgendwelchen Stars,
die jetzt immer glauben, dass sie jede CD damit verkaufen müssen,
dass sie mir noch irgendwie eine emotionale Tatsache an den Kopf knallen.
Ganz kurz noch meine Frage, freust du dich aufs aktuelle Sportstudio?
Weißt du, wer da kommt? Unser Freund, wir haben ja sein Buch besprochen im Salon, Prinz Harry kommt.
Er veranstaltet ja diese Invictus Games, haben wir ja erfahren,
der Autobiografie ist ihm ganz wichtig.
Und er ist dann in Düsseldorf zur Spieleröffnung und wird dann,
weil die Terminlichte es nicht anders zulässt, mit der Luftwaffe nach Mainz
katapultiert ins aktuelle Sportstudio.
Und dort tritt er dann auf. Also wir können da sehr gespannt sein.
Frage noch, wird Megan ihn begleiten?
Das ist einfach der Wahnsinn, oder?
Das ist so schräg.
Aber vielleicht hast du da dann ein paar schöne Clips für den Fernsehpodcast.
Und dann wollte ich dich noch einen Begriff fragen, weil wir ja in den neuen
20ern, wir müssen ja den Zeitgeist abbilden.
Kennst du den Begriff Millennial-Pause? Weißt du, was das ist?
Nö.
Millennial-Pause, nö?
Millennial-Pause.
Was könnte die Millennial-Pause sein? Und zwar?
Sich kurz aus seinem Lebensstil verabschieden und in den Menokorps einsteigen.
Es ist wirklich ziemlich gut. Und zwar, die Millennial-Pause ist in den sozialen
Medien, oder wenn man eine Sprachnachricht schickt oder mit der Webcam kommuniziert ist.
Wenn Millennials das machen, also wenn die beispielsweise einen TikTok aufnehmen
oder so, dann gucken die so eine Millisekunde, ist die Kamera an oder ist die Aufnahme an?
Das ist so ganz kurz, ah ja klappt, also das ist die Millennial-Pause. Und die Gen Z.
Ist schon so damit aufgewachsen, also sie braucht nicht mehr dieses funktioniert es auch,
natürlich funktioniert es auch, man drückt und redet los, man sendet,
man muss nicht mehr gucken, ah ist der Stream an, das ist die Millennial Pause.
Es ist ein gängiger Begriff und darüber wird es jetzt so sehr gemacht.
Also man hat ja eine Zeit lang immer irgendwie so gezeigt, welche Memes Boomer
sich in WhatsApp Kuppen oder so hinschickt.
Aber auch hier gibt es die Distinktion, auch die Millennials,
die natürlich glauben, sie seien so ganz up to date, sind es auch nicht,
weil sie doch noch nicht so ganz der Technik vertrauen oder es noch so als kleines
Wunderwerk, oh es läuft tatsächlich, betrachten.
Und dann machen sie diese ganz kleine Pause und die Gen Z sendet einfach sofort drauf los.
Das ist eine sehr gute Beobachtung, weil man sie gut fühlen kann.
Ich weiß nicht genau, ob es am Ende wirklich so stimmt.
Ja, kann ja jeder sich mal selbst befragen, wer macht die Millennial-Pause oder
gibt es auch Gen Z Leute, die die Millennial-Pause machen?
Also wenn ich meine 13-Jährige sehe, wie sie einfach grundsätzlich auf Sendung ist.
Ja, sie macht keine Millennial-Pause.
Ins Zimmer und muss erst mal gucken, läuft hier irgendwo ein Telefonat?
Ja, da läuft dann irgendwo ein Telefonat. Das Handy liegt zwar oben auf dem
Schrank und so weiter, aber es läuft gerade ein Telefonat. Also da muss man sehr drauf aufpassen.
Vielleicht ist die Millennial Pause auch die Parent Pause, dass man noch mal
ganz kurz sich vergewissert, was es hier gerade sagt. Dann sind wir unter uns.
Weil am Ende fängt man noch an, irgendwas zu reden und dann,
sorry, aber hier sind zehn Leute im Raum, ohne dass man es gesehen hat. Okay, sehr gut.
Dann vertagen wir uns mit diesen Wir weisen noch einmal darauf hin,
im Salon lesen wir, was wir der Zukunft schulden, warum wir jetzt darüber entscheiden,
ob wir die nächste Million Jahre positiv beeinflussen.
Da geht es um ganz, ganz große Perspektiven. William MacAskill hat dieses Buch
geschrieben, bei Siedler ist es erschienen. Das ist das Buch,
das wir gemeinsam lesen, besprechen, diskutieren.
Ich werde dann noch mich mit dem Buch von Maximilian Krah beschäftigen.
Es ist tatsächlich interessant mal zu schauen, was wird da wirtschaftspolitisch
und zu Europa gesagt und gedacht. aber das nicht zum zum Nachkaufen.
Was ich auch lesen möchte, ist das Buch Materialfluss von Monika Dommann.
Sie hat ein Buch geschrieben über die Geschichte der Logistik.
Das ist jetzt bei Fischer erschienen. Wir haben viel über Lieferketten gesprochen
und deshalb finde ich das sehr sehr interessant.
Hier heißt es, ohne Logistik wäre unser alltägliches Leben unmöglich,
wie die Auswirkungen der Corona-Pandemie und des zu Ukrainekriegs gezeigt haben,
wird sie jedoch meist erst dann wahrgenommen, wenn der Materialfluss zum Erliegen
kommt, ausgehend von solchen Situationen, in denen scheinbar nichts mehr fließt,
schreibt Monika Duhrmann in ihrer Wegweisend-Studie die oft verborgene,
immer auch politische Geschichte der Logistik.
Was ich sonst noch besprechen werde, halte ich offen, ich habe schon ein paar
gute Ideen, aber mal sehen.
Sehr gut. Ich bin immer noch im Urlaubsmodus, ich habe auch im Urlaub nicht viel gelesen.
Diesmal werde ich also spontan zusammensammeln, allerdings jetzt seit drei Tagen nehme ich wiederhaben.
Politischen Diskurs teil. Das heißt, er rauscht so durch meinen Kopf.
Und dieses Weltwochending, dass sie dieses Gespräch zwischen Trump und Tucker
Carlson übersetzt haben. Einfach selten was amüsanteres gelesen,
wenn auch nur in Screenshotausschnitten über Nigel Mayers Twitter.
Aber vielleicht ist sowas ja nicht verkehrt, um aus dem Sommer raus zu steigen.
Und was Seidl uns über die Religion im Osten sagt.
Das interessiert mich jetzt natürlich insbesondere. Religion und Osten sind ja genau meine Themen.
Dann sag uns noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen.
Ihr geht auf neue20er.de und folgt dem goldenen Button. Der fühlt zu steady.
Der fühlt zu Steady, ihr seid dann auf der Steady Seite.
Genau, wenn ihr auf unserer Seite seid, da ist ja nichts eingebunden.
Ihr seid sozusagen datenschutzrechtlich nicht mal ein Cookie oder so.
Es ist einfach nur, ihr könnt ganz frei dann einfach den Klick zu Steady machen.
Dann allerdings geht's da weiter, wenn ihr uns folgt mit AGBs und so weiter, Zahlungsverkehr.
Aber da kann man sich ja das Paket dann aussuchen.
Also in der Regel klappt es immer. Jetzt hat ein Bekannter aus Berlin geschrieben,
er sei gescheitert dabei den Salon zu abonnieren.
Ich weiß nicht woran es liegt. Es kann eigentlich nicht an uns liegen.
Wir haben die Woche nochmal mit Steddy jetzt telefoniert. Ich hab mich mal wieder bedankt.
Es funktioniert eigentlich immer, ansonsten kann man sich vielleicht Steddy
melden und man kann Steddy auch dann, wenn man den Podcast eh über Spotify hört,
über Spotify erreichen.
Apple bietet das auch ganz einfach an für die Apple Kunden und wer bei Patreon
ist, weiß auch wie das geht.
Wir sehen uns im Salon für die Bücher und dann noch im Live Salon dann mit einem
bunten, unterhaltsamen Strauß, wie wir hoffen.
Und sonst wünschen wir einen guten Monat.
Haut rein.